aux yeux d'un certain nombre de mes
confrères est journaliste dans ces
groupes plutôt que pour le service
public ou dans des titres à
l'indépendance au blé sans doute moins
pur mais je considère avoir toujours eu
des conditions d'exercice satisfaisante
dans ses différents environnements avant
de répondre à vos questions je voulais
poser trois remarques préalables sur les
sujets qui nous occupe
la première porte sur mon légère
étonnement du format retenu pour nous
recevoir du choix que vous avez fait de
nous associer tous les trois alors que
nous avons des histoires d offre des
places très différentes pour ses chaînes
au sens de nos groupes respectifs pour
le dire en quelques mots bfmtv emploie
près de 300 journalistes si l'on
additionne les cdi les cdd les pigistes
qui contribuent à la chaîne ce qui fait
de cette rédaction des plus importantes
de france
nous produisons de l'information en
continu
nous produisons des informations
exclusives mais aussi d émission
politique en prime time du reportage des
formats longs et même des séries
documentaires
bfmtv dégagent les bénéfices c'est la
chaîne la plus puissante de son groupe
ça ne l'ont pas une chaîne adossé à un
autre ensemble plus solide c'est une
chaîne qui s'emploie proposer une
information fiable consolidé en laissant
place à tous les points de vue et si
j'insiste sur ce point c'est parce que
j'ai pu vérifier 4 une rédaction
bénéficiaires une rédaction nombreuses
une rédaction influente est un élément
fondateur pour travailler dans des
conditions sereines et pour peser dans
les décisions
la deuxième remarque et en cela je vais
parler au nom du groupe que je
représente il ya donc aujourd'hui un
projet de fusion cours entre tf1 et m6
et nous sommes très soucieux je suis
très soucieuse en tant que directrice de
la rédaction que l'union de ses forces
ne tourne pas à écraser plus petit
qu'elle est à dévorer une part trop
importante du paysage de l'information
du marché publicitaire et par là même
des recettes disponibles pour financer
l'activité des rédactions
très soucieuse donc l'offre alternative
à ces propositions existantes l'offre de
notre groupe qui s'est imposé ces vingt
dernières années ne sois pas entamée et
plus globalement que le pluralisme ne
soit pas entamée que toutes les
informations puissent être publiées sur
des supports divers la troisième
remarque enfin j'imagine que vous êtes
soucieux des sujets de concentration
parce que se pose aujourd'hui la
question de savoir quel encadrement
quelle nouvelle loi quelle quelle
qu'elles règlent réglementation peut
être nécessaire pour mieux contrôler ces
moments
mais je voulais dire qu'au fond le sujet
est aussi de savoir qui possède avec
quelles intentions et qu'il n'y a pas
seulement le sujet de la concentration
et je voulais dire aussi que stopper les
assauts de tel ou tel sur la liberté
éditoriale de ses journalistes ça n'est
pas seulement le fait d'une nouvelle loi
ça passe aussi par le fait d'exprimer
son mécontentement d'apporter son
soutien aux journalistes de temps et
créer un rapport de force d'utiliser les
moyens déjà disponible pour sanctionner
d'éventuelles fautes le respect des
conventions des chartes signées et
parfois même par le choix des milliards
auxquels on s'adresse voilà pour mon
état d'esprit ce que je voulais vous
dire en introduction je suis donc
disponible pour répondre à vos questions
moi tout d'abord je sais que ce n'est
pas exactement le coeur de nos travaux
mais permettez moi de saisir cette
occasion pour souligner l'attachement
que je porte aux journalistes un rôle
important qu'ils jouent pour la
démocratie pour la liberté d'opinion
face au poids croissant du complotisme
face aux multiplications des filles news
je suis persuadé qu'on est tous autour
de cette table attaché à l'indépendance
des journalistes et à ce qui fait la
noblesse de notre métier c'est à dire la
recherche des faits et des faits qui
doivent ensuite être mise en perspective
décrypter analyser portait lors de ce
débat contradictoire et argumenté ce
sont en tout cas les missions que nous
nous fixons au quotidien nice est elle
si vous avez eu l'amabilité de le
rappeler c'est une maison que je connais
très bien donc moi j'ai commencé en 2000
en stage et puis j'ai fait un petit peu
je passais un petit peu par tout
tous les postes d'abord assistant à la
pige comme com comme souvent dans ce
métier puis rédacteur et ensuite j'ai pu
passer au management avec mon poste de
rédacteur de rédacteur en chef et c'est
le j'ai connu aussi un moment où elle
était la première et la seule chaîne
info
du paf j'ai découvert comment
traiter l'information dans une chaîne
d'information en continu notamment au
moment des attentats du 11 septembre
c'était l'été c'était du le tout début
mais j'ai aussi connu
lci en difficulté lorsque le passage en
clair
semblait s'éloigner
tout ça pour dire que sur ces
au fil des ans donc c'est 21 ans dans la
même maison
j'ai appris sur le tas le métier de
journaliste parce qu'on m'a fait
confiance et j'ai appris la rigueur le
sérieux
g comment utiliser des outils pour
recueillir la formation pour pouvoir
la vérifier et en effet il ya un an et
demi j'ai eu la fierté de me voir
confier le poste de directeur de la
rédaction et c'est ce sont
ses méthodes de travail et c'est ses
intentions que j'ai c'est avant tout de
transmettre donc j'imagine qu'ici ce
sera surtout la façon dont on travaille
au quotidien qui vous qui vous
intéressent donc je vais aller dans le
dans le vif du sujet dans son propos
liminaire il faut savoir qu elle si
c'est une rédaction qui compte environ
130 cartes de presse une rédaction qui
est plutôt jeune à une moyenne et monia
d'âge
de de 40 ans et qui contribuent à
produire 18 heures de direct par jour
ces rédactions jeunes mais aussi fidèle
parce qu'en fait on a une ancienneté lci
qu' un peu plus de 2 10 ans
donc comment on travaille au quotidien
et bien on a on a un découpage par
tranches d'info avec des cellules
autonomes sur chaque tranche un étrange
d'infos de 3h02 de deux heures et ces
cellules sont portés en coulisses par un
rédacteur en chef adjoint et un chef
d'édition notamment et puis à l'antenne
par des journalistes exigent avant david
pujadas audel trièves darius rochebin
pas de citer pour ne citer qu'eux mais
sûr sûr sûr chaque tranche
les porteurs de strange ou évidemment un
rôle très important et ce sont ces
cellules qui conçoit chaque jour leur
émission on définisse des angles cas le
enfin
challenge des invités moi je pour cette
audition je me suis amusé à affronter
c'est assez vertigineux lci on reçoit
chaque année près de 5000 invités donc
c'est quand même voilà c'est quand même
à chiffa c'est vertigineux
les politiques des médecins des
scientifiques des experts la société
civile des grands patrons et c'est
donc la réflexion éditoriale est un
vraiment des tranches infos parce que ça
permet à chaque tranche info d'avoir sa
propre liberté sont sa propre identité
son ton propre 1 derrière ce 3 juin va
pas de traiter l'actualité exactement
comme un comme un david pujadas et puis
on a évidemment des points de rencontre
les plus importants c'est évidemment les
conférences de rédaction porté par le
rédacteur en chef et ses points de
rencontre on vont dans mon challenge en
tire les angles voilà on partage on
échange nous on a de co2 confins de
conférences de rédaction
quotidienne j'ajoute que face au
développement des faits que nous aider
et notamment sur les réseaux sociaux du
complotisme on a développé aussi une
sorte de label d'infos vérifier un peu
plus de deux ans
et on a une trentaine de journalistes
qui ont été vraiment former aux outils
de vérification d'infos notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux comment on détecte
l'effectif aux et ses terrains
voilà ça nous a par exemple permis
de mettre en place je sais pas si vous
avez l'occasion de le voir mais l'or
lors des débats qu'on a pu mettre en
place pour europe ecologie les verts et
pour le débat des républicains
une vérification en direct via un qr
code et les téléspectateurs pouvaient
scanner ce qr code pour avoir toute une
information source et par rapport aux
propos de tel ou tel candidat on a été
aussi les premiers à lancer une émission
totalement dédié à la lutte contre le
complotisme qu'ils appellent un
basiquement anti complot portées par
bénédicte le chatelier et thomas font un
expert en la matière parce que voilà on
pensait qu'il y ait un effort à faire
dans cette lutte contre les faits que
news
voilà pour conclure si souhaite offrir
aux téléspectateurs c'est là justement
une information qui se veut qui se veut
indépendante et rigoureuse
sérieuses et c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'on a
pu observer nous demandant une enquête
dans une enquête interne chance sur un
panel
assez large que les items qui ressortait
quand on demandait comment comment les
téléspectateurs effet les français dans
leur ensemble voyez lci c'était une
belle cité perçue comme une chaîne de
qualité une chaîne variée et diversifiée
et une chaîne une chaîne de confiance
c'est pas la première fois que j'ai
l'occasion d'être auditionné par le
sénat je suis honorée pour aujourd'hui
participer modestement à vos réflexions
et travaux qui étaient mes confrères
pour me présenter sur la liste depuis 25
ans j'ai eu trois moments dans ma
carrière un moment qui concerne le
cinéma la culture à canal+ aux journées
du cinéma à l'agencé capa puis à
éléphant et compagnie avec anne sinclair
pour france 3 ensuite j'ai eu un moment
politique où j'étais grand reporter et
conquêtes heures avec que john paul
lepers pour canal+ via la société
production au 17 juin puis dimanche +
qui était présenté à l'époque par
laurence ferrari pour canal et qui a été
produit par l'agencé capa puis le
troisième moment est un moment news j'ai
eu l'honneur d'être recruté par céline
clients qui a appelé à l'époque dirigé
les télévisions comme rédacteur en chef
adjoint
notamment de l'après matinale j'ai fait
un léger crochet par ici où j'ai
rencontré bastien bond à 6 puis j'ai
rejoint
i télé encore i télé pour rejoindre le
projet de transformation de itélé ans et
news comme rédacteur en chef d'abord
puis comme directeur de l'information en
tant que directeur de l'information mon
rôle et lequel bon il s'agit de
superviser le traitement de lecture en
toutes nos éditions dans toutes nos
tranche et particulièrement de
superviser l'articulation entre la
tunisie et les débats d'actu
jeux organise donc au mieux la
couverture quotidienne de l'actualité
générale la politique économique sociale
sociétale mais aussi du rock muse en cas
de ce qu'on appelle deux breaks info
c'est nous c'est une chaîne qui a revu
son modèle pour s'inscrire durablement
dans le paysage français avec une
rédaction de talent et soucieuse de
diversité et je veux rendre hommage le
travail considérable de cette rédaction
qui n'est pas la plus nombreuse nous
sommes 120 cartes de presse
avec université femmes aux hommes une
diversité de journalistes et au talent
des talents que vous connaissez parfois
les plus connus laurence ferrari sonia
mabrouk vous connaissez ici au sénat
ainsi que jean pierre elkabbach mais
aussi pascal praud ou christine kelly
est une chaîne qui fonctionne avec un
modèle d'utilisation d'intervenants de
laurent joffrin à charles dans les as de
jean claude dassier à julien dray
d'elisabeth lévy olivier dartigolles je
ne peux que me réjouir du succès
d'audience de ces news qui démontre donc
la reconnaissance du traitement de
l'information par la chaîne auprès des
français nous avons fait une montée
spectaculaire d'audience en un an et
nous sommes devenus la deuxième chaîne
d'information de france et la nouvelle
référence en la matière mais je voulais
vous faire cette remarque cnued reste
une source d'accès à l'information
mineur par rapport à d'autres lecteurs
d'abord ces news n'est pas la seule
chaîne d'information du groupe canal+
qui distribue l'ensemble des chaînes
d'information en continu et des chaînes
généralistes notamment lci bfm ou cnn
sont distribués disponible sur my canal
surtout ses news contrairement à tf1
c'est un luxe n ma formation au sein
d'un groupe de contenu lobo et généraux
de contenu de cinéma de sport de série
de flux etc
ces news participe au pluralisme de
l'information caractérisée en france par
l'ats l'existence de quatre voire cinq
chaînes d'info en continu en clair ce
qui est une situation inédite en europe
et il faut savoir qu'en france l'accès à
l'information se fait même s'il se fait
principalement par la télévision et il
se fait à travers les chaînes de tv
généraliste généralement et seulement
pour 16% pour les chaînes d'info ce qui
est en stabilité si on en croit le
rapport le baromètre lacroix kantar
public de 2021 la
télévision ces nouvelles d'accès parmi
d'autres les autres voient l'accès à
l'information historique selon la radio
et la presse ces nouvelles accès il est
concurrencé aujourd'hui largement par
internet
est concurrencés par les smartphones il
faut quand même savoir que les plus
jeunes les moins de 35 ans affichent
clairement leur préférence pour interner
de 66% par rapport à la télé 26% et les
chaînes d'info 13% ceci pour remettre
ces news les chaînes info laissez nous
particulièrement dans le comment dire
dans le mapping globale de l'information
actuelle en france
pour autant malgré ce report
tendancielle de la conso de
l'information ces news ne faillit pas
dans ses missions et astucieuse de
respecter dans le cadre normatif
nationale dans lequel elles s'inscrivent
son occupation de la fréquence nationale
des règles qui sont fixées par la loi et
le régulateur dont le cadre de ces
conventions et que nous respectons et je
me tiens naturellement à notre
disposition pour répondre avec plus de
précision à vos questions merci merci
les
rapporteurs qui va commencer cette
question merci d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
jeu c'est vrai que le format
peut peut être discutée mais il n'y a
pas de problème parce que si on
considère vous nous d'ailleurs qu' il ya
besoin en me to be on va dire
d'approfondir certaines questions nous
sommes ouverts mais deux nous avons
voulu à dans cette première phase de nos
travaux essayez de voir le maximum de
d'intervenants pour justement ensuite
même construire la suite de ce que nous
allons auditionner au mois de janvier et
février et ses petits formats ou
ceux qui font le même boulot le même
métier on va dire sont soumis au forum
et est tout à fait intéressant quand
même donc
le sujet de notre commission denquête et
bien
la concentration dans les médias et les
problèmes que ça peut poser dans
l'exercice de la démocratie
donc vous avez des fois exposé ce que
vous faites
mais c'est pas trop de sujets le sujet
est beaucoup plus
votre questionnement les problématiques
qui se posent entre ce que vous faites
la production d'information la direction
de rédaction et le phénomène des
concentrations dans notre pays il se
trouve que vos trois rédactions bon si
on regarde où quand même l'info continue
aujourd'hui après une place très
importante dans les annales
l'information pour les citoyens et la
formation même de l'opinion et vous étés
prendre ces prochaines heures hors
service les trois chaînes hors service
public d'information et les trois ont la
particularité
pour lci avec thé afin d'être adossé un
groupe
puissant avec un actionnaire puissant
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs dont le métier
n'est pas le domaine des médias bouygues
pour vous qui est partie d'un groupe de
presse avec monsieur veille qui étaient
concentrées sur la presse
et notamment la radio et la télé avec le
rachat par monsieur draghi est aussi
d'autres ados c'est un grand dont le
métier principal n'était pas
l'information mais plutôt la téléphonie
etc et puis de la même façon ces news
vous est adossée à un groupe
vivendi avec monsieur bolloré
dont le métier principal n'est pas
l'information dit les médias mais qui a
donc plusieurs chaînes et maintenant
journaux voire même dans l'édition dvd
des achats et donc c'est bien là dessus
que je veux vous à tanger et qu'on est
intéressé
la première question qui nous vient si
on veut pas être dans la langue de bois
c est ce que dans l'exercice vote
exercés de votre métier à vous qui êtes
journaliste qui est producteur
d'information est ce que le le vous
pouvez nous assuré
prendre après l'autre que
vous n'avez jamais subi d'intervention
pour que des informations de soit pas
traité outre été d'une certaine façon
selon la volonté de l'actionnaire
principal qui possède votre média je
pose pouvez vous nous assurez c'est bien
la question qu'il n'ya pas votre
connaissance ce n'est pas ça n'a pas
existé pendant l'exercice de vos
fonctions d'une autre
monsieur morassi
alors oui moi je vous l'assuré je n'ai
subi aucune aucune intervention de
l'actionnaire aucune
aucune d'eric cision pour que ya pas de
malentendu peut toujours pas effleuré
mots de l'actionnaire directement ou
alors par le biais de votre patron de
votre mac auraient dg de votre média
alors ça ne change pas ma réponse mais
j'ai pas le reçu de directives
particulières de manière directe ou
indirecte
nous on j'ai rappelé comment se fabrique
un l'information même si j'aime pas
tellement cette formule fabrique de
l'information et comment on consommer
l'information
et comment comment comment on
travaillait et il n'y a pas deux il n'y
a pas d'intervention et
il n'y a pas de tabou dont les sujets
que l'on traitait d'ailleurs si on
permettait ce que j'ai écouté avec
attention les les précédentes tableau où
on est on parler par exemple de la 5g
vous avez pu évoquer je suis un puck il
était un interlocuteur mais évoquer la
la salle g en disant qu' on a émis sous
le tapis et qu'on l'avait pas traiter
donc moi je vous le dis ici en tout cas
pour ce qui concerne lci c'est faux nous
on a traité la singer sur notre antenne
on en a fait des sujets on en a fait des
débuts et on en a même fait notamment
chez david pujadas qui est l'émission
que phare de lci c'est notre pic
d'audience donc on n'a vraiment pas
caché sous le tapis en faisant une
émission à trois heures du matin c'était
dans notre émission c'est notamment dans
notre émission phare donc on l'a traité
quand la 5g cet invité évidemment dans
le débat politique
on a abordé cette seule question qui a
pas de volonté de vouloir cacher telle
ou telle actualité en se disant que
voilà pour une intervention directe ça
pourrait gêner untel ou untel et puis
pour prendre
un autre exemple plus récent sur sur le
rachat de 10 commence par par bouygues
on l'a traité évident sur notre antenne
comme comme comme sur les antennes
concurrentes dans nos pages économie
parce que parce que c'était c'était
c'était l'actualité on n'a pas traité ni
plus ni plus ni moins et puis je note
que que olivier roussat le
le pdg de pluie est venue présenter ce
rachat non pas sur sur une chaîne tels
que lci ou une chaîne du groupe mais sur
une chaîne concurrente je crois que
c'était c'était c'était bfm business
donc aucune aucune directive aucune
intervention directe ou indirecte est je
pense un traitement
un traitement de l'actualité qui
pourrait toucher le groupe
en tout en toute indépendance
je pense ya énormément de fantasmes
autour de ce sujet et que ce que j'ai
essayé de dire c'est que dans mon propos
liminaire c'est que on travaille
beaucoup mieux dans les groupes privés
que ce qu'on veut dire ça c'est la
première chose
je n'ai jamais reçu personnellement de
directives spécifiques de l'actionnaire
est pas non plus d'un éventuel directeur
directeur général
je pense que les choses quand parfois
elles peuvent être plus compliquées sont
plus subtiles que ce qu'on imagine et
j'entendais un précédent interlocuteurs
de cette commission dire il faut qu'on
puisse dire du mal du rafale dans le
figaro au fond on est précisément sur le
sujet évoqué ici
je crois qu'il faut surtout qu'on puisse
écrire sur le rafale dans un espace
pluriel où tout peut être dit est-ce
qu'il est absolument nécessaire que ce
soit le figaro qui s'en charge est ce
que les journalistes du figaro seront
parfaitement
confortable pour le faire
au fond quoique vous fassiez sur ce
sujet en étant journaliste du figaro on
le lira toujours avec un regard
suspicieux pour le mois et donc c'est
pour ça que le vrai sujet le sujet
essentiel c'est d'avoir des titres
indépendants ils sont capables de faire
émerger certaines informations d'avoir
différents groupes de presse pour cela
parfois plus puissant que certains
groupes indépendants et que ces choses
là puissent circuler au point que
peut-être un certain nombre de choses
finissent par être écrite y compris dans
un journal qui en première intention
n'avait pas n'avait pas forcément une
envie massive de de s'en saisir et à mon
avis c'est plutôt sain notre sujet et
notre enjeu
pour le reste comme j'ai eu l'occasion
de le dire
moi j'ai reçu une fois dans le groupe
pro j'ai ensuite quitté une demande
formelle pour traiter un sujet qui de
mon point de vue n'avait aucun sens sur
l'antenne d'i télé peut toujours dire
non dans la période où je où je
travaillais à i télé sur la toute fin de
mon parcours il m'était demandé de
rendre compte des activités des salles
de spectacles type olympia qui devait se
développer en afrique c'est vrai que ça
me paraissait pas être directement le
sujet de mon antenne voilà il ya
beaucoup de fantasmes et
particulièrement sur chez nous à ses
news
n'a pas besoin d'être grand clerc pour
effectivement quand je croise quelqu'un
nbim alors est ce que vincent bolloré tu
appelles tous les jours non je n'ai
jamais il appelle de vincent bolloré de
qui que ce soit pour me dire ce qu'il
fallait faire à l'antenne de seignosse
j'ai vu vincent bolloré six mois avant
d'être embauchée je les croisais un jour
une passe est présenté ses voeux à
l'ensemble des salariés du groupe
et c'est tout et je n'ai jamais eu de
demande spécifique directe indirecte de
traiter ou de ne pas traiter de
l'information donc ensuite on traite les
informations c'est vrai que les ma
responsabilité la responsabilité du
directeur de la rédaction de savoir
comment et quelle importance on donne
une information bien entendu ça va du
monde aux aubrais keynews
donc parfois les informations sont au
bandeau parfois ils ont embrayé de news
parfois on les traite dans une émission
de débats parfois on les traîne dans les
jt
voilà donc tourner en rond là comme ça
une palette de
de traitement de lecture qui nous permet
de faire nos choix éditoriaux comme le
ferait un titre de presse écrite qui
choisit de faire une brève ou une
met donc voilà je n'ai jamais eu de
demande du groupe canal+ de qui que ce
soit de traiter d'une actualité
particulière ou au contraire de ne pas
traiter d'une actualité particulière
comment s'exerce je reviendrai à entre
vos réponses parce que j'ai quand même
quelques exemples assez précis donc je
veux j'aimerais vraiment avoir vos
réactions mais une question qu plus
générale comment l'indépendance de vos
rédactions et elle garantit vis-à-vis de
vos actionnaires qu il ya des choses qui
sont mises en place dans toute la
rédaction pouvez vous nous les décrire
rapidement
et
si vous avez une opinion sur
une proposition qui circulent pour aller
plus loin dans le fait de pouvoir
laisser des grands groupes prospérer
tout en protégeant les rédactions de
deux aces qui est ce que vous que pensez
vous d'un statut juridique des
rédactions par rapport à tous ces
phénomènes de concentration
donc la première question c'est vraiment
ce qui est mis en place pour assurer
l'indépendance de vos rédactions et et
lors le donc nous sommes soumis et nous
respectons la loi bloche nous avons donc
une charte qui a été signé entre le
groupe et la société des rédacteurs de
ses news
cette société des rédacteurs se réunit
mensuellement avec moi-même et directeur
de la rédaction et
et nous échangeons sur le traitement de
l'actualité sur les difficultés ou les
interrogations que va voir les
journalistes
et ce travail se fait donc de façon
continue et régulière et
exigeante par ailleurs nous avons au
sein du bon canal + un comité d'éthique
comité d'éthique qui nous dira le parc
il est ou de clients composé il y a
monsieur je voudrais pas encore c'est
son prénom et monsieur michel notamment
qui est celui que j'ai rencontré du
comité d'éthique richard michel et jean
michel
et qui nous a comment dire qu'il nous a
fait deux recommandations principales
notamment concernant l'émission face à
l'info
de faire cette émission en léger différé
afin de
d'augmenter notre capacité à contrôler
les propos qui pourraient ne pas être
diffusable
voit la chose que nous avons faite et et
qui nous a alertés sur le traitement que
l'on faisait au début de la période des
gilet jaune et qui nous a permis de
faire qu'il nous a fait comment dire
pour parler un peu vulgaire ans et dans
notre jargon baisser la voilure sur sur
les germes cieux nous avions avec nos
confrères une tendance naturelle peut
être un peu fâcheuse à relayer
systématiquement les images
dès samedi de manifestations et de façon
un peu non filtrée et le comité
d'éthique nous a alertés en disant qu'on
leur faisait
confuse et bien de travail mais qu' on
pouvait effectivement prendre un peu de
recul un peu plus de recul donc voilà
les les la structure qui est mise en
place à l'intérieur du groupe canal+
mais je pense que c'est la même chez mes
confrères oui nous avons nous également
les mêmes les mêmes dispositions suite à
la loi bloch comité
d'une charte de déontologie qui
évidemment signé dès que dès qu'un
un journaliste rejoint rejoint m6 c'est
un excellent à sont contraints un comité
d'éthique
également il ya évidemment dans le
groupe nous avons deux sdj une sdj
propres a ici une sdj
propre à tf1 dans cette danse est s2j et
deux essais on elle est composée
notamment de nombreux journalistes
politiques l'adn de essayé et un petit
peu plus sur l'information politique que
que nos concurrents
mais eux
et voilà on a cet ensemble de deux
dispositifs qui sont mis en place mais
on a également mené en m'y attache une
importance particulière
des partenariats avec avec des des
instituts de formation de journalistes
on a mis en place le prix bourrin aussi
pour pour encourager ça on a une mission
de séoul et d'éducation à l'information
avec avec la fondation tf1 également
donc on a à la fois
civile et des dispositifs
qui accompagnent les journalistes mais
on a aussi un tout un travail en amont
et on y tient beaucoup
d'amour je vais pas revenir sur le fait
que nous avons une vigie très active
avec laquelle nous rencontrons
régulièrement soit sur des rendez-vous
qui sont au calendrier soit sur des
moments particuliers de l'actualité où
ils nous sollicitent il ya aussi un
comité d'éthique en gros quand j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire je pense que la
principale force d'une rédaction c'est
sa solidité c'est son ombre c'est sa
capacité à produire de l'information à
être reconnus comme tels et au fond
cette reconnaissance là elle elle
devrait valoir en tout cas pour partie
protection elle devrait aussi permettre
de s'exprimer en tant que cette
réduction est de faire savoir s'il y
avait s'il y avait des difficultés
et en revanche jeu
de ce que vous proposiez d'additionner
sur la notion d'un statut juridique
particulier pour les rédactions et en
effet
un élément sur lequel on peut on peut
réfléchir et travailler
oui alors je reviens à tout à l'heure
madame c'est une pigalle
gg j'avais été marqué à l'époque sur
france culture stéphane soumier qui
était ex directeur de la rédaction de
bfm business
avait
raconté
la difficulté de traiter les sujets
business depuis que c'était patrick
drahi qui était à la tête avait racheté
disais avant y avait nos problèmes et
depuis c'est très difficile
pouvez vous nous dire pourquoi il a pu
dire ça
peut-être pour commencer parce qu'il a
quitté le groove et qu' il avait
peut-être des raisons que je ne connais
pas
il faut dire comme bfm business est une
chaîne différente de bfm tv que les
enjeux business sont traités de façon
beaucoup plus approfondie que ce qu'on
pourrait faire sur bfm tv on est une
chaîne généraliste
et donc
il parle de sujets que peut-être je n'ai
pas eu à traiter mais pour commencer sur
ce qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure on a
évidemment fait des sujets sur la 5g on
avis dont on fait des sujets sur ceux
qui s'inquiète de ses effets on a
évidemment fait des sujets sur les
questions de l'accès
de façon générale au réseau voilà et
donc
non je ne peux pas vous dire
que j'aie jamais été confronté à une
difficulté sur ce sujet ce qui peut
exister peut-être c'est que d'aucuns
c'était l'esprit de ce que j'exprimais
ce ne souhaite pas particulièrement
s'engager sur certains sujets pour pas
se trouver en difficulté ça ça doit
exister c'est à dire vous vous nous
dites de façon plus claire c'est que
vous pratiquez nanteau censure c'est
certainement parce que je dis je dis que
en l'occurrence dans la citation que
vous rapportez c'était peut-être ceux
dont stéphane soumier lui se faisait le
relais moi je sais pas j'ai pas cette
difficulté encore une fois il parle
d'enjeux un business qui sont pas
directement les considérations de bfm tv
donc je ne sais pas quelle difficulté il
dit avoir rencontré pour m'avoir pour ce
qui concerne les sujets grand public la
téléphonie et vous pourrez le vérifier
ces sujets sont largement évoqué sur bfm
tv sans difficulté
il ya eu monsieur tu aurais body
bonnaire parlons
on a déjà eu à auditionner monsieur
bolloré dans un autre cadre plusieurs
années et
c'était un moment un peu particulier
puisque c'est le passage d'itélé à ces
news et il y avait une charrette assez
importante de gens des marques est
d'abord à canal au présentateur les
guignols externe et ensuite dans la
rédaction c'était plus de 100
journalistes quand même
et
aujourd'hui
il y a de même type de phénomène quand
monsieur bolloré va
prendre rampante
encore une soixantaine je crois de
journalistes
est-ce que vous
comment vous vivez ça c'est à dire
est-ce qu'il faut avoir un certain
format penser
comme ci ou comme ça pour pouvoir être
journaliste à ses news les formats
agricole vous allusion je ne crois pas
l'adresse que est ce que il faut penser
comme ci ou comme ça pour être
aujourd'hui et ça c'est nous
absolument pas nous avons une relation
diverses riche et vivant une plus petite
rédaction la rédaction que dirige céline
il ya 350 hommes jean la liste
300 beaucoup plus petit que le pôle info
du groupe tf1 qui dit si je ne m'abuse
et aux alentours de 400 journalistes
nous nous sommes 120 journalistes avec
une diversité
et une répartition paritaire
hommes-femmes
une réaction assez jeune
et une diversité
d'origines sociales ou culturelles
le peu de gens peuvent imaginer
forcément
parfois il peut il peut être aisé de
faire le raccourci est de coller à la
rédaction de ses news
l'image de certains des chroniqueurs ou
des intervenant à l'antenne de ces news
mais ce n'est absolument pas le cas
donc il ne faut pas avoir de format il
ne faut pas être telle ou telle ou
pensée telle ou telle chose les les
opinions et les avis à l'intérieur et
d'actions de ses new sont diverses je
pense
conforme aux spectres et à l'état des
forces politiques et idéologiques dans
le pays avec des gens qui sont plutôt
d'un board plutôt de l'autre mais je ne
le sais pas ce sont des journalistes
voyez je ne sais pas pour qui les gens
votent
les expriment des points de vue de
journalistes professionnels et c'est
tout ce que je leur demande donc on est
divers il n'y a pas besoin d'être tel ou
tel pour travailler à ses news et pour
europe 1
je ne dirige pas la rédaction d'europe 1
donc je me garderai bien de répondre
encore une question qui est clé
vous rapport notamment à la formation et
à la régulation du csa futur art comme
vous avez
à plusieurs reprises reçu des des
mises en demeure
des remontrances des sanctions
pour l'expression
passionné
dans certaines émissions
d'expression raciste
par exemple et puis dernièrement pour
avoir contrevenu à
l'expression pluraliste des les partis
politiques
reléguant contournant les règles puisque
vous réveiller la nuit un certain nombre
de partis politiques et d'autres qui y
était le jour donc
que que je me dit vous par rapport
à ces cette particularité de casser news
de contrevenir aux règles qui sont
celles que contrôle le csa
donc vous faites monsieur le rapporteur
allusion à date de à deux choses donc
différentes d'abord il ya la prise de
parole d'un chroniqueur qui a été
sanctionné et cette sanction est
contestée devant le conseil d'état
puisque christine kelly selon nous a
fait son tronçon travail de journaliste
et de modératrice et 2
l'animatrice de cette tranche en
intervenant plus de neuf fois pour front
d'eric zemmour donc ce dossier est
devant le conseil d'état je vois là je
suis pas juriste je laisse la procédure
suivre son cours en ce qui concerne les
temps de parole ils seront comptabilisés
au 31 décembre et nous serons au rendez
vous je dois vous avouer coup nous
sommes surpris d'être les seuls à faire
l'objet d'une mise en demeure préventive
nous avons des relations régulières avec
le csa enfin moi à titre personnel mais
les personnes qui s'occupent au service
juridique des décomptes des temps de
parole et effectivement nous sommes
régulièrement
nous pouvons être régulièrement alertés
sur les déséquilibres qu'ils peuvent un
clip qui pourraient exister du fait
d'une actualité
concernant un parti politique ou
l'expression de personnes un peu de
personnalité politique est effectivement
bien entendu nous nous revenons
généralement dans les clous très très
vite un exemple tout simple c'est vrai
que l'actualité politique récente était
plutôt à droite
effectivement il y avait beaucoup
d'intervenants à droite de temps de
parole à droite ok il y a deux jours une
candidate du parti socialiste à
illies le souhait d'organiser une
primaire à gauche et à relancer si je
puis dire l'actualité à gauche
d'actualité à gauche c'était un peu
atone nous avons invité ce matin
j'imagine que vous regardez la matinale
ses news la vice présidente la suisse
crée ces gens je peux vous dire
personnellement que je pense pas que
regarder
regardez je vous invite à regarder vous
y verriez notamment ce matin alice
présidente
dé sénatrice ps madame rossignol donc
vous voyez qu'on il ya un mouvement de
balancier c'est à dire c'est pas
les les périodes sont sont longues et
c'est vrai que
voilà que que nous faisons tout pour les
pour les équilibres et sur le temps de
parole de nuit vous avez raison c'est
comment dire transparents vis à vis du
csa c'est à dire que le temps de parole
de nuit c'est pas un temps de parole
caché puisqu'il est sur une diffusion
ouvert donc il n'est pas avéré c'est
transparent qui avait dû ces salles de
ces salles c c'est réglementaire mais
qu'on ferait enfin un truc à l'ailé les
autres chaînes d'info le fond c'est vrai
qui a pu avoir comment dire est une
sorte d'exception par souci de bien
faire et de rattraper du temps de parole
nous avons un objectif que nous
tiendrons le 31 au 31 décembre de
l'inversé la proportion entre le temps
de parole en journée et le temps de
parole hans ou ennui
sachant que nous avons deux deux
objectifs c'est cet équilibre jour/nuit
et l' équilibre parti politique exécutif
puisque comme vous le savez peut-être du
coin à chaque fois que nous avons on va
dire 3 3 minutes de temps de parole
d'une représentation politique nous
devons accorder une minute de temps de
parole à l'exécutif et lorsque nous
accordons une minute de temps de parole
à l'exécutive nous devons accorder trois
minutes de temps de parole aux
différents courants politiques dans le
respect des différents
des différents commentaires des
différentes proportions j'ai là les
chiffres de ce matin et qui m'ont été
remis
donc le tiers pour l'exécutif nous y
sommes ce matin nous étions à 32 67
enfin et c'est nous sommes dans les
clous
oui je l'imaginais que vous me poseriez
la question donc j'ai vérifié déjà
vérifié les chiffres et
en ce qui concerne la droite tous les
divers droite nous sommes exactement
dans les proportions dans les clous
fixés fixé par le csa et bien sûr le
décompte des temps de parole fait fait
l'objet d'un dut d'un échange et d'un
dialogue avec avec le régulateur
l'intervention hier du président de la
république n'est pas considéré dans sa
majeure partie comme un temps de parole
exécutif puisqu'il parlait de choses
enfin de deux thèmes régalien supra
nationaux et donc leurs ennemis de
l'intervention du président de la
république ne comptera pas pour le temps
de parole exécutif mais ça ce n'est
qu'après qu'on peut le savoir là j'ai
répondu monsieur la porter à votre
question
j'aurais monnaie
merci président
bonjour messieurs dames pour un peu je
prendrai ma zapette pour voir passer
d'une chaîne à l'autre mais nous avons
des écrans noirs sous sous vos personnes
vous l'avez rappelé de façon assez
groupe est consensuel sur le fait que
vous aviez je reprends votre expression
et dans pigalle des conditions
d'exercice satisfaisantes au niveau
professionnel
vous avez également
attesté du pluralisme avec vos mots du
pluralisme des rédactions et
marc olivier maistre est venu lui même
il ya 48 heures devant la devant cette
commission denquête dire que en fait il
n'y a jamais eu autant de pluralisme si
on considère l'évolution des choses ne
pensez vous pas qu aujourd'hui plutôt
que de s'obstiner à parler de
concentration parce qu'on en parle de
façon constante depuis un bon moment
j'ai sous les yeux le rapport lancelot
2005 il ne faudrait pas plutôt
considérer
la question économique et les rôles de
l'affluence dans cette économie puisque
derrière ça on l'a vu dans derrière les
trois épouvantails vie ont été nommés à
chaque commission il se passe alors là
ça a été en plus dans l'audition
précédentes ça a été très rapide où on
voit tout de suite on entend parler de
monsieur drive monsieur niestlé monsieur
bolloré
est ce que justement dans cette
recherche d' influence parce qu'on ne
parle pas d'autre chose que d'un flux
ans qui passe par une économie et qui
passe aussi par le fait qu'aujourd'hui
tout ça est lié et très lié aux télécoms
notamment et au contenu qui passe dans
ces télécom est ce que vous pensez pas
que la cible de notre commission
denquête ne devrait pas être plutôt la
régulation de l' influence en plus tôt
que la concentration des médias
les deux sujets s'additionnent
se complètent on peut avoir une grande
influence avec un média modeste
si par ailleurs il y a des positions
très fortes qui décide ou non de les
relayer ça va être un dangereux donc oui
enfin pour moi on peut pas complètement
désolidarisé ces deux questions pour
vous donner une idée on a calculé que
sur le futur groupe tf1 m6 on allait
arriver à une part de marché sur la
tranche info de la mi-journée de 62%
peut toujours dire il se passe d'autres
choses par ailleurs sur les réseaux sur
internet et ainsi de suite enfin on
arrive quand même à des niveaux qui sont
problématiques d'autant que france tv
elle a même fait 34 % et qu'il reste
donc pour les autres 3% voyez un moment
l'influent c'est un sujet l'influent
c'est indéniablement un enjeu est
certainement une nouvelle manière de
lire le paysage puisqu'on peut désormais
avoir une très grande influence quoique
n'ayant pas un poids considérable mais
plus il va y avoir des acteurs d'un
poids considérable plus ils seront
tentés de ne pas laisser vivre ce qu'ils
font émerger des choses de manière
indépendante donc voilà ces deux sujets
sont sont liés et complémentaires - la
question des influences ça c'est plus
une question de
deux stratégies et donc ça c'est pas
c'est pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment
mon domaine en revanche
le fait d'être adossé
adossée à un groupe
e
pour le cas de lci
a plutôt des avantages et ses avantages
s'il y en a un qui est qui et qui est à
retenir c'est notamment lors de la lors
de la crise sanitaire
le message le message très fort envoyé
par le groupe qu'il n'y aurait pas
de licenciement et que l'offre dafoe
serait maintenue sur l'antenne sur
l'antenne de lci comme pourrait
continuer a justement surtout dans cette
danse est
cette crise sanitaire cette épreuve
difficile à informer le public à faire
passer les messages
les conférences de presse des autorités
sanitaires et est aussi également les
spots gouvernementaux
d'information l'autre avantage c'est eux
c'est que
une information
sérieuse vérifier
sas a un coût et que être adossé un
également
un groupe un groupe puissant pour
justement
c'est un peu ma marotte mais moi j'y
tiens beaucoup lutté contre les faits qu
aux miens c'est important également
voilà d'avoir
d'abord d'être adossé d'être adossé à un
groupe
celi robert gomes monsieur le président
merci messieurs merci madame pour vos
propos moi je vais aller sur la
fabrication de l'information n'aimait
pas beaucoup ce mot mais je vais je vais
le reprendre et madame vous êtes vice
président de l'ess j je crois à lille
vos parcours nous démontrer que vous
avez une forme de distance et puis dans
la diversification de vos expériences
professionnelles est intéressant d'avoir
votre regard sur ce sujet est ce que ces
dernières années parce qu'il ya des
enjeux économiques
il ya des enjeux liés à la modification
aussi des usages
notamment des jeunes mais pas seulement
lié aussi à la présence des plateformes
et du numérique
est ce que vous observez une évolution
réelle dans la fabrication de
l'information
ce que derrière c'est la fabrication de
l'information c'est aussi derrière la
qualité de l'information le traitement
de l'information le fait qu'on met deux
journalistes au lieu en lieu au lieu
d'un parce que on est que sur du
commentaire ou alors parce que la
rapidité aujourd'hui de notre société ça
c'est des phénomènes font qu'il faut
réagir quand on est dans le souvent ce
traitement du temps est ce que vous
observez cela est ce que vous êtes
satisfait de ces évolutions et est ce
que un moment
finalement le contexte de notre société
d'aujourd'hui et son évolution
vous feront dire que ben il faut
peut-être peut-être changer un peu de
braquet parce que derrière il ya aussi
la question de la méfiance de nos
concitoyens dans la formation il ya un
vrai sujet aujourd'hui sur sur ces
questions des médias donc j'aimerais
avoir votre point de vue sur sur cela en
fait il n'y a pas d'évolution dans
fabrication d'un faux seins mais moi
j'aimerais quand même avoir votre votre
pointure merci beaucoup moi d'abord je
déteste pas ce terme de fabrication d'un
faux même si je sais ce qu'on peut
mettre dedans quand on connotation mais
finalement fait journal c'est un petit
métier d'artisan et de se prendre vilain
il n'a pas tellement changé
c'est à dire que on voit des moyens
techniques nouveaux et importants qui
font que ça masque le fait que le
travail lui-même strictement le même il
consiste à se rendre sur place et il
consiste à parler à ceux qui savent en
recoupant ceux qui savent et de ce point
de vue là les choses ne changent pas du
tout autant que ce qu'on peut dire en
revanche en effet il y a deux sujets il
y a la rapidité du monde pas la rapidité
des chaînes info comme on a tendance à
le croire mais la rapidité du monde et
des moyens techniques à notre
disposition qui nous permettent de voir
ce qui se passe à l'autre bout du monde
en temps réel et qui nous demande donc
de prendre en charge un certain nombre
de choses qu'on n'avait pas à prendre en
charge et surtout pas dans cette dans
cette rapidité et donc pour cette raison
même vous avez raison de le dire pour
faire du journalisme il faut des
journalistes il faut des journalistes
nombreux il faut des journalistes qui
sont capables d'aller là où ça se passe
il faut des journalistes qui sont
capables de parler à ceux qui sont
susceptibles de leur donner ces
informations
ça veut dire aussi qu'il faut des
journalistes qui entretiennent des liens
1 à une discussion avec différents
interlocuteurs qui eux mêmes ont
confiance dans le fait que leurs paroles
sera justement restituer
et donc la question du modèle économique
est évidemment une question fondamentale
et son micro monsieur coderre
au cours de mes 25 ans de carrière j'ai
vu effectivement évolué le la
fabrication de l'information
j'ai connu
lors de contrats pour france télévisions
l'époque où on partait en tournage avec
un rédacteur un caméraman un
éclairagiste un ingénieur du son un
stagiaire et un assistant une équipe de
avec une pause à 13 heures même si
l'interview avait lieu pour la pause
sandwich
j'ai connu aussi et j'ai initié moi même
pour france télévision pour france 3 à
l'époque où j'étais grand reporter dans
une émission qui était produit par
rachel kahn
qui s'appelait avant-première g j'ai moi
même tourné mes propres reportages avec
un iphone 5 à l'époque un smartphone
qui me permettait d'être beaucoup plus
agile qui me permettait d'écrire
différemment mes reportages et qui me
donnait plus de souplesse plus de
réactivité
en fait il y existe toujours des équipes
lourde entre guillemets ou nombreux de
télévision on peut pas organiser un
débat politique avec trois iphone c'est
faux il nous faut des moyens techniques
une régie beaucoup de caméras des décors
un savoir faire qui existent et qui qui
se maintient à l'intérieur des groupes
comme le nôtre
le groupe canal+
mais il faut pouvoir aussi effectivement
bénéficier des avancées technologiques
pour que le journaliste qui doit pouvoir
être le plus réactif possible puisse
être autonome dans cette fabrication le
plus possible et puis ce faire son
métier le plus rapidement possible quand
je dis rapidement c'est pas maintenant
pour juste après mais c'est sans avoir
besoin de subir une commande irène
infrastructures une super structure un
peu lourde
d'attendre que les gens arrivent que les
troupes arrive que le caméraman arrive
moi je suis rédacteur et je suis un
fervent défenseur de du smartphone pour
tous les rédacteurs de la rédaction donc
le déploiement se fait progressivement
et je pense que
cet appareil c'est le bloc notes
vidéo d'aujourd'hui et qu'il est
indispensable pour pour les journalistes
donc la fabrication de l'information
bien sûr elles évoluent elles évoluent
donc je vous parlais des équipes aa 5,6
à l'agencé capa le principe c'était un
journaliste un j ai ri un journaliste
reporter d'image sol avec sa betacam
c'est à dire une caméra assez lourde
mais qui était autonome
pour la prise d'image et de son et donc
il n'avait pas besoin d'ingénieurs du
son donc il pouvait aller très
rapidement sur des sujets sur des des
lieux d'actualité à l'étranger est
ramené des images sur lesquelles il y
avait l'image et le son est elle est là
où les autres équipes ne pouvaient pas
aller donc voyez il ya effectivement
cette évolution de la fabrication de de
l'information et les ailes et pas
comment elle est pâle dangereuse la
difficulté serait de tout faire selon un
seul modèle
monsieur le rapporteur tout à l'heure
vous disiez que 80 personnes avaient été
débarqués de de itv qui donnait ses news
excusez moi je reviens là dessus pearson
a été débarqué ils sont partis parce
qu'ils n'étaient pas en accord avec le
projet qui leur avaient été présentées
mais ils n'ont pas été débarqué moi je
venais d'arriver et effectivement le
matin j'avais une équipe et à midi
j'avais des gens qui me disaient nombre
en fait j'arrête je m'en vais et le soir
aussi donc
l'objectif était de garder tout le monde
qu'il n'y avait pas de volonté de
débarquer les gens
et parmi les gens qui ont été débarqués
certains ont essayé un nouveau modèle de
chaîne de télé avec des iphones et avec
un modèle de tout et ça n'a pas
fonctionné et ça n'a pas fonctionné donc
il n'ya pas de règle voyez ccc pas c'est
à dire on peut essayer ont fait partizan
a d'une certaine manière c'est à la fois
une usine une usine d'infos ont fait des
news factory excusez moi pour le pôle
anglicismes
et mais on est toujours en train
d'essayer des nouvelles façons de
raconter l'actualité globalement on
reste sur les mêmes sur la même forme
mais si on arrive à trouver quelque
chose de neuf on le fait si ça reçoit
l'assentiment du public et mais on
continue et c'est comme ça que la
fabrication de l'information évolue
michel laugier merci monsieur le
président je vois que l'exclusion moi je
peux me permettre juste du plaisir
la dessinatrice internautes et je vais
faire très vite souffre juste parce que
pas mal de questions donc s'allonger
très
importante dans l'évolution et vous avez
eu raison de le souligner si le lien de
confiance avec avec les téléspectateurs
et et le public est là dessus on a on a
un vrai enjeu vous avez eu raison de
deux policiers du doigt le
je pense que nous on a un rôle à jouer
et
on a tout à gagner dans la transparence
pour être pour accompagner les
téléspectateurs sur une forme
d'éducation aux médias leur montrer
comment on travaille leur montrer
comment on va chercher de l'info pour
justement
leur redonner confiance
montrer que nous que le travail que l'on
fait c'est apporter des sources comment
comment comment on va recueillir tel ou
tel telle ou telle information et c'est
vrai que
on a un enjeu là dessus pour bat pour
mettre en place ce genre de ce genre de
format d'éducation aux médias allaient
chercher
de nouveaux formats c'est que nous on
essaye sans nous la concurrence c'est la
même chose mais d'aller chercher sur des
formats peut-être un petit peu plus
jeunes sur les sur les réseaux sociaux
et formats tik tok et ses rangs pour
pour pour redonner confiance à a quand
même une information quand on va dire
que fiable certifiés avec
avec avec seul ce lien qu'on essaye de
retisser fois
michel lejeune merci monsieur le
président de questions au journalistique
du politique que je suis avec des récits
des réponses que notre politique était
aujourd'hui ce que vous êtes la première
chose d'un peu beaucoup parler de
l'indépendance des journalistes
est ce que pour vous il est plus facile
et d'être indépendant quand on est dans
une rédaction un groupe privé où les
scolaires ni dans une rédaction de
l'audiovisuel public et la deuxième
question
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez nous
dire quels sont les avantages et les
inconvénients de faire partie d'un grand
groupe quand on est journaliste merci je
pense qu'il y a des avantages et des
inconvénients
actionnaires privés avoir un actionnaire
public et au fond les interrogations qui
peuvent exister sur les actionnaires
privés peuvent exister sur l'actionnaire
public sur la relation avec eux avec
l'état avec le gouvernement mais comme
j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le dire
je pense que l'indépendance c'est
d'abord le sushi du journaliste lui-même
et que c'est d'abord sa capacité à
fédérer autour de lui un certain nombre
d'autres journalistes éventuellement
dans une société des rédacteurs pour
pour faire savoir les choses et pour se
défendre d'éventuelles situations vous
savez il ya toujours cette idée que
quelque chose arrive et que vous pouvez
alors qu'en fait tout se passe toujours
dans des discussions et à jamais même
dans nos fonctions respectives
dans la mienne en tout cas je dis
rarement on fait ça c'est comme ça et
c'est tout se passe toujours d'engrais
ya des conférences de rédaction tous les
jours où vous avez vous avez un dialogue
et où vous n'imposez pas des choix il ya
toujours il ya un espèce de surveillance
mutuelle permanente
et une discussion moi je pense que c'est
important en effet qu'il y ait des
acteurs de l'information solide qui soit
en capacité de rémunérer leurs
journalistes qui sont en capacité de
développer des propositions d'investir
puisqu'on l'a vu il ya des enjeux de
matériel il ya des enjeux de capacité à
voyager il ya des enjeux donc c'est
important qu'il ya des acteurs solides
après le seul le seul sujet pour moi
c'est que c'est que la proportion de
leurs solidités soient pas excessives
c'est qu'elle empêche pas d'autres
d'émerger d'exister de faire savoir
voilà donc c'est une question c'est une
question d'équilibré entre ces deux
choses là
et c'est pas inintéressant en soit c'est
vraiment une conviction pour moi que des
acteurs privés s'investissent et
consolident des groupes il faut juste
pas que qu'il n'en reste que
quelques-uns aux dépens de tous les
autres
oui moi je rejoins ce que ce que vient
de dire
sénégal le
pour répondre à la première question
c'est à dire que
là la liberté c'est aussi une question
de personne et c'est le journaliste ce
pas qu'il soit dans un groupe privé ou
dans un groupe public c'est lui face à
ça c'est sa responsabilité
voilà dans un échange avec
avec avec la rédaction à prendre david
pujadas david pujadas il a présenté les
journaux sur le service public pendant
très longtemps il nous a rejoints il ya
quatre ou cinq ans
lci jeu n'a pas changé sa façon de
travailler de concevoir de concevoir
l'information je pense qu'il a la même
exigence éditoriale quand il fait son 24
ore pujadas tous les soirs sur explique
quand il faisait les journaux
sur sur france française france
télévisions ensuite moi sur les sur les
avantages et les inconvénients je vous
réponde rapidement ce que je l'étais
déjà un petit peu un petit peu dit tout
à l'heure
moi j'y vois beaucoup beaucoup davantage
chose que j'y vois la solidité d'un
groupe je vous ai parlé de la crise
sanitaire mais voilà avec un message
très rassurant
en terme en termes d'emplois dans une
période qui n'était qui n'était pas
simple et en termes d'emplois et de
continuité d'information ça c'était
important une solidité d'un groupe pour
fabriquer l'information qui a un coût et
l'information vérifiée ce à un coût
certain c'est des coûts fixes
assez lourd est aussi un groupe solide
pour pouvoir garantir une certaine
liberté éditoriale liberté éditoriale
parce que justement ça permet le
d'apporter des garanties avec les fameux
garde-fous de la loi bloch avec une
veste et jia et c'est avec un grand
groupe c'est ces
dispositifs sont sont assurées de
manière solide
d'action enfin en paix à vous répondre
sur les avantages et les inconvénients
d'une réaction publique par rapport à la
rédaction d'un terrain d'un groupe privé
j'ai été dans des rédactions plutôt
privé dans mon dans ma carrière
professionnelle il ya une haute
distinction à établir entre les
rédactions qui sont intégrés et celles
qui sont externalisés les rédactions qui
sont les rédactions des agences de
presse
et qui sont accolés à des sociétés de
production appelle des boîtes de prod
le fonctionnement n'est pas le même à
titre personnel je me suis toujours
senti plus en sécurité et en liberté
journalistique dans un groupe intégré
dans une rédaction intégrée que dans une
même si pour le coup l'agencé capa est
une agence
journalistes
au au sens majuscule du terme pour tout
et pour tout les lettres du du du mot
il ya toujours dans l'externalisation
c'est quand même un lien de suggestions
commerciale
entre le la société de production
lagence de presse qui livre qui fournit
une prestation d'information
à un diffuseur et dans les rédactions
intégrer
ce lien de suggestions
pour moi n'existe pas puisque on est
journaliste au service du traitement de
l'information pour le groupe par
ailleurs dans un grand groupe il ya
quand même une
un avantage c'est le moyen technique la
masse critique de la rédaction les
moyens techniques et les fonctions
supports qui permettent de faire son
métier dans de meilleures conditions que
dans une
boîte de fraude ou effectivement c'est
beaucoup plus là on est dans l'artisanat
dans le petit artisanat ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'on ne fasse pas bien son
travail mais disons que
les liens sont plus complexes entre le
diffuseur et le producteur là il n'y a
pas de distinction producteurs
diffuseurs c'est la même chose c'est là
que nous à ces news on diffuse nos
propres productions donc on est beaucoup
plus libre de ce point de vue là
moi je fais deux questions à vous poser
de nature diverse tout d'abord madame
pigalle tout est là où vous avez
commencé votre propos en décrivant bfmtv
en disant que j'ai des bénéfices ce qui
est rare depuis que nous avons commencé
cette commission denquête d'entendre ce
propos moi je voulais vous poser une
question sur l'aspect économique pour
comprendre la relation entre
l'actionnaire et
et les oreilles des journalistes que
vous êtes tellement de vies on n'a pas
d'influencé en a pas de directive sur la
nature de l'information
sur la façon dont étaient organisés et
traiter l'information est ce qu'il ya
des demandes des actionnaires je prends
un exemple très précis sur chacune de
vos des chaînes il ya de plus en plus
souvent les tables rondes avec des
experts des intervenants j'imagine que à
réaliser ça doit pas être très coûteux
de les intervenants sont pas payés pour
la plupart et un animateur c'est
beaucoup moins coûteux que ce que vous
avez dû connaître dans votre fonction de
journaliste de réaliser des enquêtes
long ou qui prennent du temps qui
mobilise les équipes et c est ce qu il
ya une volonté de la part de vos
actionnaires et ses deux respectives aux
volontés ou des orientations pas dire
manière plus
plus souple des orientations qui sont
données pour des questions économiques
de privilégier telle ou telle façon de
traiter l'information notamment à
travers ces tables rondes je devrais pas
utiliser le terme le rondin terme table
ronde puisque fou c'est cher aussi ce
matin d'être en table ronde mais enfin
vous voyez c'est ça c'est ma première
question une deuxième question l'autre
jour lorsque nous avons auditionné
qu'olivier maistre
cher interrogé sur le fait qu'il ya un
glissement
dans le secteur audiovisuel et
atteignant particulier de des
télévisions vers des télévisions
d'opinion puisque jusqu'à présent ça
existe au niveau de la presse écrite et
s'est organisée dans ce sens de reste
depuis de très nombreuses années mais le
secteur de la télévision n'était pas
organisé vous ne fonctionnait pas selon
cette logique là est ce que vous vous
poserez la question individuellement à
chacun d'entre vous est ce que vous
sentez que la télévision allait autre
chaîne est devenue une chaîne d'opinion
dans l'ordre de vos questions sur la
façon dont ce fond les choix qu'il ya au
fond un consensus sans que cette chose
là soit répété régulièrement sur ce qui
est l'objet de la chaîne ce qui est son
modèle éditorial et pour ce qui concerne
bfm tv il ya une logique de s'inscrire
dans l'oeuf dans la dynamique d'une
grande chaîne populaire
s'adressant au plus grand nombre sur les
sujets d'intérêt général
qui concerne plus particulièrement la
france et quand l'actualité se déroule à
l'étranger avec une résonance pour pour
notre pays et au fond cette ligne
éditoriale qui qui est répétée de
manière un peu diffuse comme ça au
quotidien elle préside ensuite au choix
dans les conférences de rédaction en
disant ça c'est nous ça ça nous
ressemble moins ça correspond moins à
l'objet de la chaîne au quotidien et je
dirais en ce sens que la chaîne s'est
inscrite finalement peu dans la
tradition de ce qu'a pu être un rtl
historiques ou le journal le parisien
donc c'est finalement à l'aune de cette
conviction partagée et de cette ligne
partage et qu'ensuite on fait les
arbitrages au jour le jour
sur les les déclarations d'intention des
actionnaires finalement il n'y en a pas
on ne dit pas je suis propriétaire de
tel ou tel média ou rarement en tout cas
pour telle ou telle raison ou alors ce
sont des déclarations assez générales et
au fond je pense qu'il faut juger sur
les faits et c'est pour ça que j'avais à
coeur de vous dire que les journalistes
sont très nombreux dans cette rédaction
est ce que nous avons fait à rebours de
l'image peut-être qu'on en a comme la
chaîne a surgi dans une quinzaine
d'années il ya des il ya des moments
particuliers qui ont fait son image mais
aujourd'hui le moment principal pour été
pour pour bfm tv
c'est la matinale et c'est une matinale
dans laquelle il y à du reportage le
prime time de la chaîne c'est cette
matinale c'est une matinale dans
laquelle il ya de très nombreux
reportages et qui finalement ressemble
assez à ce qu'on faisait en radio à ce
qui existe dans les matinales radio avec
beaucoup de diversité
de la même manière on nous avons
développé au cours de ces cinq dernières
années une politique de doc une
politique de long format une politique
d' enquête et même une politique de
série désormais de série d'informations
avec notamment une série à la rentrée à
l'occasion de du procès des attentats du
13 novembre sur la traque des
terroristes soyez donc avec des choses
très fouillée et donc je considère pour
ma part que c'est la démonstration de
l'engagement dans la production la
fabrication d'informations sur toutes
sortes de formats est vraiment la
dynamique dans laquelle nous sommes elle
consiste à contrario et un rebours de
l'idée qu'on s'en fait pas du tout a
uniquement avoir des plateaux avec ont
des éditorialistes ou des experts mais à
être présent sur toutes les formes
d'information une matinale très varié
avec beaucoup de reportages des formats
longs et puis d'ailleurs toutes sortes
de développement aussi qui peuvent
exister à travers la mort bfm tv mais
sur sur le site internet et donc à être
une marque d'infos à 360 qui qui est
présent sur tous les registres après il
se trouve que certains débats par
exemple comme on cette rentrée celui
entre jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour
recueille une audience importante et au
fond ça marque les esprits mais dans le
quotidien de la chaîne il ya vraiment
des choses très diverses et ça c'est
possible et on en revient toujours à ça
parce qu'il ya un investissement qui est
fait pour développer toutes ces choses
là et d'ailleurs cet investissement il
est jamais
je veux dire il ya dans tout ça de la
générosité puis aussi la foi dans le
fait que l'information étant bien qui
intéressent et il faut savoir par
exemple que le fait de fabriquer du
format long nous permet aussi d'avoir
quelque part en dehors de notre antenne
une place en replay de deux voiliers de
développer cette marque d'information et
de s'adresser au public avec d'autres
matches d'autres manières que simplement
en continu et en direct
et donc pour répondre enfin votre
dernière question en ce qui nous
concerne nous ne sommes pas du tout dans
une démarche de télévision d'opinion
sommes vraiment attaché à être et
demeurer une grande chaîne d'information
ce qui n'empêche pas évidemment que des
points de vue s'expriment sur l'antenne
et en l'état en réalité dans le paysage
français et notamment avec ce sujet du
pluralisme et du respect des temps de
parole
j'ai toujours entendu alain weil qui
était donc le créateur de sa chienne qui
régulièrement était interrogé sur ces
sujets dire on peut pas faire foxy vous
en france dès lors qu'on respecte les
règles parce que on est obligé sur
l'antenne de donner la parole à
l'ensemble des sensibilités
votre expression des intervenants pas
payé
il fut un temps effectivement les
intervenants n'étaient pas payés des
intervenants extérieurs n'était pas
digne il venait s qualité représentant
lors pour les gens la liste leur journal
représentant leur ufr ou ou centres de
recherche
mais ça c'était avant
je ne dirai pas lequel de mes confrères
à commencer à rémunérer les intervenants
extérieurs mais que nous sommes dans une
situation concurrentielle il a bien
fallu avant que nous nous alignons et
que
et que ces intervenants soient d'abord
donc c'est vrai c'est pas
nous
il a fallu que nous alignons et donc les
intervenants la plupart sont sont
rémunérés d'une façon ou d'une autre
sauf les experts qui dans l'actualité
sont sollicités pour réagir quelque
chose c'est à dire qu'un un sismologue
s'il y a
risques sismiques autour d'une centrale
nucléaire on va le solliciter en duplex
ou skype ou en face time etc ou
directement sur le plateau il vient s
qualité et on va parler on va pas le
rémunérer mais les intervenants
réguliers
nous sommes en situation concurrentielle
et nous cherchons à avoir effectivement
les meilleurs intervenants et les
meilleurs des batteurs et donc
aujourd'hui les intervenants sont
généralement payés donc nous ne ne
pensais pas que les intervenants ne sont
pas payés et que parce qu'ils ne sont
pas payés les plateaux de toc ne sont
pas chères et parce qu'ils ne sont pas
chers ils ne sont pas qualitatif
en l'occurrence ils le sont
je pense en tout cas nous faisons tout
pour qu'il ait pour qu'il le soit avec
avec avec nos intervenants
comme l'a expliqué
ma consoeur bien entendu nous avons
différents formats c'est à dire il n'ya
pas que le news et le débat
nous nous sommes comment dire nous avons
travaillé assez news à faire en sorte
qu' il ya des moments d'actu
classique et traditionnelle des jt et
ensuite qu'il ya des débats d'actu et
donc il ya ce qu'ils rentrent dans le
journal rappelle le journal et puis
après il ya ce qui rentre dans débats
d'actu et c'est vrai que moi tout au
long de la journée je supervise et jeu
comment dire je distribue les
thématiques qui vont être débattues en
fonction de l'évolution de l'actualité
ou deux salles dont une évolution dans
les différentes tranches d'infos ou dans
les différentes tranches de débat et
ce qui nous démarque assez news je pense
c'est notre notre éditorialisation le
fait de s'intéresser beaucoup plus
anodin aux auditeurs et à ce qui peut
intéresser nos auditeurs cas là je vais
être j'ai pas être très confraternel
meas qui va intéresser nos confrères il
ya une tendance chez les journalistes
affaire l'info que les autres vont faire
aussi
donc il ya des infos utiles sont
effectivement
indispensable à traiter qui non mais
c'est bien et ensuite
il ya parfois une tendance naturelle du
journaliste à dire s'il faut le faire ça
il faut le faire et en fait pourquoi il
faut le faire ça
pas forcément nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est cesser de traiter l'actualité
différemment alors céline a cité le
parisien où rtl
on pourrait citer aussi rmc qui est qui
est une référence dans le débat dans le
débat populaire et et et avec succès
nous notre matinale elle est animée par
romain des arbres qui vient de rmc et
qui est effectivement une matinale eux
très riche qui sert effectivement et
c'est le modèle de tous de toutes les
chaînes d'info de vaisseau amiral et à
partir de là matinale c'est vrai que
l'actualité et le traitement de
l'actualité ce se déploie soit dans des
moments jt soit dans des moments
effectivement d'eau débat soit dans des
moments de commentaires pur
voilà ensuite est-ce qu'on est une télé
d'opinion en france y'a pas de télé
d'opinion c'est interdit est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment de travailler pour
absolument pas il est absolument nous
travaillons ni pour un parti ni pour un
candidat ni même pour pour une idée à la
rigueur s'il y avait une opinion
franchement s'il y avait une opinion
exprimée c'est celle du drapeau enfin
c'est à dire je la seule opinion c'est
celle du d'un fossé bleu blanc rouge il
ya des opinions bleu des opinions
blanche des opinions rouge elle
s'exprime tout mais il n'y a pas de télé
d'opinion en france il ya effectivement
des journaux d'opinion c'est vrai qu'on
peut distinguer la ligne le figaro
l'humanité libération mais dans les
chaînes info il n'y a pas de il n'ya pas
d'opinion est en tout cas assez news il
a des opinions mais ce n'est pas une
chaîne d'opinion
monsieur moratti et puis ensuite
dernière question de david assouline non
rapidement il n'y a pas eu
li a pas d'intervention sur les sur les
formes à eux
à l'antenne moi je pense personnellement
qu on a tout à gagner à voir mais
multiplication des formats sursaut sur
lci plus on a une offre variée et riche
plus on peut on peut séduire le
le téléspectateur donc dû du reportage
et les grands formats nous on en fait
aussi je pense que ça que ça apporte sa
porte une autre une autre forme de
narration évidemment des grands débats
voilà
les débats d'europe écologie verts débat
dlr je pense que plus on peut multiplier
l'offre mais c'est donc on a pas
d'intervention du touch ou sur des
formats qui coûterait plus cher ou moins
cher on a là dessus on a une liberté on
a une liberté totale et moi à titre
personnel je pense que il faut justement
élargir tout ça d'ailleurs on parlait
tout à l'heure de projet de fusion tf1
tf1 m6 moi je note que le quasiment
tous les groupes en tout cas les groupes
autour de cette table sont adossées à
une radio et par exemple est adossé à
rtl va ça permettrait de justement
pouvoir offrir de nouveaux rendez-vous
pouvoir offrir de nouveaux de nouveaux
événements donc ça moi je pense que
c'est plutôt plutôt une bonne chose je
suis plutôt à développer sa
voix l'a ensuite sur l'opinion joue un
pont un train très facilement et très
rapidement non on n'est pas du tout une
chaîne n'est pas du tout une chaîne
d'opinion elle c'est
monsieur la panthère
enfin c'est pour une question est une
question
vous savez
pour ce qui est de ses news
quand delà des propos feutrée que nous
avons là
certains disent les choses relativement
brutalement dans la situation actuelle
et vous est reproché d'avoir fabriqué
candidat à la présidentielle
j'aimerais avoir votre réaction mais je
vais aller plus loin pour ce qui est de
votre responsabilité personnelle vous
êtes directeur d'une rédaction vous nous
assurez ici avec
vous a répondu est-ce que vous pouvez
m'assurer pourrait être clair qu' il n'y
a aucune consigne dans des conférences
de rédaction de favoriser telle ou telle
idéologie ou tel ou tel je dis bien
idéologie
tel ou tel rôle favori long telle ou
telle idéologie
et tel ou tel
oui idées politiques
vous pouvez m'assurer que ça n'est
jamais abordé ni orientés dans aucun des
moments où
ja c'est votre responsabilité
pendant seulement important je peux vous
l'assurer j'anime
personnellement la conférence de
rédaction du matin les conférences de
rédaction de prévision et parfois les
conférences de rédaction du soir et c
est celle qui prépare la matinale à
aucun moment
je n'ai favoriser et je ne cherche à
favoriser et personne ne m'a demandé de
favoriser un candidat un parti plutôt
qu'un autre forme vraiment je vous
assure je
mets ni même une idéologie je vous lis
la seule idéologie
l'idéologie c'est justement à
l'idéologie je vois bien celle que vous
laquelle vous faites allusion mais il ya
aussi l'idéologie justement celle de
l'idéologie
global on pense que c'est comme ça et
c'est de l'idéologie cachez vous voyez
on a tous une idéologie un biais
idéologique nous avons tous un biais des
logiques moi je le sais je fais
attention à ça et je fais attention à ce
qui n'est pas une idéologie ce qu'ils
soient privilégiés par rapport à une
autre
nous avons je voulais rappeler les parmi
nos intervenants réguliers
nous avons
laurent joffrin nous avons julien dray
que vous connaissez monsieur le
rapporteur
qui récemment encore sur sur une radio
radio j pour la cité exprimer sa liberté
totale
de parole sur un autre sur notre antenne
de parole et de thèmes dans les
émissions dans lesquelles ils auxquelles
il participe je pourrais citer aussi
olivier dartigolles
et qui a lui aussi une liberté de parole
complète il n'y a pas d'idéologie
favoriser à ses news moussa l'important
je vous assure
c'est ce type
ça fait partie des rémunéré ou cd
intervenants
les intervenants en fait quasiment tous
les intervenants hormis ceux qui
viennent sur une actualité particulière
donc sociaux sur son des intervenants
qui viennent je n'ai pas je ne m'occupe
pas de 2 ça personnellement mais il ya
des intervenants qui sont rémunérés
d'autres qui ne sont pas ceux que tout
le monde s'arrache sont généralement
rémunérés sur nos plateaux sur les
plateaux
vous me dites sur vous venez de citer
ceux rémunérés
je ne lance je n'en sais rien je ne sais
pas mais ici si si si si si j'ai réussi
j'avais besoin
d'appuyer ma
l'assurance que quelques que je vous
fais je voudrais revenir vous savez nous
sommes soumis à une
convainquons tra une
charte à une a
des obligations envers le servir le csa
il ya un article l'article 2 3 2 que me
semble si leur vous connaissez et dans
lequel nous avons des obligations
à des pratiques des comportements
dangereux respecter les différentes
sensibilités sensibilités politiques
culturelles religieuses ne pas
encourager les comportements
discriminatoires promouvoir les valeurs
d'intégration de solidarité prendre en
considération dans la représentation des
dominations vous étonner ses articles je
les ai encore lui il ya deux jours en
conférence de rédaction et je suis
personnellement responsable du respect
non seulement de la lettre et de
l'esprit de la lettre de ceux de cet
article
parce que là on n'a pas posé alors
qu'elle est au coeur d'une des
problématiques de la concentration
la fusion tf1 m6 madame c'est une pique
à la
s'est inquiété de ce que cela peut
signifier
une concentration aussi importante en
surface d'audience mais aussi en marché
publicitaire pour les autres et
le service public par exemple mais après
les petites chaînes d'information qui
sont effectivement après
un tel gros va imposer à se rendre de
règne de prix
ou même de production en situation de
grand monopole on va dire mais par
ailleurs
quelle est votre réflexion vous comme
directeur d'une d'une rédaction dans les
fusions des rédactions qui vont devoir
s'occuper puisque c'est avec m6 qu'est
ce qui est envisagé
avez vous des craintes
de 2,2 en réduction
concomitants d'économies
de coûts de production de l'information
de deux journalistes
et c'est qu'elles sont calés mode
l'appréciation vous avez le regard vous
avez sur le vote rédaction de lci
avec cette fusion
d'abord sur le projet de fusion en lui
même il ya vu des
je crois des garanties qu'on était qui
ont été prises
en terme en termes d'emploi en termes
d'indépendance des rédactions
et des garanties des garanties assez
forte sur le
- demain demain de ma fenêtre à elle si
je vous lis je pense que là la
singularité
des rédactions
c'est quelque chose enfin l'indépendance
la singularité des réflexions sait
quelque chose voilà que je suis très
attaché personnellement et donc moi on
parler de fusion
du tout quelque chose que je souhaite je
pense que on est plus forts avec une
variété de variété de formats avec une
offre une offre une offre riche et
surtout singulière ça c'est le premier
point deuxième point je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure
au dos et une précision vous nous dites
que y'aura pas fusion des rédactions
dans le cadre de la fugue de deux
projets envisagés
je suis pas
je m'occupe bien compris mais en tout
cas il ya eu des engagements qui au
mourillon qui ont été pris en termes
d'indépendance
l'indépendance des rédactions il semble
que dans le projet je crois que c'était
le au lendemain
olivier roussat avait répondu à une
interview il prenait des engagements
assez fort je ne sais plus j'ai c'est
plus long terme il y avait des
engagements assez fort en terme d'emploi
de de
maintien de l'emploi et puis des
engagements forts en termes
d'indépendance
des rédactions moi personnellement à si
on me demandait mon avis c'est quelque
chose que j'appelle de mes voeux je
pense que je pense qu'
il faut garder cette singularité des
rédactions des différentes rédactions
ensuite cette cette fusion là aussi si
vous me demandez moi mon avis personnel
et vu de mon côté je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure je pense que avoir
une opportunité d'être adossé par
exemple à une radio c'est quelque chose
que du point de vue de l ci peut être
très intéressant pour justement
apporter de nouveaux rendez vous
apporter de nouveaux formats et pouvoir
voilà peut-être
diversifier au corps et enrichir encore
notre offre d'information voilà pour
cette audition de la commission d'
enquête du sénat sur la concentration
des médias en france à les sénateurs ont
auditionné les dirigeants des rédactions
de plusieurs chaînes d'information bfmtv
lci et ses news et les questions se sont
concentrés sur la chaîne ces news détenu
par vincent bolloré est souvent accusée
de défendre des idées conservatrices des
idées qui sont portées actuellement par
eric zemmour candidat à la
présidentielle et ancien animateur de
ses news en tout cas le directeur de
l'information de ces news a assuré que
sa chaîne était bien une chaîne
d'information est pas une chaîne
d'opinion voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi
continuer à suivre l'actualité
parlementaire et politique sur notre
site internet publicsenat.fr souhaite
une très bonne journée sur public sénat
revoir ce programme en replay sur
publicsenat.fr
[Musique]
l'actualité parlementaire et politique
continue sur publicsenat.fr
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez vous deux débats et des analyses
sur public sénat la promesse elle est
dans le titre donner du sens à
l'actualité et puis vous proposez avec
nos invités des clés de compréhension
des mutations de la société française
avec pour commencer le débat là dessus
il est consacré ce soir la visite du
président français en hongrie chez
victor dan le leader nationaliste qui
inspire l'extrême droite française qui
est le premier ministre hongrois faute
il faut refuser de lui rendre visite
comme l'affirment yannick jadot sur
quels dossiers européens la france
peut-elle avoir besoin de la hongrie
réponse juste après ses titres les
électeurs ont la parole à votre
rencontre notre reportage au coeur des
territoires ce soir nous serons un saint
malo où le maire de la ville est partie
en guerre contre les locations airbnb en
imposant des quotas aux propriétaires on
entendra notamment des malouins
locataires qui ont de plus en plus de
mal à se loger et puis notre second
débat vous le savez il est
volontairement décalée de l'actualité il
sera consacré ce soir à la grave crise
des hôpitaux publics français au delà de
l'épidémie de coville qui n'en finit pas
c'est un système vieux de plus de 60 ans
qui craque et menacent de s'effondrer le
constat et les idées de réforme de nos
experts à découvrir tout à l'heure mais
d'abord un président français un premier
ministre hongrois adversaires politiques
et partenaires européens nicolas fleury
ce sont deux adversaires
nous avons des désaccords politiques qui
sont connus
mais nous avons la volonté de travailler
ensemble pour cette europe et d'être des
partenaires loyaux qui peuvent en même
temps être des alliés message
d'équilibriste défendue aujourd'hui par
emmanuel macron en visite à budapest en
pleine crise entre l'europe et viktor
orban
car le premier ministre hongrois refuse
de se soumettre au droit européen
il est critiqué pour son hostilité
envers les migrants ces atteintes à la
liberté de la presse et ses attaques
contre les lgbt il n'y a pas de place
pour les bureaucrates de bruxelles ici
et quoi qu'ils fassent nous ne
laisserons pas les activistes lgbt
côtoyé nos petits dans les écoles et les
jardins d'enfants tension maximale cet
été quand viktor orban n'interdit de
montrer l'homosexualité aux mineurs à la
télévision par exemple
aussitôt les dirigeants européens
dénoncent un texte homophobes ce projet
de loi hongrois est une honte il va à
l'encontre de toutes les valeurs
fondamentales de l'union européenne
pour moi la hongrie n'a plus rien à
faire dans l'union mais je ne suis pas
le seul à décider
pourtant emmanuel macron espère bien
faire de la hongrie un partenaire
stratégique en matière de défense et
d'énergie nucléaire des thèmes au
programme de la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui démarre le 1er
janvier aujourd'hui l'elysée a promis de
l'esquivé rock un sujet emmanuel macron
doit d'ailleurs rencontrer le principal
opposant à viktor orban une façon de
prendre un peu de distance avec le
dirigeant en droit alors qu'il ya
quelques semaines j'ai eu plaisir tout à
l'heure de discuter avec thorgan il
recevait deux candidats à la
présidentielle eric zemmour et marine le
pen
et on débat autour de la personnalité de
viktor orban ait du sens de cette visite
du président français avec mes
invitèrent mais le charrier bonsoir vous
êtes éditorialistes en politique
internationale à france 24 sylvain kahn
bonsoir à vous aussi historien géographe
spécialiste de l'union européenne
géopolitique et de sa construction
professeur à sciences po paris et puis
vous publiez histoire de la construction
de l'europe depuis 1945 c'est aux puf
aux presses universitaires de france
pierre connaissent avant soit rejeté
essayiste ancien haut fonctionnaire vous
publiez le lobby saoudien en france
comment vendre un pays invendables c'est
aux éditions denoël j'accueille
également fabienne keller qui est avec
nous en duplex députée européenne j
entends soir au sein du groupe
renaissance au parlement européen et
lætitia cru pas une crise politique qui
sera à mes côtés tous les jours cette
semaine est en fait un coucou amical
évidemment à
matthieu croissandeau peut-être une
définition une présentation pour vous de
viktor orban qu'est-ce qui vient
spontanément quand vous devez définir le
le premier ministre ont recommencé avec
vaud cilv incarne la figure de proue de
l'île libéralisme en europe libéralisme
ça c'est une définition intéressante
c'est à dire que c'est une démocratie
libérale c'est même le terme qu'il
emploie c'est ça oui alors il n'a pas
inventé mais c'est vrai que c'est lui
qui l'a on va dire un peu théorisé dans
l'union européenne libéralisme en fait
c'est l'idée que l'on peut être une
démocratie
sans respecter l'état de droit et sans
respecter le pluralisme voilà c'est ça
ahmed faras qui peut effectivement
arriver quoi c'est sa définition je
pense que fait viktor orban n'y joue sur
plusieurs points c'est il est détesté de
beaucoup il se positionne comme ça en
europe en même temps il est assez
stratège parce que ça lui a permis de
mettre une césure dans l'europe et de
porter une vision différente d'une
europe qui soient évidemment plus
nationale on reprend sur la question des
immigrés mais ensuite derrière de
valeurs européennes qui prend à sa main
en disant il faut les défendre nous
sommes aussi une europe chrétienne et il
faut la prendre alors finalement dans la
rencontre macron et à viktor orban on
retrouve deux hommes qui ont la volonté
d'avoir une stature européenne
qui reconnaît ça comment vous le déficit
vient d'où tient dans l'échiquier
politique
hongrois viktor orban ya toujour ete
nationaliste à l'extrême il a été
d'abord un opposant locaux mise quand
même c'est un carrière politique
commence à ce moment là puis ensuite
effectivement il va prendre la tête d'un
mouvement politique qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui il est le premier
ministre qui a la plus longue longévité
politique en hongrie donc il est
représentatif de quelque chose quand
même mais bon la deuxième chose c'est
que la hongrie comme la pologne sont des
pays qui ont une histoire assez
différente parce qu'ils ont eu 35 ans ou
40 ans de communisme et quand en 89 il
commençait à prendre l'indépendance ils
découvrent si vous voulez la possibilité
de décider pour eux-mêmes même s'il
entre dans l'europe donc ils ont un peu
le sentiment d'être passés de la tutelle
de moscou si vous voulez la tutelle de
bruxelles et il faut être sensible à cet
aspect là parce que je voudrais pas
exagérer mais vous savez c'est le pays
qui est un tout petit pays ces dix
millions d'habitants c'est le pays qui a
vu transiter ou qui a accueilli le plus
grand nombre d'immigrants par rapport à
sa population et c'est à celui là qu'on
va donner de leçons en expliquant
qu'elle ait le droit de votre ange
heures chez vous oui je le veux dire
pour les hongrois que la priorité soit
pas tout à fait celle de bruxelles il
faut aussi la prendre en compte fabienne
keller on entendait dans le reportage de
deux je sais plus qui l'a fait excuser
moi ça s'appelle un trou de mémoire dit
que la fleury merci beaucoup il avait le
pincer qui est à côté moi qui est la
rédactrice en chef de l'émission et qui
est dans mon oreillette et là lors il ya
tout petit heureusement qu'elle est là
là bref nicolas fleury pardon et merci
on entendait une voix pour dire mais il
faut l'exclure de l'europe qu'est ce que
vous répondez à sa très bien de qualité
souvent pensé bas on est en difficulté
parce que il représente un pays qui a
accepté les valeurs de l'union au moment
de l'entrée donc dans les années 90 puis
officiellement en 2004 il a été
dirigeant clairement dans ce cadre est
désormais il s'en éloigne
c'est à dire qu'ils ne respectent plus
du tout les principes de la séparation
des pouvoirs il a pris progressivement
le contrôle de la justice on n'en parle
même plus tellement ça fait longtemps il
n'y a plus aucune presse libre dans son
pays ils pratiquent la corruption ils
nourrissent et ses proches et il a fixé
un certain nombre de cibles parmi
lesquels la technocratie bruxelloise les
lgbt y que les juifs aussi on oublie sa
campagne il faut pas oublier sa campagne
contre soros au motif de l'université
mais en fait c'était une autre cible et
puis
également les migrants donc qu'il a une
stratégie très ciblées mais il est
habile parce que de temps en temps il
s'est donné raison à l'une ou l'autre
règles de l'union européenne pour donner
le sentiment qu'il s'y conformeraient
tout au contraire il a transformé la loi
hongroise
pour beaucoup de clauses de nominations
notamment il faut les deux tiers de
majorité dans son assemblée ce qui est
pratiquement inaccessible un parti
démocratique ou à
l'ensemble de la de l'opposition qui est
coalisés entièrement contre lui ils se
sont organisés tous ensemble pour
essayer de l'emporter en avril prochain
alors ce qui est intéressant on l'a vu
dans le temps dans le reportage tout à
l'heure c'est que évidemment et eric
zemmour et marine le pen se sont succédé
à budapest on va écouter d'abord eric
zemmour c'est le 24 septembre dernier
pour lui le premier ministre hongrois
n'est pas autoritaire écoutez je ne
pense pas que les caravanes soit un
dirigeant autoritaire il il dirige son
pays et il ne se laisse pas
intimider par
ni l'eau ni les minorités agissantes ni
les médias ni le gouvernement des juges
c'est exactement ce qu'il faudra en
france ça veut pas dire un gouvernement
autoritaire
c'est intéressant c'est une source
d'inspiration très clairement victoire
française dans le petit tour de table
justement j'étais en train de réfléchir
et je me suis dit tiens je vais lui dire
leader autoritaire parce que c'est
immédiatement le mot qu'on a envie
d'utiliser mais un autre mot aussi assez
populistes voilà le populisme je sais
que c'est vraiment le mot tiroir un peu
qui sert à rentrer tout mais c'est
vraiment l'incarnation du populisme
viktor orban et c'est vrai que eric
zemmour a tout intérêt à dire que
finalement il n'est pas autoritaire
parce qu'il est dans son sillon ils ont
les mêmes obsessions l'immigration les
lgbt les femmes les élites les juges et
puis le protectionnisme donc c'est vrai
que c'est un peu dans le sillon d'un or
bad et bien sûr à la française parce que
on essaye toujours de comparer mais on
sait qu'il ya bien sûr des achats pas d
exception culturelle à chaque pays mais
c'est quand même voilà parfumé populisme
le sillage de durban et 2 et moi alors
je vous voyais je voudrais aller c'est
sur cette question d' autoritarisme et
finalement de liberté liberté de la
presse liberté des opposants qui
reconnaissent à jouer les tickets tout à
l'heure dans la liste que faisait
fabienne keller pourquoi bon parce qu'on
a l'impression si vous voulez que c'est
une shopping list c'est à dire on est en
train de chercher tout ce qu'on peut
reprocher à tout ce qu'on peut reprocher
à sorbonne et dieu sait qu'il y en a
mais en plus on veut raccrocher aux
élections françaises on dira alors si en
plus il a reçu zemmour qu'il a reçues
marine le pen donc là on est sûr si vous
voulez que c'est vraiment un méchant bon
et enfin ce type est réélu
il ya des élections en avril dans son
vin et envoie en arabie saoudite salué
un des pires dictateurs théocratique de
la planète et en excellence demande s'il
faut aller à caen entrer en contact avec
un membre de l'union européenne qui a
été réélu donc il ya un espèce
d'inversion de valeur que je vois pas
scandaleux mais ce qui se demandent
jadot qui se demande le fait même pour
des débats et le fait et le fait que
alors parce qu'il ya beaucoup plus
vielles qui sont intéressants ça va au
delà de est-ce que viktor orban et
fréquenta bouhila fréquentable et
effectivement si sylvain kahn c'est
cette question on peut écouter et
yannick jadot le député le candidat
d'europe écologie les verts à la
l'élection présidentielle je prends un
peu de temps parce que ça fait sale à la
régie l'occasion de me suivre on va
écouter c'était ce matin effectivement
il dit pour le yannick jadot il faut pas
aller à budapest l'écoutant on peut lui
serrer la main parce que c'est un
dirigeant européen mais on va pas chez
lui un partenaire
non c'est un des dirigeants européens
banio fait emmanuel macron fait la
visite hors ban il rend service au fond
à la mise en scène durban il le fait
juste après zemmour et le pen je pense
qu'il faut rencontrer tout l'ensemble
des dirigeants européens c'est ça reste
on est en terrain neutre c'est ça voilà
c'est ça résonneront n'invite pas non
plus en france ni tanzanie on va inviter
tous les dirigeants france mais est-ce
qu'on est obligé de mettre en scène or
ban chez lui avec effectivement les lois
anti les bété qui passe dans son pays
les mesures contre la liberté de la
presse les mesures contre l'indépendance
des universités je comprends pas bon
c'est peut-être pas le sur ces arguments
que yannick jadot et plus le plus
percutant où je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez c'est un peu jésuitique un
soviétique de dire oui on peut
rencontrer viktor orban mais pas chez
lui on peut le faire à bruxelles peut
être à paris en réalité tout dépend de
ce que dit emmanuel macron en présence
de victor sorbonne quand il à budapest
moi j'ai un souvenir assez assez fort
d'une conférence de presse conjointe je
crois bien que c'était à budapest il y
avait anguille la merkel et viktor orban
et un gala merkel qui était à côté de
viktor orban à 17 ans en 2014 en 2015 je
crois en garde mme merkel a dit ce
qu'elle pensait de viktor orban à viktor
orban quel concept de libéralisme par
ailleurs manuel macron je veux pas
spécialement défendre manuel macron
méprisant la république française va
également rencontrer le maire de
budapest qui est dans l'opposition sur
le plan national il rencontre le
candidat de l'opposition à l'élection
présidentielle bon il se recueille sur
la tombe
philosophe agnès et l'eire qui était
l'une des opposantes
marquante à la guerre aux intérêts dans
l'âge en fait jadot pense plus ou moins
la même chose que macron mais cherchons
des mac à s'en démarquer parce qu'on est
en pleine campagne pour l'élection
présidentielle non moi il me semble que
bon les hongrois sont dans l'ue voilà
effectivement la démocratie libérale car
un concept inventé par farid sa carrière
en 1998
constate qu' il y à des pays où ils
continuer à avoir des élections
parlementaires tous les cinq ans mais où
ce qu'on pourrait appeler l'écosystème
de la démocratie libérale est de plus en
plus anémiée ou atténuée ça veut dire
quoi se dire qu'il ya pas de presse
libre ou très peu de presse libre par
dijon il ya il ya moins très slims sait
pas qu'il ya une censure c'est que
économiquement c'est très compliqué pour
la presse d'opposition de trouver des
annonceurs petit à petit les
et les financements on va dire de la
presse deviennent tous entre les mains
d'entreprises qui sont elles-mêmes entre
les mains d'affilée durban la seule
presse libre aujourd'hui on la trouve
uniquement sur internet sur les pure
players donc va pas dire qu'il n'a pas
du tout un don qu'il faut serre que ce
qui est un peu compliqué avec le
libéralisme c'est que ça ressemble à une
dictature de type entre deux guerres
mais en vérité c'est pas une dictature
de type entre de hyères c'est un peu
différent régime il est libéral et un
régime autoritaire mais justement dans
un régime il libéral il ya quand même
des élections il ya quand même des
espaces de liberté mais aussi est ce cas
la russie est un régime autoritaire oui
mais justement en russie les élections
sont clairement pas libre il n'y a pas
le droit de manifester par exemple il ya
deux ans ou trois ans enfin oui ça
devait être trois ans quand le parlement
hongrois a fait passer une loi qui
autorisait les entreprises à obliger les
salariés à faire des heures
supplémentaires 400 parents et à leur
permettait de payer les heures
supplémentaires
trois ans après qu'elle ait été effectué
le parlement hongrois a voté ça il ya eu
des manifestations organisées par les
syndicats bon dans un pays où il ya des
manifestations en général on a quand
même l'impression qu'on est plutôt dans
un pays libre que dans un pays
dictatorial voilà donc les régimes
libéraux en particulier en europe c'est
quelque chose d'hybride nouveau alors
évidemment on a tendance à dire assez
des fascistes banon les faty ce n'était
pas exactement mais entre la 19ème
démocratie il ya justement les régimes
autoritaires et donc avec un sens oui il
ya libre comme en russie oui mais
toujours rien moi je pense que vous
en russie on met les opposants
politiques en prison on les met dans des
engrais bah non non on n'est pas les
noms mais pas les opposants politiques
en prison voilà ce débat il sert à ça
aussi la conclusion mais je suis subtil
on va devenir de ce qu'est le bon alors
à partir de là la hongrie dans lieux
d'accord elle est dans lieu alors ma
recruteurs qu'on a vu tout à l'heure le
premier ministre hollandais qui est avec
viktor orban le plus ancien dirigeant
européen actuellement poste il est
arrivé au pouvoir en 2000 on il faut
qu'ils sortent il faut qu'ils sortent
mais bon comment dire c'est comme si
enfin je vais je vais faire une analogie
qu'on peut plus qu'on peut encore un peu
schématique mais c'est comme si les gens
qui en france considéré que prenons eric
zemmour par exemple où le rassemblement
national qui ont pu dont les dirigeants
ont pu être à certains moments condamné
par exemple pour incitation à la haine
raciale
c'est comme si on faisait il ya des gens
qui violent la loi et la constitution
dont il faut les exclure alors que
pourtant ils ont obtenu des suffrages
ils ont des députés à l'assemblée
nationale bon à l'échelle européenne
c'est pareil est-ce qu'on va exclure la
hongrie parce que la majorité des
hongrois ont élu un gouvernement qui ne
respecte pas l'état de droit alors qu'il
ya 40 à 49 % des hongrois qui vote pour
l'opposition et que si ça se trouve en
mars prochain aux prochaines élections
législatives hongroises viktor orban ne
va passer dans l'opposition ça qui est
intéressant aussi
deux hommes-là foncé et allemagne prend
la main les deux hommes ils sont l'un et
l'autre en campagne électorale donc est
ce que finalement une visite comme celle
là pour emmanuel macron elle s'adresse
pas d'abord à l'électorat français est
finalement dans l'attitude de viktor
orban ne s'est pas aussi à son électorat
et vincent d'azé prioritairement vous
avez raison c'est là où les picots en
fait de la rencontre c'est qu'on est à
la fois dans une histoire européenne est
à la fois dans une histoire de politique
intérieure pour emmanuel macron il ya
certainement beaucoup d'intérêt à aller
discuter avec victor hörmann d'abord
parce qu'il dit est obligé il va prendre
la présidence de l'union européenne donc
à partir de ce moment là il faut qu'ils
rencontrent l'ensemble des pays
européens je crois que ça clôt le débat
à un moment donné c'est simplement il
est dans un état de diplomatie il faut
qu'il aille et le pouvoir il faut qu'il
aille rencontrer et puis parce que
lorsqu'il tend la main à viktor orban
certes il y en a qui vont être choqués
mais y'en a qui vont considérer qu'il a
bien fait de faire ça parce que il
effectivement on est quand même avec des
personnes qui peuvent avoir des valeurs
dans lequel ils vont se retrouver dans
viktor orban elles sont aujourd'hui
courtisé par les rimes qui zemmour
marine le pen et sa nièce va tout le
monde se précipite mais derrière
emmanuel macron il a aussi une marche de
gens qui peut récupérer en disant on
peut avoir aussi une vision de l'europe
qui soit une vision de l'europe plus
nationaliste avec des vraies questions
sur l'immigration qui sont pas forcément
d'aller dans les excès c'est à dire de
dire on interdit l'immigration on met
des migrants d'or etc mais en tout cas
je suis intéressé par comprendre
pourquoi ce pays se positionne de cette
manière là et là déjà on est dans un
autre pas en quelque sorte viktor orban
lui il a intérêt à montrer effectivement
politique intérieure que il n'est pas
rejetée par tous en plus emmanuel macron
est assez fin quand ils arrivent ils dit
je vais aller en voir aussi tous les
pays devise grade c'est à dire il avance
à ses frais la semaine
les big tchèque la slovénie et la
pologne est en fait c'est toute cette
fracture en fait européenne dans
laquelle on est en train d'assister de
gens qui sont en train de se positionner
qui n'ont pas envie de sortir de l'union
européenne mais qui ont envie de dire on
n'est pas pro occident on n'est pas
d'accord avec la vision européenne de
l'occident et là effectivement si le
président macro on ne commence pas à y
mettre le fait qu on peut en discuter ça
veut dire qu ils s'excluent complètement
à la fois de cet électorat et de ce jeu
diplomatique
et comme il se veut le président de
l'europe derrière il va falloir de toute
manière qu'il aborde ces sujets parce
que l'europe vallée du a porté pendant
les six mois qui vont venir fabienne
keller je reviens vers vous pour
rebondir peut-être sur ce que disait
sylvain kahn tout à l'heure et est ce
que emmanuel macron doit profiter de
voilà de ceux de ce séjour pour faire
passer aussi des messages
peut-être même ou alors aux français
mais peut-être mais moore
tout à fait j'ai trouvé que sa démarche
était d'aller certes rencontré viktor
orban mais aussi le peuple hongrois
quand il va rencontrer le maire de
budapest quand il va rencontrer le
candidat dont d'union de l'opposition il
s'adresse à l'autre moitié du peuple
hongrois quand il va sur la tombe
d'agnès et leur île il salue les
mouvements intellectuels hongrois donc
c'est un grand respect pour le peuple
hongrois je pense qu'il a voulu
manifester dans une démarche a été dit
mais je voudrais leur dire qui est
normal en satin pour quelqu'un qu'il va
exercer la présidence de l'union
européenne
il ya une jadot à tort c'est yannick
jadot pardon c'est naturel d'aller
dans chaque état membre et c'est vrai
que la hongrie aulas il envie d'y aller
ne n'était pas dévorer par s'étendit
donc il y est allé mais comme un geste
effectivement de diplomatie par contre
les pays du groupe de visegrad leurs
dirigeants sont des exemples de terrible
en europe parce qu'ils sont comme le co
vie d'un qui contamine et on voit bien
que le débat présidentiel français avec
à la fois eric zemmour et madame le pen
qui se rendent chez lui qui sont
d'ailleurs très bien reçus contrairement
au top d'ailleurs sont très très bien
reçus et s'en servent en politique
intérieure comme d'un exemple donc c'est
une vrai risque pour l'europe que ces
pays qui en fait très de manière très
subtile c'est probablement hors ban qui
le sait de manière la plus fine sont à
certains moments mine de respecter un
certain nombre de principes mais pour
mieux les contrôler et de manière plus
efficace en gardant en façade un
semblant d'appartenance à l'union
européenne donc c'est avec toute notre
énergie démocratique nos valeurs
bénéficient du président macron aussi
qu'il va falloir
aller de l'avant et rappelé le besoin
par exemple d'une évidence un d'une
presse libre pour que nos démocraties
fonctionne et aussi d'une justice
indépendante
ce qui n'est plus le cas dans ces quatre
pays du groupe de visegrad je vais vous
redonner la parole et les hisser dans un
instant je vous on parlera du soft power
finalement de cet objectif des macros à
l'occasion de cette visite mais je
voudrais que vous débarquiez un peu
pierre conesa avec fabienne keller parce
que quand elle parle de contamination je
vous vois réagir aux penser que le mans
est trop fort non c'est prendre le
problème à l'envers c'est à dire si des
gens comme zemmour ou comme madame le
pen ou comme victor sorbonne ont une
base électorale il faut prendre le
problème à l'envers ça il faut se
demander pourquoi ils ont une base
électorale et pas les diaboliser donc
s'ils voulaient commencer par prendre la
question de la tête de turc en disant
mais regardez si en plus ils se
regroupent alors je veux dire c'est
l'homme fascisme en marche non moi la
question que pose sorbonne est une
question que je trouve très fondamentale
pour l'europe c'est à dire ou mettant la
limite de ski et le consensus européen
et du droit national les anglais
viennent de quitter l'europe c'est quand
même la plus grave crise depuis sa
création bon et on a aujourd'hui un
dirigeant encore une fois est lui réélu
le plus long en premier ministre de
l'histoire de la hongrie et qui dit bah
écoutez moi regarder reprenant le par
exemple des lgbt il ya dix ans personne
n'en parlait c'est à dire qu'il ya dix
ans on aurait considéré qu sorbonne
était un mauvais démocrate et
aujourd'hui on pose la question sur la
table dans attention là ça devient un
critère sérieux de démocratie mais non
non encore une fois il ya un moment où
il faut arrêter cette mécanique
européenne oui ça c'est le chemin de
l'histoire face à son nom mais le cheval
gvt on n'en parlait pas il ya dix ans
mais enfin c'est quand même au coeur de
l'égalité entre eux oui on sait on
jamais les fans oui mais encore une fois
vous dire mais très bien avoir des
normes qui sont différentes de pays
comment allez-vous savoir présente le
nombre de transgenre que vous avez en
hongrie alors que leur problème
principal c'est l'immigration écoutez il
faut quand même aussi respecter les
choix prioritaires d'un pays d'une
opinion publique largement fantasmée le
problème gaz voire hongrie bon il ya
aucun migrant qui rentrent en hongrie ah
bon tiens donc c'est celui qui les a vu
transiter le plus de tous les pays de
transit et ses 10 millions de trésorerie
s'est quasiment rien dans mes transit et
oui mais encore une fois elle julie
aucun migrant qui veut s'arrêter ennui
ou nier le fait démocratique
c'est-à-dire escaut sorbonne et une
représentativité on a passé cinq minutes
à essayer de a essayé c'est pas facile
de caractériser la démocratie libérale
et vous faites comme si démocratie
libérale égale démocratie libérale c'est
pas tout à fait libérale et libéral je
rappelle
vous avez raison de dire covan a été élu
trois fois de rang et peut-être le
sera-t-il une quatrième mais on peut pas
faire comme si les élections hongrie
c'était pareil que les élections en
france où les élections en espagne mais
vous dise madame que en russie
effectivement les élections étaient
truquées mais vous reconnaissez qu'en
hongrie elles ne le sont pas donc encore
une fois attention à ne pas
gérer ce besoin de le reconnaître parce
que j'ai jamais dit l' inverse
premièrement et deuxièmement on a aussi
expliqué qu' il n'y a plus de presse
d'opposition
j'ai bien sûr la question de le dg bts
on peut aussi considérer que dans dans
les valeurs de l'europe il y à la
défense de ses de ces minorités et que
donc par les lois qui sont prises par
viktor orban ya une remise en cause ses
valeurs oui mais encore une fois ces
valeurs sont récentes c'est à dire que
vous auriez poser le même problème sur
urban ya dix ans qui était déjà un
libéral vous n'auriez pas qualifiés
comme mauvais partenaires de l'union
européenne encore une fois c'était ce
sont des pays qui ont une histoire
différente de la nôtre leur souci
nationaliste si vous voulez beaucoup
plus à vif que nous qui avons construit
l'europe donc l'idée regarder que les
polonais regarder avec lecce avec les
les fédérales avaient effectivement le
souci je résiste
je voudrais que fabienne télé reprises
vous répondre je voudrais rappeler que
nul ne peut être discriminé en fonction
de sa religion son orientation sexuelle
c'est dans la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme à laquelle l'union
européenne a adhéré
en entrant dans l'union européenne en
lors tous les pays des dix pays y
compris la hongrie ont accepté l'acquis
communautaire et se sont assuré de la
conformité de leur constitution à
l'ensemble de de ce corpus donc que ce
soit aujourd'hui remise en cause par
certains états membres c'est une
décision récente puisque toutes les
évolutions devait être négocié de bonne
foi et éventuellement donner lieu à des
adaptations soit détecte nationaux soit
de la constitution mais ces divergences
qu'il semble découvrir aujourd'hui c'est
pas du tout hein c'est historique c'est
un fait volontaire de la part de la
hongrie comme d'ailleurs de la pologne
après je maintiens qu'il a une stratégie
de stigmatisation d'un certain nombre de
groupes sociaux et les lgbt y sont au
coeur il va organiser un référendum je
vous invite à lire les questions de ce
référendum vous ne pouvez pas voter
contre sorbonne en fait parce que les
questions sont trop caricatural il sera
donc il obtiendra donc un résultat qui
sera très impressionnant j'ai rencontré
l'adjoint au maire de budapest cet été
qui m'a expliqué la mise en place d'une
taxe sur les mairies sur la base d'un
critère soit disant objective mais dans
la pratique sur des mairie tenue par des
maires d'opposition voilà une bonne
technique pour encourager néons grand
optez plutôt pour des personnes
favorables à monsieur sorbonne c'est
tout un système que nos collègues dans
mon groupe il ya deux collègues
hongroise très engagée dans l'opposition
à monsieur norman nous décrypte
régulièrement c'est très subtil c'est ça
lille libéralisme et ça a les apparences
parfois peu la démocratie mais ça a tous
les outils des régimes autoritaires et
populistes comme cela a été dit tout à
l'heure mais moi je pense que ce qui est
intéressant ce moment sur l'union
européenne parce qu'en fait c'est sa
ligne de fracture c'est qu'il faut
absolument apprendre à se rencontrer et
c'est pour ça que quelque part la visite
de maquereaux au delà des questions
européennes
de politique intérieure extérieure elle
reste fondamental parce qu'on en parle
et en fait quand on regarde tous ces
pays là on voit que lille ont des
ruptures qui sont des ruptures
historiques qui ne sont pas les mêmes
que les nôtres et quand là on a une
frontière entre l'europe occidentale et
l'europe qui est plus centrale on a une
fracture qui effectivement par des
années de communisme qui fait que bien
le rappeler que ces pays retrouve la
liberté qui retrouve une économie qui
retrouve de l'argent et donc ils ne sont
pas près tout de suite à le partager
parce que lorsque vous discutez avec des
gens de notre âge ils vont tout de suite
vous rappeler leurs années de communisme
quand il était privé de pain ou de
viande et que donc il devait faire une
grande que au supermarché des choses
qu'on n'a pas connues nous donc du coup
ils ont encore cet appétit là ils vont
regarder la question migratoire
parce que derrière ils ont aussi
l'histoire commune avec l' empire
ottoman qui a effectivement à un moment
donné était sur leurs terres et donc il
restait plus d'un siècle effectivement
là dessus et donc tout cela ça permet en
fait d'aller discuter d'aller parler
d'aller comprendre pourquoi est ce qu'il
ya un entregent pourquoi est ce que pour
nous ça va pas nous effrayer mais pour
eux ça va encore être effrayant en quoi
est-ce qu'il faut s'en prémunir y
compris effectivement sur la notion de
valeurs chrétiennes qui est aussi la
notion refuge pour ces pays là comme
maintenant la russie qui joue
l'orthodoxie et tout ça en fait à partir
du moment donné où on arrive à
comprendre que les choses se font pas à
la même vitesse des pays les uns avec
les autres on comprend j'allais dire
mieux avec plus de tolérance ce qui est
en train de se passer ce sont les pays
qui se construisent aujourd'hui avec une
autre vision en disant votre vision
européenne occidentale elle nous fait
pas rêver nous vous ne serez pas rêver
quand vous êtes dans un entrain de nous
parler des questions trans genres vous
nous faites pas rêver quand vous êtes en
train d'expliquer qu' il faut que toute
l'europe soit ouverte et qu'on accueille
le flux de chacun donc la seule manière
à un moment donné de comprendre pourquoi
ce qu'ils disent il ne vous ne fait pas
rêver c'est pas de la femme et la porte
parce que sinon auront l'agora et on a
besoin de s'exprimer on a besoin de leur
ouvrir la porte de dire pourquoi et là
on évitera peut-être que certains
populistes et on discutera davantage
avec les gens et ce qui est intéressant
laetitia c'est que c'est exactement
finalement ce que emmanuel macron a
annoncé quand je parlais de soft power
il a dit clairement que l'objet de cette
visite c'est exactement c'est exactement
enjeux des manuels macron c'est de
convaincre les hongrois n'ont pas viktor
orban lui même mais la population
hongroise et il a dit en juin dernier
justement comme quand victor ban s'était
fait un peu remonté les bretelles
rappelé à l'ordre par la commission
européenne
à cause de cette loi qui interdit la
représentation de l'homosexualité pour
les moins de 18 ans en marge de ce
sommet manuel mâcon a pris la parole et
à assumer de façon officielle sa
stratégie est écoutée
doit faire un travail au corps à corps
avec les systèmes politiques médiatiques
les organisations sociales les
intellectuels dans ces pays d'abord pour
montrer qu'on ne cédera rien ensuite
étape par étape
sanctionnés justement les états membres
qui vont dans ces directions mais aussi
faire oeuvre de pédagogie et de
conviction et montrer aux sociétés
civiles que c'est une régression
terrible vers lesquels elle en faut être
dur avec les dirigeants et convaincant
avec les peuples
c'est intéressant à cette position dure
avec les dirigeants via les les voies de
la commission européenne on compte c'est
un il ya des process qui sont mis en
place pour conditionner ou pas certaines
aides en fonction des positions des
états mais en fait le projet d' emmanuel
macron c'est de convaincre la population
hongroise peut-être ne pas réélire
viktor orban ne me l'avait dit pour
l'instant il est réélu on verra bien ce
qui arrivera en avril mais en tout cas
c'est assumer officiellement d'habitude
ce soft power comme ça cette ingérence
indirects finalement est plutôt dit en
coulisses en aux faits et là c'est
assumé sur la scène européenne alors il
ne dit pas par quel moyen il va
atteindre cet objectif
est-ce qu'il commande et on arrive à
influencer les médias hongrois comment
on arrive à toucher les intellectuels il
ya certainement tout un réseau un en
coulisse mise en place français pour
aller parler aux en tout cas les pompes
et les passerelles sont effectivement
construite et puis sylvain kahn au delà
de ces leviers que cannes emmanuel
macron que de l'influencé française
pourrait voilà pourrait s'activer en
hongrie bon j'ai un peu l'impression que
le prix en français pourront peut-être
aussi un peu ses désirs pour des
réalités mais ce qu'il faut pas oublier
dans cette visite là c'est qu'il ya des
terrains d'entente et il ya même des
stratégiquement des points d'entente a à
travailler entre la france et la hongrie
dans la perspective de la présidence
française de l'union qui démarre en
janvier oui bah ça de toute façon disons
ya peint même si ça a fait un peu
étrange de dire ça il n'y a pas que
l'état de droit comme dossier qui est
sur la table mais juste pour revenir sur
ce qui a été dit précédemment
lui enfin qu'en dire je crois que l'on
gagnerait à considérer l'union
européenne comme tendanciellement comme
étant un pays c'est à dire que dire les
hongrois sont comme si les polonais sont
comme ça les anciens pays communistes
sont comme si c'est comme si on disait
imaginons que alors qu'on est plutôt on
est on est sur un plateau d'une émission
politique française et qu'on faisait
comme si les la france et les français
le vent a été un seul bloc alors que dès
qu'on parle de la vie politique
française on l'avait montré travers vos
reportages on est extrêmement sensible
aux nuances aux différences aux
confrontations aux oppositions mais
l'europe c'est pareil c'est à dire que
moi je crois qu'il faut voir emmanuel
macron en l'occurrence là en ce moment
comme le représentant d'un
un d'une grande partie de la société
politique et de la société européenne
tout court qui est majoritaire et puis
viktor orban comme on va dire le porte
parole sans doute le plus intelligent
d'une de la partie minoritaire de la
société politique et de la société
européenne encore une fois le maire de
budapest fait partie de l'opposition en
hongrie on parlait de vigie grade tout à
l'heure le premier minis l'ancien
premier ministre tchèque andrés babiche
qui est
poursuivi par la justice de son pays
pour des faits de corruption des
détournements d'argent notamment
européens vient de perdre le pouvoir il
a été mise en minorité donc faut faire
attention c'est pas c'est pas tout les
tchèques qui sont des îles libéraux
enfin oui et tout ça c'est en mouvement
et quand macron va en hongrie rencontrer
tout le monde on est bien dans le cadre
finalement d'un débat européen et le
parlement européen reflet de ça dont il
s'agit est ce que vous pensez qu'il a
une capacité par sa visite à influencer
à même à minima le scrutin
intérieur oui encore une fois parce que
il faut avoir une vision d'ensemble du
tableau c'est comme quand le
gouvernement polonais actuelle donc
mazowiecki kaczinsky a adoptée a fait
adopter par son parlement la législation
sur l'île vg l'interruption de grossesse
la plus restrictives d'europe est une
des plus restrictifs du monde voilà
effectivement et ça contrevient à la
charte de l'union européenne des droits
fondamentaux à la convention européenne
des droits de l'homme et c'est bon il ya
eu des manifestations monstres dans
toutes les villes de pologne et il ya eu
en écho des manifestations dans tout un
tas de pays européens qui se sentaient
concernés de la même manière que si
c'était chez eux voilà donc il ya une
vie politique à l'échelle européenne
mais ce que je peux poser une question
très naïve allons-y peut-être que les
français se posent quel serait le
problème si la hongrie ou la pologne
sortait de l'union européenne
aujourd'hui en bohême pour eux comme je
reconnais ça l'a dit la hongrie ses 10
millions d'habitants c'est un ce serait
pas une perte énorme pour l'union belge
tout dépend de quel point de vue on se
place en termes de poids ça représente
pas grand chose mais en le terme on va
dire de projet politique jacques delors
disait quelque chose du genre de toute
façon s'il ya des pays qui sont
problématiques ou avec lesquels on est
en tension il vaut mieux qu'on est les
tensions à l'intérieur ses taux qu'à
l'extérieur oui mais certainement la
possibilité à d'autres pays de s'en
aller parce que l'europe elle fonctionne
aussi par clans en quelque sorte donc là
pour l'instant on a laissé les anglais
ils braquent site mais si les polonais
avec le pôle excite n'auront on parle
venait à s'en aller il ya d'autres pays
qui se diraient ben pourquoi pas
finalement que c'est la stratégie de la
hongrie ça c'est plutôt dans l'europe
pour la wii est révolu et c'est pas
franchement pas en sortir mais si vous
voulez il faut prendre le film dans sa
continuité ancrer le marché comme un
marché commun c'était simple suffisait
d' abaisser les frontières et on était
entre eux pays qui avait à peu près des
économies de même niveau bois et puis
progressivement met en place un projet
politique encore une fois avec des gens
qui avaient des trajectoires des pays
qui avaient des trajectoires politiques
assez comparable et puis il ya tout à
coup ce bouleversement stratégique de la
disparition de l'urss de l'ouverture des
pays de l'est qui vont s'intégrer
évidemment non seulement dans le dans
l'union européenne mais dans le temps
bon et donc on a aussi voulait une
entité dont l'historique est tout à fait
différente
et découvrir que si vous voulez on
puisse avoir des points de vue
divergents dans cette construction à
27,29 je peux combien on est aujourd'hui
mais on est quand même quelque chose qui
par nature est hétérogène et donc si on
se met dans une position de censeur
morale en disant attention les clés de
l'état de droit vous savez moi je suis
très fasciné par cette notion d'état de
droit je vais vous en citer un exemple
quand en 1948 on adopte la convention
internationale des droits de l'homme les
cinq pays membres du punk conseil de
sécurité c'est les états unis qui sont
ségrégationniste et raciste c'est la
russie de staline c'est la chine de
l'embellie tchèque et c'est la france et
la grande bretagne qui sont les deux
grandes puissances coloniales de la
planète donc s'ils voulaient en matière
d'état de droite c'est faites ce que je
dis faites pas ce que je fais donc on
est sur quelque chose ou si on déplace
les limites de l'état de droit en
rajoutant à chaque fois des sujets on va
dire oui mais attendez vous rendez
compte que vous ne remplissez pas toutes
les cases donc un moment où il faut
accepter qui est une espèce de
frontières entre l'identité de chacun si
les polonais votre contrôle ivg c'est
parce que c'est très fondamentalement un
pays catholique etc ce pays catholique
c'est parce qu'il était catholique il à
résister à l'air et c'est ce dont vous
n'avez pas toutes a cogné le fait que y
ait cet arrière-fond points devant moi
je n'y rien ça fait deux fois que vous
me dites vous reconnaissez-vous dans mes
côtés ben non mais c'est vrai que vous
voyez bien que l'exemple de la pologne
est l'exemple même transposer de quelque
chose vous avez identité nationale qui
pensent que la loi européenne n'est pas
la norme qui veulent appliquer chez eux
il faut le reconnaître il ya une
majorité élue au parlement polonais qui
pensent ça et il ya 80% des femmes
polonaises qui sont pas d'accord il faut
mais ya quand même des dirigeants
indiens débat démocratique qui a créé
son parti et qui a certainement ou
peut-être en tout cas croit thiélin
destin avec la france qui veulent
revenir à une europe très resserré c'est
un projet qui est sur le papier massi
soit 7 enfin je veux dire c'est pas non
plus
ont posé sur la table non mais on se
rend compte que l'état de droit si les
centrales après c'est quelle place à
l'état de droit dans l'union européenne
est ce que oui ou non c'est la condition
sinequanone pour appartenir à l'union
européenne on peut se la poser cette
question si c'est oui dans ces cas là il
faut resserrer l'europe autour des pays
qui respecte l'état de droit et puis je
vous demander finition européenne je
reprends la mapar dompierre connais ça
pour donner la parole une dernière fois
à fabienne keller et je reviens à la
question je posais à sylvain kahn tout à
l'heure sur l'un des enjeux parce qu'on
l'a pas vraiment abordés delà de la
visite des manuels macron c'est
effectivement d'aller chercher quand
même viktor orban et la hongrie comme un
allié potentiel sur certains dossiers je
pense notamment au nucléaire on sait
qu'il ya une question très importante
qui se joue en ce moment entre la france
et l'allemagne sur ce qu'on appelle la
taxonomie verte c'est-à-dire comment
l'europe va flécher le financement de la
transition écologique et énergétique est
ce que le nucléaire on fera partie là
c'est un allié de la france victor o ben
c'est un allié de sept puisque à peu
près la moitié de son énergie est
d'origine nucléaire comme là c'est bien
son style il dit être allié sur la
souveraineté européenne et l'autonomie
stratégique il avait symboliquement
envoyé quelques soldats pour la force
t'as bu cas au mali
mais là aussi identifions bien ça sa
finesse il n'a pas tort sur tout et je
ne crois pas du tout qu'il souhaite
sortir de l'union d'abord parce que ses
concitoyens ne le souhaite pas ils sont
très europhile il circule d'ailleurs
beaucoup en europe 1-le les
intellectuels et une personne du monde
de l'économie
travail avec et circule dans tout dans
toute l'europe ce n'est pas souhaitable
et l'europe le finance très fortement et
à aider et continuer à aider massivement
la transition de l'ensemble de son
économie donc il est réaliste il veut
rester dans l'europe et c'est là qu'il
faut qu'il accepte que ya des règles
quand on est en europe il ya des valeurs
communes des valeurs démocratiques et
moi je serais beaucoup plus optimiste
salut quand la grèce le portugal et
l'espagne ont rejoint l'union européenne
il sortait de dictature militaire
l'économie a permis d'accompagner et de
consolider démocratie une croissance qui
a nourri voilà une évolution de ces pays
qui qui a permis l'émergence de régimes
stables ça n'est pas pour l'instant le
cas de manière aussi positive dans les
pays dits de l'est moi je forme le voeu
que cette dynamique européenne ce projet
partagé par l'ensemble de ce peuple
européen qui a été décrit tout à l'heure
et bien puisse amener l'ensemble des
pays de l'est à ce respect des valeurs
fondamentales auxquelles nous sommes
très attachés et qui les ont tous tous
les hongrois accepté en 2004 merci
beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je rappelle le titre de vos
ouvrages respectifs sylvain kahn
histoire de la construction de l'europe
depuis 1945 aux puf et pire connaissait
le lobby saoudien en france comment
vendre un pays invendable c'est aux
éditions denoël merci à tous encore une
fois ne ratez pas tout à leur sens
public continue évidemment ne ratez pas
notre second débat vous le savez il est
volontairement décalée de l'actualité
est plus prospective débat de société
qui est consacré ce soir la grave crise
des hôpitaux publics français 20% de
lits fermés faute de personnel ces
chiffres du conseil scientifique sont
contestés par le ministère de la santé
mais c'est bien d'une crise structurelle
dont on parle le constat des pistes de
réforme aussi à découvrir dans moins de
dix minutes mais d'abord mais d'abord
notre
rubrique les électeurs ont la parole
c'est parti
les électeurs ont la parole chaque soir
un reportage au coeur des territoires la
rédaction de public sénat qui part à
votre rencontre on est à saint malo ce
soir où la mairie se bat contre les
propriétaires qui louent uniquement sur
les plates formes comme airbnb il faut
dire que le nombre de logements proposés
sur ces plateformes a été multiplié par
dix depuis 2000 14 sandra cerqueira
véronique habite le centre ville de
saint malo depuis 30 ans dans une
ancienne maison divisée en trois
appartements
mais en 2015 arrivent les premiers
touristes ses voisins de palier ont mis
leur bien en location sur une plateforme
en ligne très vite les nuisances se font
sentir
du jour au lendemain on croisait son
voisin et puis là on croise état d'un
connu comme dans un hall de gare qui
rentre et qui sortent et il se trouve
qu'au fur et à mesure en nous on se rend
compte qu'on ne se sent plus chez nous
les paliers encombrer les portes
ouvertes la sécurité on voit sa vie
complètement altérée en fait après cinq
ans de combat elle obtient gain de cause
devant le tribunal et a voulu inscrire
son action dans une démarche collective
avec franck ils ont créé un collectif
pour fédérer d'autres villes françaises
impactés même si ces séjours
touristiques de courte durée sont
limitées par la loi à 120 jours par an
certains propriétaires y voit une manne
financière notamment depuis que saint
malo est à peine à deux heures de paris
avec la lune grande vitesse en 2014 il y
avait 300 logements locatifs sur les
plateformes ils sont aujourd'hui 3000
soit un tiers du parc immobilier de la
ville la massification des locations de
courte durée a accentué le prix de
l'immobilier notamment par ba l'achat
par ce qu'on appelle de plusieurs
appartements par un seul propriétaire
qui préfère mettre en location de courte
durée plutôt qu'en location l'année
effectivement on assista
de spéculation immobilière de bulle
immobilière finalement dans les rues du
centre les boîtes à claix se sont
multipliés si vous attaquez ça voilà de
finalement la transformation des
locations contenus
personnels y compris dans une des
laveries de la ville une boîte où on
peut récupérer jusqu'à 25 clé les
magasins aussi se sont mis à changer
petit à petit les magasins de vêtements
pour enfants pharmacie boucher et qui
ont été remplacés par des magasins liés
au tourisme nous avions des commerçants
qui était lié à saint malo qui habitait
à saint malo et on a vu avec puisque
c'est souvent remplacés par des
franchisés donc des multipropriétaires
de commerce qui sont plus liés à saint
malo qui habite à caen à parité terrain
on peut des fois qualifié intra muros de
de disneyland quelque part qui ce qui
soude manche simon michel isation si on
peut dire ça et qui est extrêmement
regrettable qu'il ya encore des
habitants qui veulent éviter certains
voudraient même venir et y revivre pour
lutter contre ce phénomène la mairie a
instauré depuis cet été de nouvelles
règles parmi les plus restrictives de
france en mettant en place un quota de
logements éligibles à la location de
courte durée en fonction des quartiers
de la ville on a appliqué des quotas de
nombre de logements qui sont éligibles
au changement d'usagé et deuxième
critère croisés nous limitons à un
logement par propriétaires qu'ils
puissent et demi à la location meublée
de courte durée aux biens par
propriétaire par personne
donc physique ce qui fait que bon voilà
ça peut se démultiplier quand même dans
le cas d'une famille on a fait une photo
à l'instant t du marché et nous avons
dit nous stoppons le développement donc
on l'a pas restreint on a simplement dit
on le stop au stade où il est
aujourd'hui les propriétaires des
logements locatifs concernés ont lancé
une procédure judiciaire
il estime que ces règles sont contraires
à la loi et que la mairie a outrepassé
ses compétences voilà on va plus loin
avec jean virgile crance convient
d'entendre dans le reportage premier
adjoint au maire de saint malo bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous dans ce sens
public vous avez pris cette décision au
printemps dernier si on rentre un peu
plus dans le détail est ce que vous en
voyez déjà les effets
bonsoir on va écouter c'est un peu tôt
pour dire que ça produit tous ses effets
mais oui on commence à voir les prémices
des effets escomptés puisque un certain
nombre de biens immobiliers reviennent
sur le marché soit à la vente soit à la
location est l'objectif vous l'avez
compris c'est d'une part donc de
retrouver une partie d'offres donc
locatives ou à l'achat mais d'offre de
logement et d'autre part surtout de
stopper la prolifération trop
importantes et trop rapides de ce type
de location ce qui est important à bien
intégrer c'est que pour nous c'est une
disposition dans le cadre d'un projet
global de politique d'urbanisme qui a
d'ailleurs fait débat pendant la
campagne électorale et c'est en fin de
compte la multitude d'un certain nombre
d'actions et de dispositions qui nous
permettra d'améliorer la situation de
l'urbanisme à saint malo qui est
extrêmement compliqué l'enjeu c'est de
garder tout simplement de la vie dans la
ville au coeur de ville
alors tout à fait nous avions dit
d'ailleurs pendant la campagne
électorale qu on s'opposait à ce que
saint malo devienne la venue de miss
bretonne et comme il a été dit dans
votre reportage le problème c'est
qu'après c'est tout un écosystème qui
est impactée et nous avons considéré que
si nous ne faisons rien avant la fin de
notre mandat très probablement que toute
une partie de quartier de partie de la
ville se serait trouvé vidée de ses
habitants et donc du coup par
conséquence vous perdez aussi un certain
nombre de commerces de proximité vous
perdez une partie d'activités à l'année
et salut nous y sommes farouchement
opposés
j'aurais qu'on écoute maintenant
toujours avec nous en direct dans ce
sens public daniel salmon qu'est le
sénateur d'ille-et-vilaine membres du
groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires dont soir daniel seulement
est-ce que vous approuver l'action de la
mairie de saint malo
bonsoir oui tout à fait c'est une
décision courageuse une action qui était
qui est très légitime
j'étais pas plus tard que vendredi à la
rencontre du collectif saint malo j'y
vis j'y reste des gens qui sont
objectivement confrontée comme le montre
le reportage à de grosses nuisances on a
une ville aujourd'hui une ville qui se
construit sans habitante avec des gens
n'est pas isolé dans l'eure dans leur
immeuble et donc il faut réagir parce
que on a un vrai de souffrance une vraie
d'être est qu'on a rencontré près de
près ces personnes et donc il ya aussi
une problématique je vais dire social et
économique voire écologique puisque les
gens qui travaillent sur saint malo ne
trouve plus à s'y loger et donc soit
obligé de faire de nombreux kilomètres
bien souvent en voiture particulière
donc des pertes de temps des coûts
inhérents à ces déplacements et donc une
espèce passion donc il ya vraiment un
problème il ya également un problème
culturel je dirai juste pour terminer
parce qu'on a eue avec ce genre de
tourisme on a une muséographie donc 2 de
la ville et on a donc une culture d eau
qu'alcatraz de disparaître on est sur
origin au charisme de rencontre je reste
avec vous d'agnès allemand et qu'est ce
que vous attendez de l'état est ce que
vous attendez une loi un cadre plus
contraignant parce qu'il ya d'autres
villes qui sont dans la même situation
que que saint malo oui c'est exactement
ça la problématique c'est à dire que là
c'est quoi quel saint malo intra muros
mais effectivement si on reste au niveau
très localisés comme cela on déporte un
peu le sujet et on voit que déjà les
boîtes à clés sont en train d'apparaître
dans d'autres quartiers de saint malo
voir les d'autres quartiers comme ça
servant comme paramé voix de ces moines
à terre dans d'autres villes également
c'est assez courant comme à dinard et
sur tout le littoral breton donc il ya
besoin d'avoir quelque chose qui se joue
non pas seulement au niveau local mais
au niveau régional voire national
je remercie d'ailleurs seulement je
reviens vers vous jean virgile crance
pour vraiment un mode rapide de
conclusion même question je sais pas si
on vous entend toujours oui même
question sur ce que vous vous attendez
vous que vous avez agit localement est
ce que vous avez besoin d'un soutien au
niveau national alors on a besoin d'un
soutien au niveau national d'une part
pour
clarifier la situation de la sci
familiale c'est à dire aujourd'hui les
droits d'enregistrement sont données
qu'à des personnes physiques et non
morale c'est la loi qui nous l'imposent
cela dit c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup de
pétitionnaires qui nous revendique le
fait qu' ils peuvent être sur la statue
de sci familiale et à partir du moment
où la vocation de cette es6 et
simplement la transmission d'un
patrimoine et non une activité
commerciale développée alors auquel cas
nous ne serions tout à fait savoir à ce
que dans le cadre d'une et si familial
mais faut-il avoir défini juridiquement
ce qu'est une sci familiale alors nous
le serions favorables à ce que le
législateur
clarifie ce point là après sur les
dispositions que nous prenons il me
semble indispensable que en fin de
compte ce cette règle de numéro
d'enregistrement et de changement
d'usagé soit appliquée pour la totalité
des communes de france quelle que soit
leur taille et leur situation puisque
après c'est proportionnel bien entendu à
ce que la commune souhaitera mettre en
place et je rappelle sur saint malo nous
avons mis en place des quotas par
quartier on a défini quatre grands
secteurs qui nous permettent en effet de
quantifier le nombre de logements
éligibles à ce changement visage ce qui
nous permet de le cadrer cette activité
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
jean virgile crance premier adjoint au
maire de saint malo et daniel seulement
le sénateur écologiste d'ille-et-vilaine
merci encore à tous les deux je passe
tout de suite à notre second débat
directement liée à la commission d'
enquête du sénat sur la situation dans
les hôpitaux publics français les
premières auditions elles ont lieu la
semaine dernière et face à la cinquième
vague de kovy 19 c'est tout l'édifice
qui menace de s'effondrer flora sauvage
à deux semaines des fêtes de fin d'année
la pression s'accroît sur l'hôpital on
compte actuellement plus de 14 mille
malades du coït 19 hospitalisés et 2600
personnes en soins critiques
le directeur général des hôpitaux de
paris propose une incitation financière
aux soignants qui acceptent de décaler
leurs congés auditionné au sénat la
semaine dernière le président de la
fédération hospitalière de france
frédéric valletoux a rappelé les
fragilités de l'hôpital qui existait
déjà avant la crise ducobu 19 il faut
rappeler que l'hôpital a abordé la crise
avec 30% de postes de praticiens
hospitaliers vacants il faut rappeler
que les tensions sur les recrutements
toucher aussi les deux infirmiers
infirmières les postes d'aides-soignants
bref qu à tous les étages de l'hôpital
les tensions sur les effectifs étaient
déjà le quotidien des établissements
bien avant la crise pour éviter un
engorgement huit régions ont activé
leurs plans blancs il permet de
déprogrammer des opérations de
réquisitionner du personnel de reporter
leurs projets et de rappeler certains
soignants en vacances une situation
tendue alors que les soignants estime
que le ségur de la santé le plan pour
l'hôpital qui devait revaloriser les
métiers n'a pas porté ses fruits quand
le médicament n'est pas bon quand peu
ségur eh ben c'est pas le bon médicament
c'est tout monsieur véran il faut
changer de médicament nafia mer de
nuages gagnent 1 euro de l'heure un euro
de l'heure donc les français doivent le
savoir parce que les soignants qui sont
encore en place ils en ont marre aussi
ils vont finir par partir et à jour on
aura un système de santé sans soignants
alors que depuis 2000 13 27 mille lits
d'hôpitaux ont été supprimés en france
aujourd'hui un lit sur cinq est fermés
faute de personnel pour ne pas
surcharger l'hôpital le président de la
fédération hospitalière de france
frédéric valletoux appelle les médecins
libéraux à reporter leurs congés de fin
d'année
l'hôpital public français en grand
danger voilà le thème de notre débat je
vous présente mes invités vo ni
guillotin bonsoir vous êtes médecin
sénatrice radicale de meurthe-et-moselle
vice présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales est membre de cette
commission d' enquête dont on parlait
commission des enquêtes du sénat sur la
situation de nos hôpitaux j'accueille
également benjamin rossi bonsoir soir
bienvenue vous êtes infectiologues au
centre hospitalier intercommunal
d'aulnay sous bois et vous publiez en
première ligne c'est chez prisma édition
frédéric bizarrement soit au soir
bienvenue à vous aussi professeur
d'économie prégnant l'institut santé
votre livre l'autonomie solide et en
santé la seule réforme public possible
c'est aux éditions michalon laetitia que
pas été évidemment rester à mes côtés
ces auditions de la commission denquête
elles reprennent le 16 ce jeudi au sénat
avec je crois les représentants des
services d'urgence c'est ça je vous
propose bien d'écouter à un autre
extrême on a eu certains dans le
reportage mais d'une audition qui a eu
lieu la semaine dernière c'était celle
de patrick goudot et vice-président de
l'intersyndicat national des praticiens
hospitaliers
n'espérait que segura les résoudre tous
les maux sont accrus que l'hôpital
d'après serait pas comme l'hôpital
d'avant non non il est pas tout à fait
comme avant il est bien nous sommes en
réalité face aux conséquences d'une
spirale négative d'ing qui est mise en
exergue qui a été mise en exergue par le
cos vide après l' alerte
des collectifs un terreau urgence un
terreau hospitalier qui avait précédé ce
cet événement cette pandémie et cette
situation donc a conduit à la démission
nombreux praticiens y compris parmi nos
rangs hospitalo universitaire avec
toutes les conséquences que ça
représente en matière de formation de
recherche etc
la situation est pire qu'avant la crise
qu vidé ce que véronique guillotin c'est
la taule in tonalité générale des
premières auditions oui c'est la
tonalité générale je pense que c'est pas
que des auditions d'ailleurs ce qu'on
entend sur le terrain dans les hôpitaux
chez les jeunes voilà on sent bien qu'on
redémarre cette crise qui est une crise
assez violentes et la situation des
effectifs à l'hôpital est inférieure à
ce qu'elle était avant la première crise
donc ça rend les choses plus compliquées
et parler de spirale négative c'est ce
que je dis toujours effectivement moi ya
de monde plus c'est compliqué puis ça
fait perdre les gens plus a fait fuir
les gens enfin les personnels et du coup
sûr une période de crise mais voilà on
est dans une situation aujourd'hui fin
dramatique dans les hôpitaux failli bise
à vous parlez souvent de la perte de
sens à l'hôpital ça aussi ça s'aggrave
d'une certaine façon ce que viens de
décrire la sénatrice oui absolument moi
ce qui me frappe quand même c'est le la
forme d'impuissance politique on a
vraiment l'impression que c'est pas
propre au gouvernement mais on a
l'impression que la classe politique est
impuissante face à ce problème d'abord
on était j'ai été frappé par le projet
de loi de financement de sécurité
sociale qui quand même et historiquement
montre un déséquilibre durable des
comptes sociaux en pleine crise du
système de santé avec un système de
retraites dont on n'a échoué que l'on a
échoué donc là et finalement sans qu'il
y ait de débat de fond on peut être
d'accord ou pas d'accord et sans qu'il y
ait de solution proposée est là c'est la
même chose finalement on voit bien que
au delà et la visite par exemple du
premier ministre a au chu de strasbourg
il ya deux jours montre cette
impuissance politique pré ministre
arrivait dire écoutez je vais sauver
l'hôpital je vais rajouter 20 millions
d'euros parce que l'hôpital était au
bord du lac cessation de paiement ce
strasbourg strasbourg était
de strasbourg et donc uni veille et sans
aucune solution sans aucune espoirs dont
qui a forcé - des parce que c'est pas
aux médecins à régler les médecins
doivent être partie prenante pour régler
cette solution met donc il faut bien
quand même que les politiques est une
vision d'avenir de l'hôpital public mais
du prochain modèle de santé parce que la
crise et des sram entre animaux
l'hôpital public qui était au coeur du
modèle de 45 notamment avec les
ordonnances de bris en fait est
l'épicentre d'une crise mais qui est
systémique donc à la fois la crise
systémique et la solution est systémique
et donc il faut on ne trouvera pas de
solution au sein de l'hôpital public qui
voit bien que tout se désagrège et qui
en plus à une crise sanitaire dans la
crise systémique qui fait que la en
effet on est dans une situation très
grave du fait de la crise sanitaire mais
c'est pas la crise sanitaire qui a mis
par terre l'hôpital public et puis
évidemment on développera cet aspect
c'est la crise systémique et
éventuellement des des solutions
d'épilation béthune saurait revenir
benjamin aussi à ce que voulait dire
c'est que en fait les hôpitaux se sont
sont maintenant responsables de leur
dette d'une certaine façon quand quand
le premie nice dit je viens sauver
l'hôpital de strasbourg c'est ya un peu
de ça je sais pas c'est comment comment
ça se passe chez vous ça veut dire quoi
c'est à dire qu'il ya du matériel que
vous pouviez pas commander acheté par
hasard oui oui en fait nous on avait
commencé à faire un mouvement sur
l'hôpital pendant le mois de juillet
2019 puisqu'on a un hôpital et j'en
parle dans le livre on a un hôpital qui
est soi-disant sans papiers donc ça veut
dire que tout est informatisé les
ordonnances de sortir par l'informateur
par l'ordinateur on n'avait plus qu'à
tout genre et le prestataire ne pouvait
pas livré les cartouches d'encre et
s'ils n'avaient pas été payés par
l'hôpital depuis trois ans donc en fait
pendant la crise covivo fait retrouver
en manque de gaz du sang donc c'est un
test un réactif qui nous permet de
mesurer le taux d'oxygénation des
patients on peut comprendre que pendant
la crise kovy de première vague ne plus
pouvoir avoir de gaz du sens à cette
problématique on avait pu découvrir on
pouvait plus payer découvrions pour vous
donc en fait on a eu une série comme ça
donc de blocage on a des problèmes de
pour affréter les médicaments donc
l'hôpital est défaillant on réussit pas
à commander du nouveau matériel tout est
vétuste on a plus de couette on a plus
de bus circulent hier
voilà il faut quand même comprendre que
les gens qui se lancent comme les
infirmières les aide soignante pour
s'occuper des gens ils ont au coeur
l'idée de prendre en charge les gens
bien ceux des gens qui ont une mentalité
qui est plutôt empathique et c'est pour
ça qu'ils font ce métier quand on leur
dit ben en fait ils sont insultés par
les patients parce qu'il ya pas de
cuillères parce qu'il a pas deux passes
cas pas de couverture parce qu'il fait
froid parce qu'à pas de chauffage pas ce
qu a pâti etc ils ont l'impression
d'être maltraitant ça les met dans une
situation d'impuissance est forcément
forcément il part ils partent donc en
fait le problème de l'hôpital public et
un problème de salaires il ya un
problème aussi de disparités mais ça on
pourrait peut-être en parlais tout à
l'heure entre entre l'argent public
qu'on donne aux privés et l'argent
public qu'on donne au public puisque ça
c'est quand même assez aberrant et ça
fait partir quand même un bon nombre de
soignants et de médecins surtout mais il
ya aussi un problème de en fait
d'environnement c'est à dire qu'on a à
un moment fait il ya une loi qui a été
fait en 2008 qui fait que l'ensemble du
budget d'un hôpital l'hôpital se paye en
facturant un maximum à la sécurité
sociale les actes qui sont faits c'est
une pareille pour les cliniques etc sauf
que l'hôpital ne choisit pas les actes
puisqu'il doit en fait on sait qu'à une
inégalité avec des spécialités qui sont
plus rentables que loeb que d'autres et
donc les hôpitaux qui vont faire de
l'argent vont se spécialiser dans les
actes les plus rentables et des fois il
ya des patients avec ses grilles qui
sont plus rentables que d'autres donc
ils vont ils vous choisir les patients
les plus rentables le privé va choisir
voilà et donc l'épisode
va prendre sa part en facturant avec des
actes qui ne sont pas qu'est-ce qui se
passe le trou de la sécurité sociale qui
disparaît puisque l'assiette et est
répartie un peu comme ça est en fête et
mis dans tous les hôpitaux de france et
navarre et donc en fait tous les
hôpitaux de france sont surendettés ils
ne peuvent plus rien payer ils ne
peuvent plus payer leur personnel faut
quand même voir que dans notre service
on parle de deux filles des soignants
mais des titulaires fayyad et il ya des
il ya des soignants qui sont là depuis
10 ans 11 ans et qui sont pas titulaires
et donc c'est à dire qu'ils sont bloqués
dans leurs grilles de salaire à échelon
1 ça veut dire qu'ils ne peuvent pas
avoir de progression et depuis dix ans
ils sont pas titularisés et l'hôpital
maintenant les ars 10 va titulariser les
mets l'hôpital n'a pas l'argent pour les
titulariser et l'état ne donne pas
l'argent à l'hôpital pour pouvoir le
faire donc on est dans une
puissance 1 alors j'ai je vais vous
présenter prisca thévenot qui vient de
nous rejoindre qui est porte-parole
évidemment de de la république en marche
merci d'être avec nous dans cette
émission
vous avez peut-être entendu s'cusez
frédéric bise à tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que ça va bien au delà de ce
quinquennat ou de ce gouvernement mais
est-ce qu'il ya pas eu quand même avec
le ségur et avec finalement ce contexte
inédit historique de crise sanitaire une
petite grande occasion manquée pour tout
remettre à plat et lancer cette grande
réforme
alors effectivement je rejoins ce
qualité des avancées que la crise
sanitaire a mis en exergue des
difficultés qui existent depuis
longtemps sur le système de santé le
système de santé effectivement
hospitalier mais également les systèmes
de santé en ville maintenant l'objet
n'est effectivement pas de chercher des
responsables mais plutôt de trouver des
solutions et je peux pas dire qui on
peut que le ségur de la santé est une
occasion manquée puisqu'elle apporte
quand même des réponses des réponses sur
l'investissement et le désendettement
des hôpitaux comme le docteur viennent
le dire juste avant des investissements
aussi en matériel en matériel du
quotidien pour que celles et ceux qui
n'ont pour soigner au quotidien puissent
travailler dans des situations dignes
des rebelles au risation salariale etc
maintenant est ce qu'il s'agit de dire
aujourd'hui qu'il s'agit de se
satisfaire de tout cela est de se dire
que c'est bon tout est fait et qu'on n'a
plus qu'a avancé nous je pense qu'il
s'agit d'une première étape et
d'ailleurs les annonces qui se suivent
sur le segment de la santé se poursuivre
pas plus tard que je crois que c'était
la semaine dernière olivier ferrand
continue d'ailleurs ce travail avec les
fédérations représentant en ayant signé
un protocole d'accord pour justement
travailler dans le détail très précis
des modalités de mise en place des
réformes de financement donc on voit que
ce travail c'est le début d'un long
cheminement qui bien évidemment a
commencé dès l'année dernière avec la
crise sanitaire qui a rappelé que
l'urgence était d'agir très rapidement
mais ce n'est pas fini ça doit se
poursuivre mais je vais vous redonner la
parole vous pourrez réagir évidemment
pris ce quinté nommé frédéric bizarre
c'est pas la grande réforme dont vous
parlez c'est pas la remise à plat dont
vous parlez non fois le ségur de la
santé était je pense nécessaire pour
faire passer cette crise sanitaire à
l'hôpital qui véritablement risquait de
devoir une fuite de ses ressources
humaines du fait d'un découragement
quand vous augmenter la charge de
travail sur un personnel qui est déjà
assez démotivés et qui est mal payé
forcément la voyelle donc moi je gagne
quand même mais si c'était en partie à
cette fuite donc
jusqu'à maintenant mais je donc jeudi
après je vais vous dire ce que je pense
qu'ils étaient insuffisantes d'abord il
a été mal ficelée parce que je pense que
de donner à tout le monde quel que soit
son sa compétence la même somme d'argent
est une fausse bonne idée de ne pas
avoir été revalorisé les tâches pénibles
la pénibilité qui est extrêmement
importante à l'hôpital est une erreur
profonde en tant qu il ya eu des erreurs
dans ce fait ça mais il était nécessaire
maintenant est ce que c'est la réforme
structurelle qui va permettre à
l'hôpital de sortir de la crise
certainement pas certainement pas
personne de sérieux ne peut dire ça
juste deux choses
l'hôpital je pense qu'après 20 ans de
crise à l'hôpital parce que ses vingt
ans de crise à l'hôpital on voit bien
que la vie à l'hôpital se dégradent les
conditions sociales se dégrade à
l'hôpital et notamment à l'hôpital
public même si on viendra sur cette
opposition
public privé qui est à mon avis assez
stérile mais en tout cas il ya une crise
depuis 20 ans donc faut peut-être se
poser la question si l'état et le bon
gestionnaire si l'état est vraiment un
bon manager un bon gestionnaire de
l'hôpital public peut-être qu'il faut
repenser la gouvernance et le peut-être
c'est qu'il faut certainement repenser
la gouvernance cave ou qu'avons nous
fait depuis 20 ans en gros on a augmenté
cette étatisation qui se traduit par une
bureaucratisation sans feu et on a des
médicalisé la gouvernance dans l'hôpital
c'est à dire qu'on a de bons à penser
que le problème c'était que les médecins
avaient trop de pouvoir au sein de
l'hôpital d'accord donc finalement le
médecin se retrouve en effet sans réel
pouvoir donc l'administration décidé
organisme mais ça on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas c'est pas très surprenant
d'ailleurs mais on voit bien que ça ne
fonctionne pas donc à la fois
l'extérieur de l'hôpital il faut
repenser la place de l'état ça s'éteint
c'est un sujet éminemment politique quel
doit être le rôle de l'état demain dans
le futur système de santé c'est
certainement pas de s'occuper de
l'organisation des services de l'hôpital
si après ses vingt ans de crise on n'a
pas compris que c'est pas à l'hôpital de
gérer l'hôpital public ça veut pas dire
que le pire ne le sait pas mais
attardons non ça ne veut pas dire encore
une fois que l'état doit se retirer doit
pas avoir les tailles doit être
stratégie doit être régulateur doit
s'assurer mais un set cette autonomie
hospitalière d'ailleurs dont on parle
beaucoup dans les discours il est
peut-être temps de l'abattre ont glissé
un constat qui est partagée ouais ce que
dit est ce que dit monsieur s'est
partagé par beaucoup de candidats à
l'élection présidentielle s'est partagé
depuis 20 ans il ya vraisemblablement un
problème d'organisation dans l'hôpital
de gouvernance l héroïsme disco les
candidats les candidats ils le disent
puisque arnaud montebourg dit par
exemple la gauche il dit oui il y à 30 %
de personnel dans les hôpitaux qui sont
chargés de contrôler des autres oui
c'est 35 6 35 secondes administrative
wallace et 30% et peut-être les remettre
au contact des des malades un homme au
contact des soignants pour les aider
valérie pécresse dit exactement la même
chose et dis moi je vais embaucher 25
mille soignants supplémentaires dans
l'hôpital sur cinq en tout temps des
bureaucrates is an parce que
effectivement il n'y a pas assez de
monde en première ligne pour reprendre
un peu le champ lexical du président
pendant la pandémie donc il faut plus de
personnel vraiment aux côtés des malades
etc ce problème là dans l'hôpital bon
marine le pen elle dit que effectivement
il ya eu la non compensation des 35
heures que les immigrés étouffe les
systèmes comme eric zemmour mais elle
parle aussi d'une par exemple d'une
fraude à la carte vitale qui est
responsable de la faillite de l'hôpital
donc voyez ça c'est des petites mesures
qui sont vraiment original par rapport
au corpus qui est vraiment unanime à qui
et c'est un bloc tous tous tous à gauche
comme à droite qui veulent augmenter les
salaires pour lutter contre la pénurie
ils veulent en finir avec le numerus
clausus est toujours plus
à toi emmanuel macron le veut aussi
emmanuel macron l'a proposé aussi pour
le ségur de la santé c'est ça qui est
incompréhensible m'attendais
on y lit alors sur le côté administratif
suit je suis d'accord qu'il ya trop
d'administratifs et pas s est fait dans
un hôpital et que la miss ratier juste
quand vous me dites que vous manquez de
deux cartouches d'encre il ya 30%
apparemment d'administratifs en trop ils
sont pas capables de commander des
cartes et je me
sens pas le budget c'est juste un
problème de buté mais il ya un problème
à la fois d'administratifs effectivement
je pense qu'il ya cette rotative être
administrative mais ce n'est pas le seul
problème il faut changer le système de
rémunération il faut qu'on arrête de
faire une rémunération à l'activité on
peut pas être on peut pas gérer la santé
comme on gère une entreprise de manière
de du business c'est à dire la
tarification à l'acte à tarification à
l'acte on peut pas dire on sait quand
xavier bertrand a été mis en place en
fait ça existe ça a commencé a commencé
en 2001 et après ça a terminé en 2008 et
mieux de voler c'est pour lui pour les
hôpitaux 1 mais on peut prendre on peut
enfin moi j'ai travaillé dans des jets
travailler dans des cliniques et j'ai
travaillé dans des établissements qui
fonctionnaient un peu manière différente
et on peut pas dire à quelqu'un vous
allez gagner 30 euros de consultation si
vous opérez pas et 1200 si vous opérez
ça il ya un biais il ya un biais qui se
fait que la personne va plus faire
certaines interventions il ya un biais
inflationnistes qui est fait de cette
tarification ça pousse à faire des actes
qui sont pas forcément nécessaire ça
pour ça rajouter des examens qui sont
pas nécessaires ils sont en train de par
exemple de privatiser nous notre notre
système de radiologie de sur l'hôpital
d'accord un scanner thoraco avoue ne pas
bien quand il tord axe abdomen pelvis
c'est on va dire sans au thorax seul ses
80 euros abdomen pelvis et 80 euros donc
ils vont faire revenir le patient deux
fois pour faire l'examen double
irradiation pour pouvoir gagner plus
d'argent c'est comme ça que ça
fonctionne une tarification à l'activité
et donc c'est pas efficients ça ira dit
deux fois le malade saint-jacques deux
fois le produit contraste c'est
dangereux pour le patient donc c'est pas
dans l'intérêt du malade donc il ya
aussi un problème une réflexion qu'il
faut qu'on est tous de manière
collective sur le système de
rémunération des mets des soignants
alors se proposera quant à calmer nous
de nous rejoindre
la parole juste après
les terres parce que vous allez nous
faire bon soir quand un but justement
11.1 peu plus détaillée des premières
auditions devant la commission d'enquêté
du sénat tout a augmenté à l'origine de
cette commune oui voilà c'est ce que je
vais vous proposer de remonter à
l'origine elle est venue d'une demande
dlr cette commission d'enquêté est le
point de départ c'est un chiffre que
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure thomas
cse 20% de lit qui sont bien fermés
faute de soignants dans les grands
hôpitaux publics c'est ce chiffre qui
avait été donnée par le conseil
scientifique qui a fait réagir jusque
donc au sénat y avait que cette demande
de commission d'enquêté alors ce chiffre
on le sent il est contesté par le
gouvernement et il interroge quand même
sur l'état notre santé notre système de
santé en france et donc la première
étape jeudi dernier c'était
effectivement d'auditionner les
représentants des personnels soignants
est effectivement comme vous l'avez déjà
un peu évoqué un leur constat est sans
appel sur la situation de l'hôpital au
delà même de la gestion de l'épidémie de
cause il ya une situation qui date comme
ça depuis plusieurs années et surtout
ces départs massifs de soignants qui ont
été décrits comme des vagues de départ
pendant les auditions et qui sont
directement liés à des décisions
budgétaires y compris des décisions
budgétaires récente vous parliez de la
loi de finances celle qui était examinée
l'année dernière et bien ça ça a eu des
conséquences directes écoutez un
représentant des infirmiers
830 millions d'économies imposées aux
hôpitaux pour la performance interne 215
millions d'euros d'économies imposées
aux hôpitaux pour structurer les
parcours de soins efficient ce qui
entraîné donc une deuxième vague de
départs d'infirmiers et
d'aides-soignants depuis le 1er juin 21
qui est énorme à savoir que
les lits qui ont été fermés l'été
pour permettre aux agents de partir en
vacances n'ont pas pu être ouvre ouvert
ses syndicats et collectifs ils pointent
deux choses dans ces auditions déjà la
tarification à l'acte 1 vous venez aussi
de l'évoquer à la t2a comme on dit
également long dame ses recettes
objectifs qui étaient fixés et qui
existe depuis les années 90 ça aussi
c'est une contrainte pour ces
établissements pourraient être y revenir
et côté la représentante du collectif
inter hôpitaux c'est ce collectif qui
était né en 2019 avant même la crise du
coc vide il en résulte une nécessité
d'économies or les économies se font
majoritairement sur le personnel
soignant qui reste la principale
variable d'ajustement
alors que des études scientifiques ont
démontré que la mortalité des patients
augmente dès qu'une infirmière doit
s'occuper de plus de six patients de
jour ou de nuit dans un service
d'hospitalisation standard dans nos
hôpitaux il n'est pas rare qu'une
infirme heures doivent s'occuper de
seize patients en journée voire 24 la
nuit des personnels soignants variable
d'ajustement budgétaire ce sont des
propos qui sont revenus à plusieurs
reprises thomas dans les auditions et la
commission qui a également auditionné
les les présidents de fédérations
d'établissements et alors là c'est
intéressant parce qu'ils ont donné des
précisions sur le manque de soignants
oui on en revient à ce chiffre vous
savez qui a déclenché la commission
denquête qu'elle voit la véracité dans
ces chiffres et bien frédéric valletoux
le président de la fédération des
hôpitaux publics il a parlé plus tôt lui
de 2 6% de lits fermés en moyenne faute
de soignants un chiffre déjà énorme
dit-il lui pendant son audition mais ce
taux il dit aussi qu'il peut monter
encore beaucoup plus dans certains
établissements dans le privé alors là on
parle pas de lits fermés le représentant
des hôpitaux privés parle plutôt de 10%
d'infirmières qui manquent à l'appel
mais il tient à nuancer ces chiffres sur
le manque de personnel écoutez la mine
gharbi
pas les mêmes tensions ne fut jamais
nous manque 10 % des infirmiers donc
qu'est-ce qui se passe on essaye d'être
inventif imaginatif et de travailler
quelquefois on est en difficulté et ce
qu'on appelle j'aime pas ce mot mais en
mode dégradé on est obligé mais aucun
patient qu'ils se soient présentés
importe en fait quand même 54% des
chirurgies 39 concerne la cancérologie
aucun patient n'a été refusé aucun aucun
et les chiffons sont la balle à l'ailé
en tout cas c'était les premières
auditions elle continue cette semaine
vous l'avez dit mais en tout cas on voit
déjà qu'une sénatrice pendant ses
auditions a parlé d'un constat lourd
difficile avec des problématiques très
vaste une situation tellement complexe
qu'on ne sait pas par quel bout prendre
la chose en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai
essayé de faire le sénat puisque il a
donc six mois pour travailler autour de
la situation de l'hôpital et du si thème
de santé en général puisque c'est aussi
là dessus que le vêlage jir le sénat
merci beaucoup merci quentin pour toutes
ces précisions véronique guillotin à
quoi ça sert au delà de voila ca on est
vraiment dans le travail de la
représentation parlementaire c'est c'est
passionnant et c'est aussi de la
pédagogie vis-à-vis de nos
téléspectateurs mais ça peut déboucher
sur quoi des propositions je l'espère
mais moi je voudrais redire quand on
parle de la crise de l'hôpital public
mais c'est la crise d'un système de
santé dans sa globalité l'hôpital public
alors on a parlé de l'hôpital privé je
partage complètement il ya c'est lié à
la halle à la tarification il ya des
services dans certains hôpitaux privés
qui ont énormément d'argent ou en tout
cas qui récupère beaucoup d'argent de la
sécu parce que c'est des ac rémunérateur
une tarification à l'acte alors que des
services par exemple dans l'hôpital
public vont s'occuper de temps en temps
faire les mêmes sacs m'avoir des
patients plus compliqué plus âgés plus
dépendants au lieu de les garder deux
jours ils vont les garder quatre jours
ça va se compliquer derrière c'est une
tarification qui n'est plus du tout
adaptée donc ça c'est une première chose
moi j'ai l'air j'irai aux et aussi aux
hôpitaux privés à but non lucratif sur
certains territoires il ya qu' il n'y a
pas de concurrence neisseria n'y a pas
d'hopital public à côté de certains
expliquent etc ils sont dans la même
situation difficulté aujourd'hui est à
tout ça il faut rajouter la ville il
faut rajouter la ville le lien entre la
ville et l'hôpital parce qu'on a aussi
une crise de la médecine de ville et des
soignants à domicile on veut faire moins
de diminuer en fait la durée
d'hospitalisation mais pour ça il faut
qu'en aval on est les équipes mobilisées
et tout ça c'est une réelle
problématique alors il ya une prime de
tarification moi je pense que c'est un
système aujourd'hui qui doit être vu et
vous l'avez dit le plfss hormis
l'augmentation des dépenses et
l'augmentation des recettes lié à l'as à
la conjoncture de la crise qu vide ce
que l'on peut dire quand même c'est si
on se projette et c'est ce que l'on nous
a montré si on se projette dans quatre
cinq ans on a un déficit encore qui est
structurelle et on paie et on a et on
voit pas en fait de mesures qui pour
corriger ce déficit structurel donc je
pense que le grand ségur qui a été
annoncé nous a annoncé des
revalorisations salariales c'est bien
des reprises de dette de les eaux des
hôpitaux c'est bien de l'investissement
c'est bien mais moi mon avis c'est pas
suffisant c'est à dire ces mesures jeu
la parole je voudrais juste me tourner
vers prisca thévenoud une dernière fois
parce que vous vous devez partir dans
dans une minute je rappelle les chiffres
de ducey y aurait la santé 8,2 milliards
de hausses de salaires 19 milliards
d'investissements sur sur dix ans je
reviens à la question de la grande de la
grande réforme est ce que finalement ça
ça pourrait être dans le
le programme d'un candidat d'un futur
candidat emmanuel macron
oui effectivement c'est ce que
j'entendais put alors que le thème de la
santé s'inviter sur la campagne des
présidentielles et c'est fort heureux
c'est nécessaire c'est fondamental au vu
de tous les débats et les échanges que
kylie a sur le plateau depuis tout à
l'heure mais en faire un thème de
campagne
c'est important certes mais en fer en
revanche une action de mandat c'est
fondamental visiblement la plupart des
candidats à gauche comme à droite qui
ont été cités sur le plateau on un jour
était aux manettes d'une façon ou d'une
autre au cours de ces vingt dernières
années et malheureusement eh bien on se
rend compte qu'ils en sont encore
réduits aujourd'hui en faire un thème de
campagne là où emmanuel macro et olivier
l'hérault en ont fait des actions on
pourra dire que ce n'est pas suffisant
ce n'est pas assez c'est ça je vous
l'accordé sûrement mais ce n'est qu'un
début il faut continuer on parlait tout
à l'heure justement de venir soulager
d'un point de vue financier les hôpitaux
mais également d'un point de vue humain
et là ça veut dire qu'il s'agit de
recruter je suis d'accord mais pour
recruter vous êtes d'accord avec moi
qu'il faut former et c'est la première
fois qu'on a eu la suppression du
numerus clausus mais qu'on a eu aussi
l'augmentation des places en institut de
formation rien que sur cette année c'est
6000 places en plus pour les instituts
de formation aide soignants et
infirmiers donc encore une fois bien
évidemment il faut que ce sujet s'invite
sur la campagne des présidentielles
mais attention à ne pas faire qu'un
thème de campagne et en faire des
actions comme cela a été le cas au cours
de ces cinq dernières années poursuivant
sur ce qui a été fait sans venir se
griser sur cela mais en poursuivant
l'action est plus que de chercher des
grands mots des grands thèmes regardons
le concret du concret parce que
finalement c'est ce que nos soignants
ont réclamé c'est ce que j'entendais
piotta lors sur le plateau en réalité
merci encore une fois prisca thévenot 2
d
intervenir comme ça en direct dans notre
dans notre émission voilà c'était quand
même important il ya pas mal de
critiques exprimées contre l'action du
gouvernement
donc c'était important d'avoir une voix
de défense de ce bilan je voudrais faire
faire un focus sur l'état de la
situation à l'instant t parce que voilà
il ya pas mal de chiffres liés à la
crise qu vide ça c'est olivier verront
qu'ils disent est un malade toutes les 6
minutes qui entre en réanimation alors
que c'était un malade toutes les 10
minutes la semaine dernière et puis
après on est allé avec qu'ils avaient le
pain c'est là la rédactrice en chef de
l'émission chercher le nombre de
patients que vite qui sont hospitalisés
aujourd'hui on en a près de 14000 dont
2539 en soins critiques ce sont les
chiffres d'hier est donc on a cherché le
pic le pire depuis depuis deux ans et
avril 2020 on était à 32 mille patients
qu'aux vide et plus de 7000 en soins
critiques alors je voudrais bien
comprendre comment vous vous devez de
l'intérieur benjamin aussi parce que là
comme moi moi je vois ces chiffres au
liban on a encore de la marge sauf que
depuis un nombre de lits qui a fermé on
a perdu des soignants des lycées ça
alors il ya on a perdu des soignants des
lits et de la motivation
en vrai il ya la concorde qu'on a connue
pendant la première vague dont je ne
mange pas un peu dans le doubs vous le
raconter dans un livre en premier et
en gros on a nous au départ ça a été une
source d'angoissé avec des patients qui
arrivent et partout on savait pas quoi
faire et des patients intubés mais tout
l'hôpital n'a fait que du covan sur
notre hôpital on avait on a un hôpital
de on va dire 400 lits de médecine sur
les 410 médecine elle avait 250 qui
était qu'il y avait des patients qu'aux
vide et donc on faisait plus que sarah y
avait plus qu'une maladie dans tout
l'hôpital parce que aussi il faut dire
que les chiffres d'avril il était sûr de
région c'était c'est l ile de france et
s est le grand est un don que c'était un
gros gros pic mais c'était vraiment
principalement sur deux régions donc
c'était énorme ce qu'ils avaient à
l'hôpital mais donc
là là et je peux vous dire il ya 3000 m
de 1500 en soins critiques on est proche
de l'offset proche de craquer c'est
alors en fait ce qu'il sait ce qui se
passe ce qui se passe
entre temps il ya eu un départ un nombre
de départs hallucinant d'infirmiers des
soignants et que je voudrais dire à un
air ils partent sans chômage sans rien
ils ont dû gérer la crise pendant deux
ans où tout le monde est au chômage
partiel et ils partent ils ont droit 0-1
parce que quand on travaille dans la
fonction publique et compare on touche
rien du tout et je voulais juste le dire
parce que c'est des gens qu'ils vont qui
sont traumatisés par ce qu'ils ont vécu
qu'ils partent parce qu'ils sont épuisés
mon leur donnant mes jeux pour en
revenir à ce qui se passe c'est que nous
on est passé des équipes de soignants on
avait 22 23 soignants qui était
titulaire à 7 donc qu'est ce que vous
voulez alors bien sûr il ya des bus ont
réussi à maintenir des lits ouverts mais
en fait c'est hyper en confortable on
peut plus faire du dépassement de
fonction il n'y a plus de il ya plus de
il ya plus de personnel on a des
soignants qui sont épuisés quand on
demande à des certains spécialistes qui
disent ben en fait moi j'ai fait du coc
vie pendant cette crise est en fait
maintenant on me donne des chiffres
d'activité on ne donne pas d'argent
parce que j'ai pas été rentable sur mon
activité première est que si ça continue
comme ça vu qu'un projet de fusion entre
trois hôpitaux parce que
l'administration a décidé de fusionner
des activités trois hôpitaux si on fait
moins d'activités que le service c'est
nos services qui va fermer
du coup les gens la logique précédente
continue ça voilà la logique précédente
5 août une appliquer ce qu'ils voulaient
fait du coup me disent je veux pas me
faire avoir je vais pas faire de covin
ils veulent pas prendre les patients les
patients restent aux urgences pendant
une semaine il faut remplacer le
tracteur d'hôpitaux enfin moi ce que
j'entends d'un point de vue tout à fait
profane c'est que vous savez
mauvaise direction de l'hôpital sans
mauvais si vous aussi vous dites c'est
les mouvements de part j'ai acheté on
essaie de regrouper les hôpitaux entre
eux pour faire des économies entre les
donc alléger à acheter c'est lé groupe
hospitalier territorial d'accord alors
quand on est dans le 93 qu'on a des
hôpitaux qui sont à une heure les uns
des autres on a un bassin de dix
millions d'habitants quasiment comme
paris avec dix fois moins d'hôpitaux
odile est née cette fois moins 10 de
réanimation comment etc on dit qu'il
faut les poulets pour encore diminué
pour essayer centralisée qu'il faut les
en fait c'est des décès des doctrines
qui ont lutté pour passer par la grèce
qui essaient des doctrines des
directeurs de j'ai acheté c'est déjà
cédé j'ai des choses qui sont en train
d'être mises en application et donc
forcément les gens par rapport à ça sont
beaucoup plus en difficulté et donc tout
juste pour dire ce que vous voulez pour
les urgences les urgences elle déborde
actuellement on n'a plus un seul
praticien aux urgences donc à pic des
vacataires les patients restent deux à
trois jours aux urgences sans avoir de
nuit d'hospitalisation 20% de nos lits
sont fermés sur l'hôpital nous à titre
personnel je parle de mon hôpital je
vois pas des chiffres nationaux donc on
est dans cette problématique là
effectivement on n'est pas capable de
gérer le flux malades c'est bizarre est
ce qu'on pouvait parce que c'est quand
même compliqué essayons de se mettre un
peu à la place du ministère la santé
confrontés à une crise comme celle là
est ce qu'on pouvait lancer la grande
réforme dont vous parlez seigneur tout
remettre à plat ou en plein milieu de
cette crise sanitaire dire alors d'abord
il ya une crise sanitaire à gérer c'est
pour ça que je dis que le le ségur de la
santé on peut le critiquer mais à ce
moment il fallait bien la passe et s'est
créé sauf que cette crise elle dure plus
que ce que ce à quoi on s'attendait et
donc vous avez les effets d'un
délitement du système hors crise
sanitaire qui équipe qui viennent qui
vit qui continue qui viennent s'ajouter
à sa juste quand même parce que je pense
qu'elle est très sincère la prévenue
était là et quelques échappées noé elle
dit mais elle a l'impression qu'on a mis
le sujet sur la table mais je suis
désolé moi j'ai pas entendu un seul
candidat quel que soit le parti dire il
va falloir vraiment qu'on restructure le
système de santé qu'on réfléchisse à
l'ensemble du modèle donc le sujet n'est
pas sur la table présent dans les
souliers de ce programme il existe bien
mais c'est pas le point central des des
comptes et le dit et on peut pas faire
trente réformes systémiques dans un
quinquennat
si obama il a dit moi mon premier mandat
je n'ai fait qu'une seule réforme
systémique cesser la santé et mon
deuxième mandat j'ai passé l'essentiel
de mon deuxième mandat de défendre mais
c'était extrêmement compliqué de
réformer un système de santé j'ai pas
qui a que ça à faire loin de là enfin
ils ont une crise covin non mais donc
oui mais je viens mon deuxième point
c'est que j'ai l'impression que la même
que le ministre a l'impression d'avoir
déclenché une réforme structurelle mais
je suis désolé dans le système dans le
secteur de la santé il n'y a que des
dépenses supplémentaires nécessaires
comme ça a été dit mais il ya zéro
réformes structurelles qui pour la
plupart ne nécessite aucune dépense
supplémentaire d'accord que les j'ai
acheté la fonctionnement des ars
commente howard eut on voit bien que ce
n'est parce que parce que il n'ya pas de
réflexion globale ou depuis trois ans
nous travaillons une centaine qui a
permis d'arriver à ce livre avec aussi
bien la cgt que des mouvements les plus
libéraux donc on a vu d'abord savez ça
peut pas se faire sans consensus donc
c'est pas une réforme de gauche et pas
de réforme de droite c'est une réforme
systémique pour un nouveau modèle de
santé qui va faire les 50 prochaines
années donc il faut mettre les gens
autour d'une table donc là il ya une
responsabilité politique pour qu'il ya
un débat alors et mais il n'y a pas il
n'ya pas d'abord on est dans un système
de contraintes fort au quatrième set up
dont on ne va pas parler aujourd'hui
mais qui est essentiel que dont on ne
parle plus qu'à la santé publique c'est
à dire travailler sur la population en
bonne santé pour cette espérance de vie
sans incapacité augmente en france vous
savez qu'on a les inégalités sociales de
santé parmi les plus élevés d'europe que
l'on a des résultats de prévention parmi
les plus mauvais d'europe et il n'y a
pas un seul euro supplémentaire depuis
cinq ans mais depuis longtemps qui ont
été dépensés pour ça donc nous perdons
aussi énormément de puissance de
capacité à aller j'ai notamment le poids
qui pèse sur l'hôpital et sur les
soignants en s'occupant des gens bien
portants oui et tout ça c'est une
politique à mettre en veilleuse est-ce
que c'est pas trop tard c'est horrible
ce que je vais dire discuter avec un ami
j'ai senti discuter avec un ami médecin
dans la région nantaise ce qui s'est dit
sur le moment
[Musique]
de partage
c'est le second oui je veux dire on peut
le dire comme ça au détour d'une
conversation à la demie cet art oui cet
art la crise en plus à l'ap a révélé
elle a décuplé le problème de l'hôpital
donc voilà mais moi je suis complètement
d'accord sur le phalanx qu'est-ce
qu'elles allouent qu'est-ce qu'il a
loupé ségur je crois qu'il a loupé
quelque chose de fondamentalement c'est
la décentralisation très sincèrement
c'est à dire qu'on a parlé de beaucoup
de choses et on peut pas dire que rien
n'a été fait moi je soutiens
investissement leur prise de la dette
l'augmentation des salles arrive à tous
les liens le voulez oui c'est mais c'est
pas c'est pas en soi ses pensées une
transformation notre système de santé
c'est des mesures qui est absolument de
rattrapage nécessaire mais on n'est pas
sur une transformation du système de
santé qui aujourd'hui devient
obligatoire et quand on dit système de
santé mois de transformation je pense
qu'il ya également d'un stress
transformation un la décentralisation
est ce que l'état peut tout gérer dans
les régions est ce que les régions
aujourd'hui qui sont des méga régions
non pas lors leur
concentration c'est l'état donc moi je
suis conseiller régional sur des sujets
de santé et on voit bien que la rs on
tend la main dans le grand test on
essaye de travailler c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué parce que c'est une
déconcentration mais c'est pas une
décentralisation donc moi je pense qu'à
la décentralisation qui devrait
s'inviter dans le débat présidentiel
et la deuxième chose c'est la prévention
c'est quand même la prévention
aujourd'hui on a des maladies qui
pourraient être évitable mais est-ce
qu'on est ce qu'on mobilise assez
d'argent sur la prévention banon on en
mobilise pas assez et peut-être et après
j'arrête la table la troisième chose que
l'on pourrait donc là déconcentre la
décentralisation la prévention et c'est
ensuite une question aussi de faire
travailler les gens ensemble de la
gouvernance des systèmes la gouvernance
des hôpitaux l'hôpital c'est s'est bien
débrouillé quand ils ont dû se
débrouiller pendant la quinzaine ce soit
quand on les a laissés qu'on a lâché les
brides qu'on les a laissé travailler il
était dans un marasme pas possible et
ils s'en sont bien sortis ils ont
réorganisé en deux temps trois
mouvements ils ont organisé leur s'il
allait vous donner le mot de la fin
mais je voudrais quand même rappeler ont
à la fois qu'on a parlé de l'hôpital ici
on avait en
duplex le directeur l'hôpital de
valenciennes c'est un peu le contre
exemple en matière de l'administration
il a totalement déléguée aux chefs de
service c'est pouvoir résultat est plus
que 5 % de personnels administratifs au
lieu de
chaque fois c'était en juillet mais
pourquoi on ne fait pas partie est-ce
que vous pour vous c'est un élément
central ça le fait de redonner aux chefs
de service finalement la main je crois
qu'il faut surtout redonné en fait au
fond le rôle d'un hôpital c'est de
drainer une demande territoriale de
patients donc nous notre objectif et moi
c'est pour ça que je suis on a tous un
peu désespérée c'est qu'on voit depuis
depuis la troisième bac on n'est plus
capable de gérer la demande de nos
territoires cirque ont fait des patients
affluent et les médecins se voit le voit
les patients et doivent organiser la
demande enfin l'offre de soins en
fonction de la demande de soins donc les
médecins c'est ce qui manque en bas on
réussit pas à passer ces patients là il
faut monter ça et c'est donc ça devrait
être les médecins qu'ils soient qui
décide ce qui est de faire remonter aux
administrations ce qui est nécessaire
aujourd'hui il ya une direction qui est
effectivement complètement complètement
pyramidale et qui vient de
l'administratif qui sont tout le temps
au qui ont des marqueurs et des
indicateurs je ne sais pas lesquels mais
qui ne sont pas efficients finalement
sur le terrain sur la nécessité du
terrain et on devrait utiliser en fait
en premier lieu la demande des patients
ensuite comment on fait pour les fédérer
auprès de médecins puis après comment on
fait pour les financer au niveau de
l'administration mais ça devrait être
comme ça plutôt que se passer dans ses
rangs termine là dessus merci beaucoup
merci
j'appelle le titre de votre livre majeur
aussi c'est en première ligne alors ici
de l'intérieur c'est chez prisma
l'édition et fédérer bizarre l'autonomie
solide et en santé la seule réforme
possible aux éditions michalon merci à
tous encore encore une fois je vous dis
à demain et puis ne ratez pas demain
matin bonjour chez vous adrien taquet le
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'enfance
et des familles reçues par oriane
d'enseignés votre soirée
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans
audition publique tous les lundis soirs
sur lcp et public sénat emmanuel macron
pas encore candidat évidemment président
sera la télévision mercredi soir pendant
deux heures face à des journalistes
annoncera-t-il sa candidature est ce un
coup d'accélérateur il ne manque plus
que lui de toute façon sur la fiche de
cette présidentielle bousculé par la
candidate valérie pécresse comment
l'affronter qu'elle se rend la
martingale de la macro demies face à
elle en posant la question tout à
l'heure à amélie de montchalin bonsoir
madame la ministre de la transformation
et de la fonction publique merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous pendant une
heure dans une vingtaine de minutes
justement yves thréard reviendra sur ces
questions politiques par ailleurs les
syndicats ça vous concerne évidemment
les syndicats la fonction publique ont
claqué la porte de votre ministère la
semaine dernière après l annonce du gel
du point d'indicé des fonctionnaires
alors que oui l'économie française va
mieux et que l'inflation se profile est
ce une politique juste vous n'avez pas
fait baisser le nombre de fonctionnaires
en cinq ans ce sera votre débat avec les
parlementaires tout à l'heure une
question pour commencer à marseille est
ce que noël se fera se fêtera sous les
poubelles pourquoi j'en parle parce que
les poubelles s'amoncellent depuis
presque quinze jours les syndicats
refusent de passer aux 35 heures au 1er
janvier ils réclament l'abrogation de
votre loi de votre loi ou alors le
report de l'application de cette loi
vous leur dites quoi ce soir
avant de devoir répondre sur le fond de
sujets peut-être dire à nos
téléspectateurs de quoi on parle et
quels sont les enjeux
perdurer dans notre pays depuis
maintenant plus de 20 ans une situation
de grandes inégalités sur le temps de
travail puisque dans certaines
collectivités les agents publics
aujourd'hui travaillent moins de 35
heures et donc le passage aux 35 heures
c'est pour qu'on travaille au moins 35
heures c'est pour moi un enjeu d'égalité
d'équité d'abord entre les salariés du
privé et les agents publics puisque dans
notre pays le temps de travail pour tous
ses 35 heures
c'est aussi un enjeu d'équité et
d'égalité entre les agents publics eux
mêmes qui font les mêmes métiers mais
qui selon la communauté travail ont du
pouvoir d'achat ou un temps de travail
en une organisation du travail
différente ce qui crée et que avait été
vu lors du débat de la loi de 2019 une
inégalité que notre gouvernement a pris
la responsabilité de vouloir résorber
d'accord le principe est posée qu'est ce
que vous dites ce soit en suisse ce que
je dis c'est que ville par ville là où
il y avait un enjeu d'augmentation du
temps de travail des négociations
difficiles et je reconnais qu elles sont
difficiles ont été menées par beaucoup
d'élus courageux de très bonnes volontés
qui ont remis sur la table la question
du temps de travail la question de
l'organisation du travail les enjeux
également de salaire qui peuvent aller
avec l'augmentation du temps de travail
puisque moi je crois au travail qui paye
je vous donne un exemple à montpellier
on va parler de marseille qu'est ce que
vous dites ce soir aux syndicats qui
refusent d'appliquer la loi au 1er
janvier juste ça mais moi c'est pas avec
les syndicats de marseille que j'ai une
négociation moi je suis la ministre avec
la ministre démissionnaire
bien sûr et je dois assurer le fait
qu'ils aient égalité de traitement entre
les agents publics de petites communes
de plus grandes communes entre marseille
montpellier direz vous leur dites vous
vous mettrez dans l'illégalité par
exemple si au 1er janvier on appliquait
pas c'est quoi le sujet s'allonger
l'employeur public qui doit et ça a été
menée avec beaucoup de courage beaucoup
de communes où il y avait également des
écarts très importants c'est un dialogue
social de proximité moi je crois à ce
dialogue social de qualité et je peux
vous témoigner à montpellier par exemple
le maire a à la fois augmenter de long
travail augmenter les primes prix voilà
un temps qui était un temps qui fait
qu'à la fin c'est gagnant pour les
agents gagnent du pouvoir d'achat c'est
gagnant pour la collectivité parce qu'il
ya plus de travail c'est un circuit que
plus efficace vous allez en parler parce
que avec
brigitte boucher que je vous présente
les vous connaissez d'un sens de
l'assemblée nationale estime jourdain on
va parler du cas particulier de paris
encore une fois ma dernière question
journal réponses précises les syndicats
marseille force ouvrière dit on veut
rencontrer quelqu'un du gouvernement qui
nous méprise sur ce sujet vous êtes la
mise et fonctionnaires répondez-leur
vous leur dites non vous réglez ça avec
votre mairie c'est une question de
collectivités locales'' un bras de fer
que vous avez avec monsieur payant ouais
vous dites on s'en lave les mains non
moi je dis qu évidemment je suis
attentive à toutes les situations c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'il ya quelques
semaines j'ai lancé une grande
consultation de ville par ville les
préfets ont fait un suivi pour savoir où
est-ce qu'on était prêt où est-ce qu'ils
avaient encore des difficultés pour
qu'on puisse aussi donnée au maire de
nous des outils pour qu'on puisse
faciliter les négociations
en regardant bien quelles étaient les
leviers possibles et puis ya des
endroits qui m'inquiète notamment la
mairie de paris on est en parler mais
mais pour marseille cela j'ai à dire
c'est la négociation se fait pas avec
moi d'accord elle devrait pas je n'ai
reçu les syndicats d'eau qu'une commune
d'accord je fais en revanche confiance
au dialogue social on peut évidemment et
les services de la préfecture des
bouches du rhône travaille aussi en
partenariat avec les élus pour regarder
toute la palette d'options possibles
pour que ce soit un progrès c'est aussi
une opportunité va pas regarder on n'est
pas un travail des organisations
brigitte boucher paraissait pas avec moi
la loi est posée voilà donc c'est pas
moi c'est pas vous les recevoir mais je
vous crucial de mon sort amélie demont
chelle effectivement c'est le même cas à
paris où les agents de la ville
travaillent 32 heures alors que vous
souhaitez que tout le monde passe aux 35
heures au 1er janvier 2022 il ya un
appel qui a été rejetée donc pour anne
hidalgo aujourd'hui est ce que la mairie
de paris on travaillera 35 heures au 1er
janvier la situation à paris elle est
très différente de celle de marseille ou
d'autres villes où le dialogue social
est en cours mais n'est pas pour
l'instant porteur d'un consensus à la
mairie de paris il n'y a pas eu à ce
stade de volonté de l'employeur public
de la mairie de paris elle même de la
maire de paris de vouloir présenter un
règlement du temps de travail qui soit
conforme à la loi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui la mairie de paris elle a
proposé un règlement de travail que le
préfet le tri l'administratif et
maintenant en appel confirme qu'il n'est
pas légal donc vous pourrez appliquer
votre loi dès le 1er journée et donc moi
c'est très simple la loi doit
s'appliquer pour tous les français que
l'on soit mer que l'on soit français
dans la rue que l'on soit entreprise
l'état de droit c'est le socle de la
démocratie c'est sako la république que
madame hidalgo soit candidate à la
présidentielle c'est une chose mais
qu'elle décide parce qu'elle serait
candidate à la présidentielle de faire
du règlement du temps de travail de la
mairie de paris un outil politique où
elle cherche à gagner du temps à
repousser le moment où elle devra
s'engage un dialogue social comme dans
toutes les autres communes de france
réfléchissons au fait que à paris
travaille cinquante mille agents c'est à
dire autant que dans toutes les
préfectures et sous préfectures de
france moi je crois au travail autres à
qui paye avec lacets et raisons
idéologiques sociale
etc toute candidate de gauche kim nam il
ya le mot qui a pris récemment la ya
quelques semaines la décision
d'augmenter les plus bas salaires y
compris à la mairie de paris c'est moi
madame hidalgo nous dit ces personnes
font un métier difficile c'est vrai ces
personnes y avait une mauvaise c'est
vrai maintenant je pense qu'une bonne
façon les valoriser c'est de les payer
et j'ai dû prendre mes responsabilités
de ministre pour m'assurer notamment que
les salaires soient augmentés à la
mairie de paris où on peut pas dire que
les efforts notamment de salaire était
au maximum de ce qui pourrait être fait
et puis surtout derrière moi je crois
profondément au fait que le dialogue
social c'est au coeur d'une démocratie
sociale en bas et moi si nos amis
notamment chez eux la question des
géants cette france de la leur et bakel
et une majorité qu'elle va changer la
lettonie les gens rient jaune et du face
à la question méritait au 1er janvier
toutes les communes mairie de paris
comprise qui n'ont pas montré de bonne
volonté pour pour vouloir se mettre en
conformité elle est en effet comme c'est
toujours la pratique et bien iront
porter le cas de chacune des communes
devant les tribunaux administratifs et
ce sont les tribunaux qui décide s'il ya
des astreintes si il ya un délai qui est
donnée ces tribunaux qui y mais je
voudrais surtout dire une chose se
présente en combien de communes
aujourd'hui le seul endroit où de
manière très claire une mairie n'a
montré aucune bonne volonté et a
présenté un règlement illégal c'est
paris mais je voudrais dire quelque
chose parce qu'à une fait que news qui
circulent et que je veux ici démonter la
loi 2 19 elle prévoit évidemment des
exceptions sur le temps de travail aux
personnes qui font des tâches pénibles
aux personnes qui travaillent la nuit
aux personnes qui travaillent dans les
égouts et évidemment la loi elle ou une
loi de progrès social simplement ai dit
madame hidalgo nous dit pas ce qui m'est
avis légaux non à paris on nous dit on
il est bruyant tout le monde à paris
travaille dans un environnement pénible
d'abord je pense que c'est pas respecter
les gens qui ont vraiment un métier
pénible évidemment ça montre le peu de
courage des hawks social qui est mené
dans on a compris paris c'est la mairie
qui bloque vous en fait un cas
particulier ailleurs comme à marseille
ce sont les syndicats et vous leur dites
le dialogue social doit primer d'abord
et aboutir évidemment steve question
pouvoir d'achat mais il montchanin un
des mines et la dignité inflation sera
versée à partir d'aujourd'hui 100 euros
pour ceux qui gagnent moins de 2000
euros nets qu'en est il des
fonctionnaires quand est-ce qu'ils vont
la touche et combien de personnes sont
concernées alors évidemment les agents
publics sont concernés quand ils ont une
rémunération mensuelle inférieure à 2000
euros pour les fonctionnaires il y avait
une étape supplémentaire par rapport à
ce qui est le cas des étudiants ou bien
des salariés c'est que c'est de l'argent
public directement versé des agents
publics donc il fallait que le parlement
de manière explicite approuvent cette
dépense c'est maintenant chose faite et
donc l'un des mythes appelation sera
versée en janvier fin janvier enfin en
janvier exactement au moment où les gens
sont bien ils devaient salaires janvier
avec le salaire de janvier pour 2 5
millions d'agents dans notre pays sans
démarche particulière sans démarche
particulière qu'ils soient dans l'état
dans les hôpitaux dans les collectivités
locales et donc toutes ces personnes
comme tous les autres français parce
qu'on a une situation exceptionnelle une
situation qui est hors du contrôle de
notre politique énergétique en
l'occurrence puisque scellier vous savez
au prix de l'énergie en dehors de nos
frontières ce qui d'ailleurs justifie
que à court terme on est cette mesure
d'urgence mais que par ailleurs on est
un plan très ambitieux à la fois de
conversion des véhicules avec
aujourd'hui des millions de français qui
ont pu être accompagnés pour changer de
véhicule deux rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments pour moins dépendre du gaz ou
du fioul quand on chauffe est évidemment
d'un plan de sortie de la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles alors on revient sur 7
tout d inflation qui va tomber donc
d'ici fin janvier pour tout le monde et
puis il ya aussi ce chèque énergie
exceptionnelle pour 6 millions de
français est ce qu'on peut dire que vous
distribuez un peu les cadeaux de noël
tout cela à quelques mois de la
présidentielle
alors je crois pas que ce soit dans cet
esprit là qu'on fasse les choses c'est
un esprit de responsabilité et
d'ailleurs on écoute ce que tous les
économistes tous les experts nous disent
qu'il est essentiel de faire si on veut
réussir la transition écologique pour ne
laisser personne au bord du chemin tous
les économistes je pense à olivier
blanchit pas l'objet du chèque
exceptionnel énergie c'est parce que
c'est parce que les prix flambent oui
mais ce que nous disent tous les
économistes c'est la transition
écologique va créer un renchérissement
de l'énergie fossile c'est d'ailleurs le
but puisque le but c'est qu'on utilise
moins de cette énergie beaucoup plus du
renouvelable pour que cette transition
soit possible et qu'elle débouche pas
d'une crise sociale tous les économies
du monde entier disent qu'il faut
accompagner les plus modestes de manière
continue c'est l'enjeu du chèque énergie
contraire voilà et neerman on aménage ou
alors quand il ya des périodes de pics
les ménages les plus modestes c'est
l'enjeu de l'un des mythes inflation qui
touche toute la classe moyenne et les
plus précaires et les plus frappants que
c'était un cadeau de noël on vous dit
non il faut accompagner les gens a
évidemment à amortir le choc
les pays européens qui ont aujourd'hui
une stratégie coordonnée des européens
font cette mesure il aurait été absurde
que sous prétexte qu'une érection fait
pas mieux que les autres la maison
est utile et efficace soit parce qu'une
élection présidentielle qu on se dirait
on a des bons outils reconnus comme
explications nécessaires excusez nous
nous y ait des élections a pas le faire
parce qu'elles ont le pouvoir d'achat au
delà de cette indemnité inflation vous
avez refusé madame la ministre de
remonter le point d'indicé en indice qui
n'a pas bougé depuis cinquante pourquoi
avez vous refusé de faire remonter ce
point d'avis parce que depuis quatre ans
avec le président le premier ministre
nous avons choisi sur l'enjeu du pouvoir
d'achat des fonctionnaires un chemin qui
est difficile mais qui est payant ce
chemin et si ce que l'on dit c'est sa
priorité il tient d'abord à vouloir
revaloriser les métiers
reléguées et oubliées et dernier
quinquennat je pense aux soignants
chance aux jeunes aux enseignants aux
jeunes chercheurs des métiers qui avait
été mis de côté et qui avaient beaucoup
perdu en attractivité et en pouvoir
d'achat deuxième priorité nous avons
poursuivi s'est résorbé d'eysines
égalité vous aviez dans la situation
telle que nous l'avons trouvée à notre
arrivée des écarts de centaines d'euros
par mois de salaire de gens qui font le
même métier mais ils sont pas dans des
ministères et puis troisièmement et ça
c'est l'enjeu vraiment majeurs d'un
politique nous avons mis en 2022 en
particulier tous nos moyens sur la
revalorisation des bas salaires moi j'ai
pris le choix et c'est un choix
politique assumé de n'ont pas augmenté
tout le monde du même petit pourcentage
le fameux point d'indicé d'un enfant
qu'il ait augmenté c'était une
augmentation de chaque français à zéro
si c'est pour ça en des 0,6 pour faire
aussi bien si j'avais fait ça tous les
agents publics les moins bien rémunérés
ses 5 à 6 euros de plus par mois oui
mais l'un et pas le choix que j'ai fait
ces rattrapages là c'est pas des
augmentations dans les salaires
attendait les en 2022 le 1,2 million
d'agents dits de catégorie c c'est à
dire les moins bien rémunérés vont être
augmenté de 40 à 100 euros par mois
incroyable combien de personnes ça
concerne 1,2 million d'agents publics
qui soit dans les collectivités dans
l'état ou dans les hôpitaux le choix
politique on a fait c'est de dire on va
pas entre guillemets augmenter tout le
monde d'un tout petit pourcentage qui
fera que pour les plus bas salaires
c'est 5 ou 6 euros de plus par mois on
va assumer
c'est vrai que c'est un choix politique
fort un que le levier que nous voulons
mobiliser c'est de revaloriser
significativement 2,40 à 100 euros par
mois les plus bas salaires alors ça
qu'ils sont les fonctionnaires qui sont
pas concernés et qui voit l'inflation se
profilait comme vous ils se disent quoi
on va perdre en pouvoir d'achat en fait
il ya beaucoup de fonctionnaires qui
sont concernés par les autres mesures
que nous avons prises les mesures de
repas toutes les démesures quand vous
augmentez les infirmières et les
aides-soignantes de 10 milliards d'euros
dans le ségur la santé vous toucher les
gens qui sont pas forcément les plus bas
salaires mais ils ont été revalorisés
quand vous revaloriser les jeunes
enseignants ils sont pas dans les plus
bas salaires mais ils sont revalorisés
quand est ce que vous dites quand même
aujourd'hui l'année prochaine et bien il
y aura des des fonctionnaires qui vont
voir leur pouvoir d'achat baisser ce que
ce qui s'est passé
simon ya un enjeu qui n'est pas traitée
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi j'ai aussi
annoncé jeudi qu'il nous fallait
repenser le système de rémunérations
publiques en profondeur et dans sa
totalité c'est que le problème le plus
grave reste c'est moi celui de vous
fixer en particulier c'est qu'on a
beaucoup d'agents publics aujourd'hui
qu'ils n'ont plus de perspective réelle
d'augmentation non pas seulement en 2022
mais en 2022 ou 2023 2004 donc vous
reconnaissez que des fonctionnaires vont
perdre du pouvoir d'achat le jeu ce que
je reconnais c'est que nous avons
aujourd'hui un système qui à bout de
souffle qui ne permet pas de fidéliser
qui ne donne pas de perspectives de
salaires a beaucoup d'agents publics
points à 10 ou bats pour nice ils sont
bloqués et donc aujourd'hui laisse un
message qu'à 30 lisa torres sociabilité
pourquoi rien n'a bougé avant parce
qu'on avait des urgences les urgences de
l'inégalité homme femme les urgences des
métiers oubliés on a fait objectivement
un vrai investissement dans les salaires
des fonctionnaires on a fait ce qui
était urgent à résoudre les inégalités
maintenant si on est lucide et qu'on
regarde leur point d'arrivée apparaître
des années j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
prépare collectivement avec les
employeurs publics avec les organes
syndicales une négociation mais je tiens
à tirer de l'eau chaude vous avez pas
résorber toutes les inégalités il ya
encore un peu plus de 12% entre les
hommes et les femmes alors que c'était
la grande cause du quinquennat c'était
galice sonne si vous regardez où l état
ne montre pas l'exemple c'est un sujet
que je prends je peux vous dire à bras
le corps vraiment avec le tour il ya
encore 12 % des cas si vous regardez à
métier galles les cas inexpliqués
c'est un peu moins de 4% c'est beaucoup
trop c'est pour ça que quand je vous dis
qu'on réserve les inégalités il ya des
choses qui souhaite qu elle il faut
qu'on travaille j'ai d'ailleurs annoncé
qu'on allait faire comme l'index
pénicaud dans le privé un baromètre
ministère par ministère très précis pour
qu'on identifie ou est ce qui est du
rattrapage à faire c'est un échec du
quinquennat quand même sinon sur
l'égalité à la fois salariale qu'en fait
segura santé les professions soignants
c'est la plus grande revalorisation des
femmes d'autres pays parce que c'est 80
% de femmes les 10 milliards d'euros
quand vous calculez le chiffre
d'ailleurs des écarts hommes/femmes en
globalité en moyenne vous verrez que
céder car il aurait été fortement réduit
par ségur il rêve d illégalité à
résorber mais pas seulement parler
aux postes à responsabilités 2020 a été
la première année de l'histoire de notre
république ou avec le président
république et le premier ministre nous
avons réussi à nommer plus de 40% de
femmes dans les nouvelles personnes qui
accédaient original tant mieux ça avance
ici
l'engagement est là on est en pleine
crise sanitaire au cours des dernières
24 heures plus de 40 mille nouveaux cas
de co vides ont été enregistrés le
télétravail est aujourd'hui recommandé
dans les entreprises privées combien de
fonctionnaires sont aujourd'hui
concernés par le télétravail
d'abord tous les fonctionnaires à
l'hôpital quand ils ont des métiers
télétravail à bhl dans les collectivités
dans l'état depuis le 13 juillet dernier
sont couverts par un accord unanime
c'est suffisamment rare pour être
souligné une anim de toutes les organes
syndicales et de tous les employeurs
publics pour qu'ils puissent sur la base
du volontariat travail et un deux ou
trois jours donc oui dont il est
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons proposé
aux différents ministères c'est que
quand les gens on va organiser
l'entracte et travaille sur un ou deux
jours ils puissent en faire trois jours
pour participer à l'effort national de
moins de circulation - n'aura pas
d'obligation un n'y a pas d'obligation
30 mai nous ce qui est intéressant c'est
loyer pendant longtemps j'ai toujours
considéré davos bic était en retard sur
les progrès
l'organisme du travail qu'on était moins
équipées moins préparés moi j'ai voulu
replacer la fonction publique en avance
il y en a combien aujourd'hui ans
qu'elle est très réduit je peux vous
donner un exemple au dans le mystère du
budget hormis sa part exane et 75 à 80 %
des agents qui télétravaillent un deux
ou trois jours et maintenant donc trois
jours dans les préfectures et
sous-préfectures voyage était à la
préfecture d'île de france on est à peu
près à 40% 50% selon les services
d'agents qui télétravaillent au l'année
dernière au pic ou même au début du
printemps 2021 nous avions 75 % des
agents des ministères parisiens nous
avions 50 % des agents dans les
préfectures et sous-préfectures visage
et de le rendre obligatoire ce
télétravail aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur
l'obligation on a un accord qui permet
de faire donc trois jours de télétravail
dans un cadre de dialogue social avec
une à forfait d'ailleurs de 2 5 euros
par jour 220 euros dans l'année pour
prendre en charge les frais qu'engendre
le télétravail à domicile avec justement
des sujets sur l'égalité hommes femmes
parce que le but c'est pas que les
femmes soient tout haut des travail
pendant que les hommes soient tous dans
les réunions en train de prendre des
s'il en est bien d'accord tout ça c'est
à négocier et gère vraiment remis et ça
a été vraiment travail qu'on a pris
vraiment en quelques mois un accord
unanime pour repositionner la fonction
publique comme au fond un moteur du
progrès social dans le monde du travail
dans notre pays
beaucoup d'entreprises privées qui
s'inspirant notre accord pour
l'appliquer dans l'offre reçue avec le
sanitaire et le débat sur la vaccination
obligatoire qui a lieu en europe en
france elle est obligatoire uniquement
pour les soignants est ce qu'il faut
penser à l'élargir aux fonctionnaires
qui sont en contact avec du public il ya
quelques autres professions que les
soignants notamment dans les armées
gendarmes pompiers ont été effectivement
parce qu'ils sont dans des situations à
risque pour eux il ya le risque de
propagation à société mais moi j'ai
aussi une responsabilité de protéger les
agents publics d'une maladie grave qui
peut les emmener en soins critiques qui
peut amener à avoir des séquelles à vie
dans ma première responsabilité c'est
déjà de protéger en tant qu'employeur
les agents qui par leur métier même sont
plus exposés au virus que d'autres et
donc quand on accueille du public on
pourrait imaginer l'art aujourd'hui on a
pris une mesure de réciprocité dans les
lieux où les usagers présente impasse
les agents doivent être soumis à la même
mesure d'avoir un pass and it et
invalides par exemple dans les musées
quand vous présentez un pass en tant que
visiteur la personne qui vous accueille
à elle aussi fait valider son passé ni
d'assas et à mesure de réciprocité dans
des équipements sportifs ça peut être le
cas aussi dans des bibliothèques vous
avez un taux de vaccination donc de
combien danser dans ces institutions ont
fait en somme nasa serait j'ai fait très
peu de cas on a eu très très peu de cas
annoncés des dizaines de cas et qui ont
été traités je crois avec beaucoup
d'humanité et pas la fois la fermeté
aussi mais on a très peu de cas
problématiques ou les agents dû être
mobilisés sur d'autres fonctions ou être
se repositionner sur roues ou parfois
suspendus mais c'est des cas très isolés
à renier ce qui est surtout intéressant
c'est que les agents publics au moment
du début la campagne de vaccination et
notamment cet été on était en fait très
exemplaire dans leur volonté se faire
vacciner tirer un peu le mouvement avant
le que le 12 juillet le président
s'exprime le taux de vaccination des
agents publics était supérieur à celui
la population générale
jean castex qui dit que la vaccination
des enfants est une nécessité alors si
il y à un accord de la haute autorité de
santé d'ici la fin du mois par exemple
est ce que vous vous envisageriez de
faire vacciner vos enfants moi je crois
effectivement d'abord à la science je
crois que la science a fait des progrès
incroyables pour nous protéger d'une
épidémie extrêmement dangereuses et donc
oui à titre personnel mais là je vous
parle comme mère de famille de trois
enfants qui en huit ans 8 ans et 10 ans
deux garçons jumeaux une fille oui je
pense que si le vaccin est autorisée je
ferai confiance à vous de voir et d
santé pour les protéger assuré aussi
qu'ils ne diffusent pas le virus autour
d'eux et leur permettent aux dames en
dessous une scolarité continue et je
pense que mais c'est un choix à la fois
envoyé personnel réfléchi et se serait
pas obligatoire pour look et on a
toujours pensé que ça devait se faire
dans le cas du volontariat vous avez vu
d'ailleurs qu'on l'a ouvert là dès
maintenant pour les trois cent mille
enfants les plus fragiles qui ont des
maladies chroniques qui sont dans des
situations de grande fragilité santé
pour les protéger notre but c'est pas de
l'ancien et max maxi nation notre but
c'est de protéger les français et c'est
de pouvoir au maximum conserver une vie
éducative culturelle sociale la plus
normale possible merci beaucoup j'ai
beau chez c'était au jardin dans un
instant extraire va nous rejoindre et en
attendant je vous présente vincent roux
du figaro live bonsoir vincent merci de
nous avoir rejoints vous avez
sélectionné une question qui intéresse
beaucoup les lecteurs du figaro et que
vous voudriez adressé à amélie de
montchalin vous écoute
bonsoir mais il ment chalain alors c'est
un sujet un petit peu plus léger encore
que les sujets abordés mais c'est un
sujet qui est très commentée par les
lecteurs du figaro également sur les
réseaux sociaux en général c'est la
décision date de la mairie de lyon à
d'avoir banni le foie gras des
réceptions officielles
est ce que vous seriez une
décision vous prendriez pour les
réceptions ministère alors non mais je
vais vous dire pourquoi derrière ce
sujet moi je dis voit autre chose qu'un
sujet de polémique c'est moi je viens
d'une famille d'agriculteurs des
éleveurs alors ils font pas du foie gras
issue plutôt dans le monde de la
production laitière mais derrière le mot
foie gras il n'y a pas qu'un symbole il
n'y a pas il ya surtout une filière et
des hommes et des femmes qu'il faut
vivre leur famille qui ont une tradition
savoir faire qu'ils exportent dans le
monde entier et donc moi personnellement
oui je veux soutenir la production
agricole de qualité française dans mon
ministère on se fournit au maximum en
circuit qu on se fournit chez les
producteurs et moi je pense que cette
souveraineté alimentaire de qualité
c'est à la fois un motif de fierté
tradition mais c'est pas folklorique et
bien-être animal sur beer et rallye ça
la question mais de bien être animal
c'est quoi le sujet c'est de faire
respecter les règles
mon collègue vient de normandie matin
midi et soir sas tâche à ce que dans les
élevages dans les abattoirs partout en
france les règles de ce bon traitement
des animaux soient pleinement respectés
et comme je suis vient d'une famille je
vous dirais les reit gavage on va aimer
un vincent merling de les voir ils
arrivent à
savoir 1 avait fait part des personnes
qui ont un savoir faire une tradition
mais moi je viens d'une famille
d'éleveurs
je peux vous dire qu'un éleveur la chose
qui lui faire réveiller la nuit qui lui
fait avoir des soucis c'est la santé des
animaux dont il s'occupe et donc tout ce
débat prend parfois des allures de
polémique et qui à mon avis ne sont pas
à l'honneur des femmes et des hommes qui
font vivre nos territoires d'un savoir
faire et qu'ils font penser en alsace
depuis des siècles
l'ours qu'elles ont deux récits de
filières économiques rapidement ces
hommes et ces femmes qui lancent des
polémiques vous voulez parler des
écologistes et en particulier des maires
de lyon je parle de ceux mais qui sur
plein de sujets sont dans la caricature
de ce que sont les pratiques agricoles
aujourd'hui et qui parce que parfois et
des abus que nous sanctionnons très
fortement bien embarque toute une
profession qui l a à coeur de faire un
métier en respectant les animaux en
respectant les traditions le
savoir-faire l'excellence merci vincent
on se retrouve tout à l'heure pour une
autre question du figaro lundi yves
thréard éditorialistes lé directeur
adjoint du figaro vous nous avez rejoint
yves c'est à vous bonsoir elisabeth bost
soir bedie de montchalin soir alors les
lits pécresse candidate à l'élection
présidentielle pour le parti des
républicains
et bien et pas contente parce que
mercredi soir elle devait faire une
émission de télévision dans le cadre de
la 4è campagne électorale et le
président de la république d'un
claquement de doigts convoque deux
journalistes d'une chaîne concurrente
pour faire une grande émission qui va
durer quelques 2 heures et donc madame
pécresse a décidé de saisir le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel en disant
mais attendez c'est tout à fait anormal
que le président de la république se
comporte comme ça alors qu'il n'est même
pas encore officiellement candidat et
raison vous avez à dire à madame
pécresse j'ai plein de choses à dire ça
alors que beaucoup de français elles
réclament certains des comptes
d'abord il paraît que madame pécresse
dit que le présent macro est obsédé par
elle même moi je pense c'est plutôt un
verre je pense que madame pécresse et
équipes sont obsédés par le président la
république et en viennent à avoir
objectivement un comportement qui
donnerait l'impression qu'il faudrait
que mal à pékin autorise le président à
s'exprimer devant les français non je
pense que écouter les journalistes aussi
les observateurs qui vous diront que bon
fallu prince quoi le président
d'ailleurs depuis le début de la vème
république a toujours eu je pense que
c'est l'honneur derrière la politique un
échange direct avec les français et je
ne pense pas qu'ils demandent
l'autorisation à quiconque de pouvoir à
tel ou tel moment s'exprimer ensuite moi
je laisserai la période il s'articulait
politique c'est de convaincre par ses
idées et je ne crois pas que madame
pécresse était privé de temps de parole
ni de temps de présence médiatique ni
d'exposition minutie je suis monsieur le
président de la république est ce qu'il
faut instituer des règles qui fasse que
eh bien ces polémiques qui sont je vous
la corde récurrentes à chaque campagne
électorale
c'est ce mois je pense qu'il faudrait
que d'abord les oppositions soit un peu
moins pressés de rentrer dans un match
où au fond c'est l'esprit de revanche et
là on voit bien vous dites ça parce que
vous êtes dans la majorité parce que on
voit bien qu'en plus en l'occurrence la
droite passe son temps à nous dire que
nous tout est légitime que nous étions
depuis qu'à cinq ans et a qu'une envie
c'est de refermer la parenthèse de ce
qu'a été ce quinquennat par ailleurs le
président la république il a mené une
action depuis quatre ans je pense que
c'est ta tout à son honneur de rendre
compte aux français et 2 il a fait la
semaine dernière il parle sans arrêt
mais pas de dire qu'aucune personne à
l'opposition aucun candidat à présent
c'est même musée dans votre pays est ce
qu'on doit en que le président s'exprime
ça me paraissent lourds on doit défendre
les ce temps de parole qui va prendre
sur potentiellement ce qui pourrait être
son temps de parole alors qu'il va
rentrer en campagne prochainement et on
a une autorité indépendante qui est
chargé va décider avec des on a dans
notre pays il faut arrêter de faire des
fausses polémiques on a une autorité
indépendante qui est chargé de s'assurer
d'une blague bonne auriez dû débarquer
quand le président marc et puis si cette
autorité dit dans quelques jours le
temps pris par monsieur jeu sera comptée
comme du temps de campagne politique
s'il se déclare quand jusqu'à nouvel
ordre quand le président marc dewitte
parle aux français on décompte pas le
temps du président réduit qui parlent le
français on décompte pas le temps que le
président de la république passe sur le
terrain quand il va à vierzon quand il
va à vichy échanges avec les français
ont des comptes pas ce qui fait pour moi
les types et l'honneur de la politique
rendez compte que ce que vous dites là
ça veut dire qu'il pourrait se déclarer
candidat l'avant-veille du scrutin
oui d'accord biais des règles notre pays
qui est des cons de il ya des règles il
ya des comptes de temps il ya un
président qui dit j'ai une action je
veux pouvoir échanger je veux pouvoir en
rendre compte je bois me mets devant les
français quand le général de gaulle
depuis le début la saga de madame non et
qu'on fait après ce but 1965 et les
choses ont changé les comptes mais on
considérait comme c'est le rôle qui a
des règles lycée qui piquent quelques a
fini son apprentissage si on suit votre
raisonnement
vous en êtes à peut-être me faire dire
que ce serait antidémocratique le
président république s'exprime devant
les français donc vous savez très bien
que je lui aie appelle vous inquiète
madame pécresse finalement non et moi je
suis alors pas du tout l'enjeu c'est pas
la peur c'est pas l'inquiétude c'est les
idées moi je peux vous dire que quand je
vois ce que dit madame pécresse quand je
vois que ce discours le président a
donné règle c'est la droite est de
retour oui mais qu'est ce que les
français on à faire que la droite le
retour le sujet c'est noir et pas qu'à
ça si on est dans cet esprit de revanche
qui anime aujourd'hui la droite dans
l'idée que n'ayant rien appris rien
oublié on repart dans les rangs guen de
2017 de françois fillon
2c'est d'esprit je peux d'ailleurs
soutenu alain juppé mais vous étiez
d'ailleurs assez oui mais moi je sais
pourquoi je suis parti en 2016 je suis
partie précisément au moment où cette
vision soit disant libéral soit disant
réformatrice qui voulait d'ailleurs de
manière présentés étaient faire les
réformes dont le sang et les larmes quoi
coûte que coûte moi je préfère le quoi
qu'il en coûte qui s'adapte à la réalité
que le coûte que coûte qui créent de
l'entêtement et on a eu des exemples
d'entêtement politique de gens qui ont
joué justement des coups politiques
n'est pas le brésil c'est les
conservateurs qui se sont pris au jeu le
montrer les muscles et qu'ils en aient
location en france oui mais en france
regardez monsieur raffarin qui est
plutôt assez qui regardent avec beaucoup
d'intérêt monsieur macron qui le qui le
qui le dorlote même danse on va dire
dans son commentaire balla il se pose la
question et je dis tiens bat valérie
pécresse finalement pourquoi pas mais si
mes seins pécresse a décidé que ça peut
à sa petite oasis et femmes sans qui ce
mois gens de venir lequel je vais
choisir le débat d'idées il est légitime
en démocratie mais voyez dans la fausse
polémique essaye d'être là mis sur la
table ce soir du temps de parole ça on a
l'impression que c'est pas une fausse
polémique n'a là et vous allez on ça va
pas tu as l'impression qu'on en vient
vous savez la campagne gens suivent aux
arguments sa voix est une fausse pour
les mains on en revient à la campagne de
françois fillon ou tout ce qui se
passait et et machinations et grand
complot il n'y a pas de complot de
l'origination ya pas de machination ya
parle de fait du prince il ya un débat
d'idées moi je peux vous dire que des
idées demain pécresse cojo combat et je
les combats lesquelles par exemple quand
on nous explique que la seule vision de
l'état de la droite d'aujourd'hui c'est
cette obsession du nombre de
fonctionnaires ont alors demandé ça va
être un débat vous allez avoir des baby
du mal avec les parlementaires enfin seb
à l'idée que l'on puisse maintenant à
coups de référendum un référendum pour
reprendre le contrôle de l'immigration
mais moi je suis pour le fait qu'on
contre l'immigration je suis au
également pour qu'on reste la sécurité
par m il paraît que madame pécresse
référendum vous allez en parler mais
donc est-ce que je pense que si vous
vous allez trouver mon propre aux
attentes id machiste venant de la bouche
d'un homme est-ce que d'être une femme
en 2022 pour une élection présidentielle
ça peut être un atout en france alors
moi je peux vous dire qu'en tant que
femme qui était dans le premier groupe
parlementaire paritaire moi j'ai été wip
vous savez le responsable du budget à la
commission des finances à la première
fois qu'une femme occupe ce poste parce
qu'avant il aurait fallu une dizaine
d'années de mandat pour que on octroie à
cette possibilité à une femme je suis
membre d'un gouvernement paritaire je
suis pas une jupette mais j'ai pas été
de potiche florence parly est pas une
tête de potiche elisabeth borne n'a pas
une tête de potiche moi je crois surtout
que ce qui compte c'est pas savoir si on
a un homme une femme c'est ce qu'on
pense est ce qu'on peut nous reconnaîtra
nous les favoris des potiches non plus
non mais ce qui compte a même dégraissé
ses idées c'est ce qu'elle pense et ce
qu'elle propose le maire jamais les
prêts publics c'est pas pour vous un
symbole de modernité quand même c'est la
modernité c'est dans ce que vous
proposez quand le président de la
république fait de la violence contre
les femmes une priorité il arrive à
faire nommer jeu les 10 pour la première
fois notre histoire plus de 40% de
femmes reposent responsable de vous
entendre et ça me ferait plaisir qu'on a
une présidence avec moi ce qui me ferait
plaisir si on est surtout un ou une
présidente ya un programme moderne
dernier question nous lie le fait que
nous les femmes politiques on n'est pas
là pour le symbole que la modernité
c'est qu'on est des rôles on ne soit pas
l'assurer photo et que mme pécresse soit
une femme c'est une chose maintenant moi
ce qui me contenant la candidature de
madame pécresse sait sont ses idées
alors notre jeu notre dernière question
alors une très courte qu'est ce que vous
pensez de monsieur darmana qui est avec
beaucoup de gens qui dit en parlant de
décret de valérie pécresse elle
peut-être une bonne candidate pour
versailles je ne crois pas que ce soit
une mode candidats pour parler aux
électeurs tourcoing c'est un peu dur ça
quand même un côté un peu des vies de
sale gueule quand même quand madame
pécresse ou de grande bourgeoise i mais
nous dit que son modèle c'est thatcher
et merkel je suis patient effectivement
je peux vous dire que c'est populaire
parce que je suis pas sûr que dans les
quartiers où on cherche à relancer
l'industrie service public je ne sens
pas voir ma référence c'est pas thatcher
je dois dire et je peux vous dire que
c'est pas une question de classe sociale
c'est une question de idéologie
politique et je sais rien à ce sujet à
ce propos monsieur le président de la
république à un film tourné en est
actuellement en hongrie il a filmé
conférence de presse la semaine dernière
sur l'europe est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un argument que de
parler de l'europe dans une campagne
électorale en france alors ou au
contraire un handicap vais vous dire une
chose le président république est le
premier président de la cinquième
république avoir fait de l'europe non
pas un hochet symbolique qu'il fallait
manier aux bonnes occasions a jamais été
ambiguë si la deuxième touche jusqu'à un
destin qui l'a toujours dit je serai sur
l'europe un président qui fera de
l'europe un outil de souveraineté
puissance/poids france auquel il est
fidèle à ses idées et donc il est fidèle
et on va le voir là c'est probablement
garder que l'idée qui lui seraient surgi
d'un seul coup en disant c'est moi
j'étais là ministre des affaires
européennes de ce président c'est un
grand honneur de faire un travail
objectivement parfois très ingrat
d'aller chercher n'est payé faire ni les
idées majorité pour faire avancer ce
qu'on veut c'est là qu'on reconstruit la
puissance première si beaucoup ri
alors merci car ce serait animé est
intéressant on va accueillir tous
parlementaire pour débattre d'un sujet
alors là qui sans doute vous passionne
aussi qui est très intéressant mais
d'abord une question d'actualité amélie
manche en un appel à la grève sncf trois
syndicats sud rail cgt et unsa
entendre débrayer le premier week-end
des vacances 17-18-19 là le descendre
sur les axes sud est où il est beaucoup
de français qui se rendent pour les
vacances de noël mouvement reconductible
pour plus des salaires plus ok la
position du gouvernement la position les
serait évidemment mon collègue me disais
transport voulait détaillé mais on a
réformé la sncf parce que cette
entreprise avait besoin d'être
modernisée de son stade une illusion
mais il le dira le principe même de
cette cet appel à la grève et le droit
de grève il est protégé par la
constitution ensuite excusé moi est ce
que le motif de grève aux rimes est
légitime et ce qu'on a des réponses à
apporter qui soit autre chose que le
bras de fer jean baptiste jebbari vous
répondra sur le fond moi je tiens à vous
dire que c'est pour nous une fierté
d'avoir réformé cette entreprise devait
avoir modernisé et de s'assurer que nous
puissions faire disait l'autre c'est une
jeune médecin vente un bras de fer
choisi le premier week-end et rennes ont
une méthode que dont vous dites bon à
lacets droit de grève après tout ce que
j'ai à dire c'est ensuite est ce que il
ya un dialogue social honnête et
authentique qui se met en place ou
est-ce qu'on est juste dans la posture
et les apparences mais en tant que miss
du gouvernement effectivement respectées
dans la grève mais on va aussi
expliquer aux français ce qui a été fait
dans l'entreprise quelle est la réalité
est que chacun pourra juger ensuite de
ce qui se passe on a plaisir
d'accueillir annie jeanne vardon soit
manager novare députés l ère du doubs
vice présidente de l'assemblée nationale
merci à vous d'être là rémi féraud
sénateur socialiste de paris merci
beaucoup alors votre thème commun c'est
tout de suite vous donner la parole
c'est ce sont les fonctionnaires la
réduction du nombre de fonctionnaires
le programme de valérie pécresse est
très clair sur ce sujet vous n'avez sans
doute pas les mêmes options c'est vous
qui ouvrait le bal madame jeanne var
face à la ministre des fonctionnaires
merci bonsoir madame lamy istres alors
oui effectivement nous pensons qu'il est
indispensable de mieux gérer les
ressources de l'état les ressources
humaines dans la fonction publique
notamment dans les trois domaines qui
sont importants qui sont celui de la
protection d'éducation et du soin et en
effet nous envisageons nous voulons
réduire le nombre d'emplois publics
n'ont pas seulement dans une seule
logique comptable mais parce que
beaucoup s'accordent à considérer
aujourd'hui que notre pays souffre
terriblement d'une sur administration et
en la matière votre action n'a rien
résolu et je pense que nous avons un
état qui étouffe qui étouffe les
français sous le poids des normes qui
étouffe l'initiative française et je
crois qu'en la matière il y a beaucoup à
faire il y a beaucoup à faire et c'est
la raison pour laquelle effectivement
valérie pécresse a le projet non pas de
supprimer des fonctionnaires que madame
deux manches à la se plaît à le dire
comme s'il s'agissait de ma prenez
quelques de supprimer des ddd
il s'agit de diminuer le nombre
d'emplois publics et d'en recréer
ailleurs où il y en a besoin en effet
pour rendre l'état plus agile plus
efficace parce que au fond le problème
c'est qu'il y à beaucoup
d'administrations mais un déficit dans
l'exécutif votre interpellation en fait
vous n'avez rien fait pendant cinq ans
on va alors nous l'a trahi mon
interpellation moi je connais bien
madame de montchanin puisque nous avons
siégé sur les bancs ensemble elle a
beaucoup de tempérament je lui reconnais
bien volontiers mais une
autosatisfaction orgueilleuse et parfois
un brin arrogant et je pense que en la
matière elle devrait s'interroger
sérieusement pour ne pas faire du
maintien du nombre d'emplois publics à
totem absolue d'autant que comme cela a
été rappelé avec malice par yves thréard
en son temps madame de montchanin a
défendu un candidat qui envisageait d'en
supprimer 300 milles donc
voilà
il ya quand même là quelque chose qui
interpelle beaucoup et on se dit marc
aymes de montchalin en changeant de
d'equipe a tourné le dos à une
conviction qui était la chaire alors il
ya beaucoup de questions vous allez
répondre à tout ça je vais répond pour
parfois et rémi féraud
que ce qu'on appelle la droite
aujourd'hui et au moins de l'humilité de
reconnaître que ce qu'elle propose
aujourd'hui quand vous étiez aux
responsabilités sous le quinquennat
nicolas sarkozy est en partie due entre
2010 et 2012 ça a pris le nom cette
réduction du déficit ionnaires qu'il
fallait gpp la rgpp je pense que les
français doivent savoir c'était un échec
cuisant ça affaiblit l'état régalien
pour une famille politique qui se dit
rattache aux enjeux de sécurité réduire
douze mille le nombre de gendarmes et de
policiers dans le pays c'était un échec
ça affaiblit ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
clamez comme étant une priorité absolue
c'est l'état de proximité ça a vidé les
préfectures et sous préfectures
ça a donné moins d'interlocuteurs aux
élus locaux avec qui on a à travailler
et ça a donné beaucoup moins
d'interlocuteurs aux français là où ils
vivre pour que les décisions soient
prises proches et soient prises de
manière efficace et donc moi je suis
avec beaucoup d'honnêteté tout à fait
lucide sur une chose c'est que cette
rgpp en 2010 2012 a créé une un immense
échec c'est une vision comptable aveugle
que aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression qu'on
est dans le recyclage d'un programme qui
était en partie déçus de monsieur fillon
pour donner des gages à un électorat et
que ce n'est plus adaptée à l'état de la
france d'aujourd'hui je peux vous c'est
ce qu'on a fait nous avec le président
république depuis quatre ans on a acté
que parce que nous cherchons de
l'efficacité de la plus grande
simplicité la plus grande proximité nous
avons redéployé massivement des
personnes guide dans les ministères à
paris nous avons redéployé donc sur le
terrain dans les départements redéployés
dans les écoles par les moines clastres
dépouille dans les commissariats
redéployant les tribunaux redéployés
dans les hôpitaux redéployés dans france
services pour que des hommes et des
femmes puissent être accueillis pour
falloir des marges qu'est ce que vous
dites sur la probable nouvelle a été
créée donc moi ce que je dis c'est que
cette vision qui chercheraient dégage un
électorat en répétant la même chose
qu'en 2007 en répétant la même chose
qu'en 2012 sais tu ne réponds pas à ce
qui est pour moi l'objectif comment on a
des services pic et pic alors proche des
français
juste un élément plus nous sommes le
gouvernement grâce au courage du
troisième but qui a fait la réforme de
la haute fonction publique qui a comme
première priorité de sortir une culture
administrative de la norme est de passer
d'une culture administrative de
l'analyse en oeuvre les aux fonctions de
notre pays à médine en salle en salle r
ça que je ne va pas faire
d'annoncé
qui contredit les propos de madame de
montchanin c'est très intéressant elle
parle du nombre de policiers qui
auraient diminué sous nicolas sarkozy
je pense que madame de montchat la a lu
le rapport de la cour des comptes de
novembre 2021 donc il a un mois et qui
atteste qu'en dix ans la masse salariale
des policiers des forces de sécurité a
augmenté de 21% mais que la présence sur
le terrain a baissé de 37% c'est
exactement la situation à laquelle
valérie pécresse veut remédier non pas
pour enlever de la qualité de service
public mais pour un redéploiement
absolument
ce dont elle a montré la dse dont elle a
fait la démonstration à la tête de sa
région comme laurent wauquiez déjà
une minute mais ne l'atteindrait pas une
minute prenant on va voir je regarde
nous avons parce que nous avons
exactement ce sujet de la présence des
policiers sur le terrain ont fait une
priorité dans sur le site du gouverneur
rêve sur le 6 novembre 2020 sur le site
du gouvernement
gouvernement.fr tous les français
peuvent voir dans leur département le
nombre d'heures de patrouilles des
forces de danger d'environnement au
plaidoyer pro domo lancé la transparence
en toute transparence vous pouvez dans
le doubs vous pouvez à paris ou dans
l'essonne voir qu'elle est venue en
raison en faisant seize des mamans un
terme est de voir qu effectivement
c'était très bas et depuis deux ans et
demi ça remonte très fortement parce que
nous avons bien pris le point en
considération que le but ce n'est pas
d'abord des policiers dans les
commissariats et policiers
pas celle qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
perturber un débat interne à la droite
mais finalement aujourd'hui on a le
programme de valérie pécresse en termes
de baisse du nombre de fonctionnaires
qui est à peu près celui en nombre d'
emmanuel macron qui n'a pas mises en
oeuvre puisque vous n'avez pas tout à
fait les mêmes noms mais en tout cas
c'était entêtant et deux grandeurs avec
un timide moi j'invite à se méfier des
promesses préélectorales émet ensuite se
justifie
et ensuite on se justifie de ne pas
avoir diminué
ministère par ministère
notamment là en l'occurrence dans les
ministères régaliens le nombre de
fonctionnaires en réalité la rgpp a été
un moment terrible et aujourd'hui nous
ne sommes pas dix mille policiers et
gendarmes de plus à la fin du
quinquennat comme on s'y était engagé
comme vous y étiez engagé c'est
d'ailleurs sous le quinquennat de
françois hollande que le nombre de
policiers de gendarmes a le plus
augmenté moi je dis attention aux
promesses démagogiques d'avant campagne
sur le nombre de fonctionnaires qu'il
faudrait retirer pour ensuite se
justifier de ne pas avoir sacrifié tel
ou tel ministère mais j'entends bien les
promesses aujourd'hui de valérie
pécresse je ne sais pas quels seront les
promesses que fera emmanuel macron si
les candidats en termes de nombre de
fonctionnaires et de
n'appliquer vous mais vous n'avez pas
appliquer le programme sur lequel
emmanuel macron c'était
je crois ils étaient plus de monde
n'était pas adaptée tout simplement et
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas où est le
gouvernement en termes de fonctions
publiques et on a vu comment vous
traitez durement les fonctionnaires vous
en parliez au début de l'émission sur la
pauvre répond guère différent et ensuite
indigènes 20 tout l'objectif depuis 2007
c'était un état plus efficace et on n'a
jamais fait du nombre de fonctionnaires
une fin en soi on le voyait comme un
moyen de redéployer les forces en
proximité les français ce qui s'est
passé en 4 ans et qu'on a tenu cette
même ligne mais en faisant les plus et
les moins vu les enjeux les besoins en
proximité du fait de la crise sanitaire
des enjeux régalien desanges l'émissaire
la justice du dédoublement des classes
et de beaucoup de poésie que namouh rené
quand nous faisons le bilan nous
assumons que le nom de fonctions de
l'état n'a pas bougé entre 2007 et 2020
de parce qu'une grande différence avec
la proche de la droite c'est que sans
nous renier sur les objectifs les
objectifs réels que nous poursuivons
nous avons accepté d'en faire évoluer
les moyens parce que à chaque fois et
c'est ça que je disais tout à l'heure
quand vous présenter un programme et que
vous entêtez que le monde change ou
qu'ils ne changent pas que vous ne
preniez pas en compte les événements
socio sanitaire économique de notre pays
aujourd'hui on doit réussir la relance
alors qu'elles ont réussi à la lançant
qu'elle est là le sens puisque rémi
féraud on parle du père mois mais promet
là pour pointer programme électoral des
manuels macron pendant vingt-deux 2027
oui est ce que vous vous investirez de
proposer mois en terme de jeu pondent
effectifs des fonctionnaires la proche
qui était la nôtre maintenant de manière
continue parce que on s'est aussi adapté
l'arrêter c'est précisément ça c'est de
considérer que ce qui compte c'est la
qualité des services publics c'est ce
qu'on avait fait un max est de voir si
c'est un objectif quand on vous dit
quand même 120 rue des risées réduire le
nombre de fonctionnaires voudrait des
nouveaux outils de travail je veut
redéployer des français sur le terrain
mais je pense que entrée sur la fonction
bien que par le seul prisme du nombre
sénat prochain les génériques moi j'la
blot excellent qui déshumanise et les
agents et les français qui sont des
usagers quotidiens du service public et
donc moins ma vision c'est comment on
est vraiment plus efficace comment on
est vraiment plus simple comment on est
vraiment plus proche et ensuite que le
nom de fonctionnaires soit une
conséquence mais pas un point d'entrée
idéologique parce qu'on veut donner des
gages à l'électorat et qu'en
l'occurrence il encore quelques instants
je vous invite quand même à relire le
programmes des manuels mamie mais parce
que le fait de vous n'avez pas appliquée
sur la diminution du nombre de
fonctionnaires en allant même logique
que ce qu'on voit à elle qu'est son
programme ne fait pas en soit une politi
je pense que il y a dans cette majorité
à double échec d'abord madame me démange
alain parle beaucoup de la présence sur
les territoires
ça fait trop longtemps que vous n'avez
pas été en contact avec des maires
madame de montchalin parce que les
semaines dans ma fera lité non je peux
vous dire j'aurais même se désespère
parce que tout est parti ils ont ils ont
perdu absolument tout
et pourquoi jacques verges et mai 2010
et je rentre de son mât que ni à défaut
comme il est justement 5000 je dirais
dans les préfectures 2009 double échec
mais elle accueille les français la
matière vous avez une curieuse
conception du débat parce que vous
deviez s'est pas terminé vos
interlocuteurs
deuxième échec et celui là je pense que
un jour il faudra quand même empoigné le
problème vraiment courageux juin moi je
pense que le système au fond qui est
très socialiste pardonnez moi chers
collègues qui considère que le volume le
nombre est là pour résoudre les
problèmes résultat des courses on a un
système très mal traitants on ne paye
pas assez nos fonctionnaires ils sont
notoirement est moins bien payés que
dans les autres pays européens et la
fonction publique n'attire plus regardez
ce qui se passe dans l'éducation
nationale pour qu'on attende ya plus de
candidats est reproché à l'ue la
nomination parce qu'on ne sait c'est le
seul domaine je pense que c'est un
système doublement maltraitant loin des
territoires et finalement maltraitance
socialement pour les fleurs sont
courtes amélie montchalin parce que
l'oignon 21 et 2022 sont les premières
années depuis maintenant quinze ans où
effectivement le nombre de
fonctionnaires interlocuteurs des maires
sur le terrain réaugmente un bon c'est
un choix ne se voient pas très fort et
je suis voile est à venir vous détailler
dans le doubs où sont les espaces francs
service où sont les personnels dans les
préfectures et sous-préfectures comment
réelles personnelles étaient écrits
personnels municipaux avec les
fonctionnaires de l'état non deuxième
élément sur lequel je souriais nous
allons passer tout le début de
l'émission a échangé sur le pouvoir
d'achat des fonctionnaires et j'appelle
et j'ai ouvert la préparation d'une
négociation pour repenser en profondeur
ce système de rémunération qui ne
satisfait plus personne ni la saveur
moins de la fin du caca oui après avoir
par ailleurs revaloriser les salaires
notamment des soignants qui avait été
notamment par les présentes majorité
complètement délaissé mais ce qui
m'intéresse c'est que ce sujet qui est
un bon sujet comment on veut rémunérer
comme on veut attirer comment on veut
rendre notre fusion blick attractif y
compris un phobique territoriales mais
qui en parlent ce soir vous êtes la
première personne de la droite comme on
dit qui me parle de ce sujet et ce
depuis maintenant un an et demi mais
parce que lorsque vous allez en parlons
pas c'est tools et toute la logique de
jeunes évolue votre programme qu'une
seule chose supprimer le statut comme si
ça allait tout résoudre mais gardez les
grands corps parce que cela il fallait
pas y toucher je pense que c'est ça
je sais qu'il restera de votre politique
malades de montchanin c'est la
suppression démagogique de l'ena
je suis fier d'avoir porté une réforme
que jacques chirac voulait faire que
nicolas sarkozy voulait faire que la
droite a porté pendant secret ni ce
qu'ils ont été je me suis fiancé je ne
suis pas sa joie
le président et mon président comme vous
dites il a fait une chose qui est
courageuse c'est qu'il a dit comment la
haute fonction publique peut s'adapter
aux enjeux du 21e siècle par sa
formation vous voulez match aller on
préfère
s'adresser leurs ambassadeurs sont des
métiers essentiels avis votre carte
blanche je connais peu de la sont plutôt
ceux qui n'ont pratiques et de la
jeunesse allez-y dans vous tout s'écrit
saisissez la parole jeunesse ça a été
vraiment la sacrifier depuis depuis un
an et demi sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire le gouvernement a fait
beaucoup d'erreurs des insuffisances
parfois a fait ce qu'il fallait mais
s'il ya vraiment une faute qui a été
commise c'est d'avoir abandonné la
jeunesse à ce point alors que le
président de la république lui même a
dit que la jeunesse était la grande
sacrifiée de la crise économique sociale
déconfinement et l'a totalement
laissée dans la précarité dans la
pauvreté pour un grand nombre de jeunes
refusant la mise en place de tout
dispositif de soutien aux revenus en
dehors d'un moment très triste 150
contrats d'engagement réduit à peau de
chagrin
engagement l'an dernier 250 euros par
mois qui finalement a fait pschitt n'ont
pas été tenues comment pouvez-vous
aujourd'hui assumer d'avoir fait aussi
peu pour les jeunes de ce pays qui se
retrouve dans une telle précarité
parfois dans de telles difficultés et de
ne proposer aucune perspective autre que
quelques contrats d'engagement de plus
lui sont une reprise des dispositifs
existants par le décalage entre ce que
vous dites est la réalité de notre pays
nous avons engagé un plan qui s'appelle
un jeune une solution 3 millions de
jeunes ont été accompagnés par ce plan
2.4 millions de jeunes ont trouvé un cdd
ou un cdi depuis la dernière sortie donc
l'été 2020 nous avons aujourd'hui six
cent mille jeunes en apprentissage dans
notre pays quand nous sommes arrivés aux
affaires nous étions à 280 milles et
vous avez dit si vous arrivez à 300
milles ce sera un succès je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire que ce
gouvernement n'aurait pas réussi à faire
ce qu'aucun gouvernement précédent mais
on a réussi à faire à faire baisser
structurellement le chômage des jeunes
de 4 à 5 points et dans certains
départements nous sommes enfin revenu
sous les 12 % à l'impression d'être vous
en dehors de la réalité et d'andré cela
je traverse je suis toutes les semaines
toutes les semaines sur le terrain avec
les élus avec les associations quand
nous lançons le contrat engagement
jeunes nous prenons par les cornes un
problème qui est là devant nos yeux tous
depuis des années qu'ils s'appellent les
jeunes qui sont sans emploi sans
formation sans stage en anglais on
appelle les knicks ils sont 400 me dans
votre pays c'est quoi la solution c'est
de redonner une allocation à vie ou
celle en donner les clés de leur
autonomie leur formation ce contrat
engagement jeunes c'est des droits et
des devoirs ses 500 euros par mois pour
que ces jeunes qui sont laissés à eux
mêmes qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé la voie
pour s'engager dans une filière qui ce
qui professionnalise aux clients mène
par un emploi puissent être accompagnés
15 15 à 20 heures par semaine soit pour
se former soit pour se soigner parce
qu'il est aussi un enjeu d'addiction
qu'il faut traiter et que nous relais
remettions dans les chemins d'une
autonomie d'un adulte qui trouve sa voie
à léon concret parce que je voudrais
prendre un cce s'est terminée ce alors
que nous avons annoncé les restos u à un
européen et vous les avez abandonné pour
les garder pour les autres cartes
blanches mal car c'est la loi film à
cannes et blanches bien c'est l'autre
terme de la vie ce ne sont pas les
jeunes qui dont le sujet est éminemment
intéressant c'est au contraire les
seniors les personnes âgées vous avez
annoncé triomphalement il ya quelques
mois je me rappelle très bien
l'assemblée nationale nous créons la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
qui sera dédiée à la dépendance vous en
avez fait un slogan pendant dix semaines
on allait voir ce qu'on allait voir et
puis cette réforme a été longuement
préparé vous avez même nommé une
ministre pour sa madame bourguignon et
puis et puis rien mais puis rien et a
aussi quelques mesures quelques mesures
quelques mesures conjoncturelles en
direction de direction des aidants
familiaux mais qu'elle a l'expérience
mais j'estime que il n'y a rien et
c'était pourtant annoncée dans le
programme des manuels macron ça a très
mal commencé le cas kane avec
l'augmentation de la csg des retraités
donc moi je pense que c'est une c'est
une faute parce que on le sait notre
population vieillit et pourquoi avoir si
peu de considération pour quoi ton
annonce est si peu d'action si peu de
résultats si peu de réformes ou font ça
me paraît très emblématique de ce qu'est
de ce corps a été le quinquennat des
manises
président de l'assemblée données
d'observation savez qu'il ya quelques
semaines la revalorisation de 13 à 15%
des personnes qui travaillent à domicile
pour les personnes âgées les essais avec
l'été une pas familiaux les personnes
les assistants de vie sociale vous allez
me parler aussi des éléments familiers
ou
par des femmes et des hommes qui
s'engagent dans les mini très difficile
du soin à domicile nous avons voté un
milliard d'euros pour faciliter la
rénovation des logements des personnes
pour qu'elles puissent rester à domicile
notamment des rénovations dans les
salles de bains qui sont essentiels nous
avons voté 2 milliards d'euros dans le
cadre du ségur la santé pour rénover des
ehpad nous avons résorber des inégalités
entre les départements vous l'avez voter
mal à me peut-être j'espère vous l'avez
voter je sais pas quel était votre vote
pour que dans tous les départements de
france il ya un tarif unique de prise en
charge le 22 euros par heure des heures
que parce ces aidants c'est parce qu'ils
sont parfois des soignants sans cette
forme forcément formés d'ailleurs comme
les soignants au domicile des personnes
âgées est-ce que ça en fait la cinquième
branche ses créanciers union qui certes
n'a pas fait une loi en son nom mais ce
qui a permis à ce qu'elle lui a laissé
toutes ces mesures dans cette cinquième
branche qui était d'ailleurs un projet
de nicolas sarkozy qu'il n'avait pas pu
faire les coqs je tiens là aussi à
ramener les débats dans la réalité est
ce qu'on a tous résolus non est ce qu'on
arrive à recruter assez non est ce qu'il
faut former mieux oui et puis sans
l'avoir annoncée ainsi parce que et
parce que ray et faire les mesures
utiles telles que celles que vous
énoncez que vous énumérez mais crée la
cinquième branche de la sécurité sociale
c'est une autre ambition c'est tout à
fait gagné
la cinquième branche de la sécurité
sociale la grande loi dépendance comme
le revenu d'engagement pour les jeunes
ce sont deux grandes réformes sociales
annoncées par le président de la
république à l'été dernier est abandonné
c'est un résumé assez juste de la bande
ou je vois pas en mettant toutes les
mesures de là vous parlez financés dans
le cadre de ce budget dans le cas de
cinquième manche c'est des centaines de
millions d'euros financés par l'état
parce que je crois comme vous et vous
avez tout à fait raison le souligner
c'est un enjeu majeur comment les
personnes âgées dans notre pays ne sont
pas au fond obligé de se dire qu'elle
reste chez elle tant qu'elles peuvent
dans de mauvaises conditions pour
ensuite aller dans des ehpad wars obligé
d'aller vont de la madrasa d'accord et
ses maisons s'il vous plaît à ce que
vous votez ou alors je sais pas si vous
votez je sais pas si vous avez ôté ses
mesures
de revalorisation des salaires de
soutien à une profession de soutien
invasion c'est plutôt sa question en
fait que j'avais dans ma dame de monchel
vous savez très bien parce que vous êtes
une politique pour voir les budgets on
est dans l'opposition on ne veut pas le
budget ben c'est bien demain de l'accusé
c'est un projet global et vous le savez
bien ne fuyez pas d'ignorer les règles
de base il peut y avoir telle ou telle
mesure favorable mais quand on vote le
budget c'est qu'on approuve globalement
la position la politique du gouvernement
et qu'on appartient la majorité
voulaient voler sans télé réalité vont
se mettre au vert très très vite vincent
alors vous avez 15 secondes pour poser
la question des des lecteurs du figaro
que vous avez relevé ce soir une
question très importante
elisabeth beaucoup de commentaires
autour des débordements observés après
le match maroc-algérie samedi soir
est-ce que amélie dimanche à l'ats ce
sont des simples débordements qu'on a vu
sur les champs-elysées à barbès ou le
symptôme comme le disent lecteurs du
figaro d'un échec de l'intégration et de
l'assimilation ou à la grosse question à
vous avez 35
des actes absolument condamnable sur
lequel la fermeté de l'état est total
je vais d'ailleurs vous signaler qu'il
ya eu des débordements en marge d'autres
matches qui se tenait entre des villes
notamment je crois que c'était nice
marseille et quelques semaines que nous
avons un enjeu majeur de sécurité avant
pendant et après les manifestations
sportives est évidemment dans notre pays
nous sommes en république la loi
s'applique pour tous dans toutes les
circonstances sur les champs elysées
soirs de match ou pas et je tiens
d'ailleurs ici vraiment à remercier
forces de l'ordre qui dans un contexte
objectivement assez compliqué ont
rétabli le calme ont interpellés et ont
donné de leur personne pour que la
sécurité à new voix assurée sur l'avenue
des champs elysées à paris merci vincent
vous avez votre réponse on n'a pas le
temps d'aller plus loin merci beaucoup à
michel jarre rémi féraud d'avoir été ce
soir merci ameline montchanin on se
retrouve le 3 janvier maintenant bonne
fête à tous c'était auditions publiques
sur lcp public sénat restez bien sûr sur
la chaîne parlementaire bonne soirée
[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour un nouveau numéro
ad matin du sénat les missions qui vous
fait vivre les travaux de la haute
assemblée le sénat poursuit sa
commission d' enquête sur la
concentration des médias en france et
les sénateurs ont auditionné la semaine
dernière à les dirigeants de plusieurs
chaînes d'information comme bfm tv lci
et ses news l'occasion de leur demander
sur les journalistes de la rédaction
avait une vraie liberté éditoriale dans
leurs activités je vous laisse écouter
cette audition
aux yeux d'un certain nombre de mes
confrères est journaliste dans ces
groupes plutôt que pour le service
public ou dans des titres à
l'indépendance au blé sans doute moins
pur mais je considère avoir toujours eu
des conditions d'exercice satisfaisante
dans ses différents environnements
avant de répondre à vos questions je
voulais poser trois remarques préalables
sur les sujets qui nous occupe
la première porte sur mon légère
étonnement du format retenu pour
recevoir du choix que vous avez fait de
nous associer tous les trois alors que
nous avons des histoires d offre des
places très différentes pour ses chaînes
au sens de nos groupes respectifs pour
le dire en quelques mots bfmtv emploie
près de 300 journalistes si l'on
additionne les cdi les cdd les pigistes
qui contribuent à la chaîne ce qui fait
de cette rédaction des plus importantes
de france
nous produisons de l'information en
continu
nous produisons des informations
exclusives mais aussi d émission
politique en prime time du reportage des
formats longs et même des séries
documentaires
bfmtv dégage des bénéfices
c'est la chaîne la plus puissante de son
groupe ça ne l'ont pas une chaîne adossé
à un autre ensemble plus solide c'est
une chaîne qui sont plus à proposer une
information fiable consolidé en laissant
place à tous les points de vue et si
j'insiste sur ce point c'est parce que
j'ai pu vérifier 4 une rédaction
bénéficiaires une rédaction nombreuses
une rédaction influente est un élément
fondateur pour travailler dans des
conditions sereines et pour peser dans
les décisions
la deuxième remarque et en sage
[Musique]